[Musique]
he
he he
[Musique]
he
salut à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau live salut Fab salut keV salut
tout le monde donc Fab je vois un peu
les discussions dans le chat alors il y
a plus aucun Français qui peut se
qualifier hein c'est juste pour revenir
B qui il a un bon départage mais
malheureusement là il joue contre un
joueur qui est 2600 et quelques donc son
départage va s'amenuiser et devant il y
a déjà des joueurs qui ont un aussi bon
départage lui voir même très légèrement
meilleur et leur départage à eux au
contraire au cours de cette ronde et la
prochaine vont s'améliorer donc si Baki
finit à 7 et demi en fait il aura pas du
tout le meilleur départage du tournoi
bah parce que là il joue contre des
joueurs qui sont plus faibles on voit
par exemple Nakamura qui joue contre
Fabiano 2780 contre 2786 donc ça te
monte ta moyenne tout ça ouais
exactement et et donc l'un dans l'autre
ça fait que ah tiens intéressant Petrov
cavalier C3 bah n nou dans 10 minutes il
y a plus de la partie la seule partie
qui nous intéresse sera terminée
mesdames et messieurs alors on continue
à regardera on continuera à regarder les
Français bien évidemment mais la seule
partie qui a un impact pour nous
Français sur le classement sur le
classement sera terminé dans moins de 20
minutes ouais alors à moins que enfin il
y a pas de à moins que mais je veux dire
non non il y aura pas d'idée mais que
ikarou essaye un peu et si Fabiano
et si
Fabiano se souvient pas de tout ou quoi
peut-être tu peux jouer longtemps un
truc microscopiquement mieux mais en
tout cas ikarou qui a pas répété la
petov qu'il avait joué hier contre
cheparinov là il a joué k C3 de prendre
E5 et donc on tombe dans cette écossaise
des quatre cavaliers et ce qu'on avait
fait dans le répertoire facile donc en
général c'est des5 ici c'est
extraordinaire quand on a passé des
journées de 6h à regarder des partie
pour que dans l'emballage final la seule
partie qui compte pour le classement se
termine en en 10 minutes quoi enfin ça
me dépasse alors j'en ai j'ai rien
contre les joueurs ils ont raison de
faire ça et c'est leur jeu mais je veux
dire c'est encore une fois on est dans
enfin ça montre l'absurdité
du de tout en fait
ouais donc là je m'attends un petit rock
des noir petit ro des blan et F G4 ouais
mais je crois qu'on ro d'abord ouais ro
ro fou G4 bon tu peux aussi faire ses
prender il y a pas c'est pas la fin du
monde
mais mais ouais bon en gros Naka qui qui
qui veut pas risquer de perdre ou il pas
besoin en faisant nul là il garde ses
chances dans le tournoi et surtout au oo
où il a une énorme avance et il veut
sécuriser sa place au candidat comme ça
sans il a raison enfin en fait c'est
pragmatique et voilà alors pour le
spectacle on préfère un gros combat et
Machin mais en fait si tu te mets la
place du joueur c'est non non mais c'est
c'est enfin 1000 % c'est juste que le
forat est mauvais et donc un mauvais
format crée des mauvais scénarios c'est
tout enfin les joueurs bah tiens il jou
avec ses Pr 5 que les joueurs ils sont
pour rien
il ça ça leur est imposé en fait ce
format ouais on t'impose un format comme
ça ben oui mais c'est comme si
demi-finale de Roland Garos ben tu
arrives 5 minutes après les mecs se
serrent la main enfin bon enfin le sport
n'existerait juste plus mais non mais
mais tu peux pas leur reprocher si c'est
dans leur intérêt à eux deux c'est
normal en fait mais bon créer des
circonstances où en demif enfin c'est
l'équivalent d'une demi-finale en
quelque sorte où l' des joueurs en
demi-finale c'est de jouer c'est de pas
jouer en fait bah tu joues pas ouais
mais c'est un peu étonnant en fait oui
oui je sais non mais ça n'existe nulle
par ailleurs en fait bon on va attendre
voir c'est vraiment ça mais bon oui H3
c'est une petite variante c'est pour
faire dame F3 et qu' ait pas de fou G4
qui viennent de te casser les pieds mais
bon tout ça est bien connu et ne donne
pas d'avantage au blanc mais tu peux
essayer enfin en gros c'est très Simp
comme position avec les Blancs tu as tes
deux hos de pion tu as déjà sorti tes
pièces nous c'est ce qu'on conseillit
mais c'est vra pour le niveau débutant
quoi en fait ah mais c'est très bien
ouis moi j'ai commencé avec cette
ouverture elle est c'est très bien pour
commcer c'est bien pour c'est une très
bonne ouverture pour commencer le
problème c'est pas ça c'est bon pour
faire la différence quand tu es dans les
trois meilleurs
mondiaux normalement c'est pas c'est pas
un jeu aussi simple qui permet de le
faire quoi mais on verra si jamais alors
après Caro en plus je le comprends tout
à fait parce que lui demain il va jouer
contre quelqu'un qui probablement sera
obligé de gagner avec les noirs et il
peut contrer donc il peut se dire toute
façon si je fais nul aujourd'hui je
perds demain c'est pas si grave j'en
perds qu'une sur deux donc je garde de
l'avance au ho donc quelque part je me
sécurise un petit peu de côté là demain
j'ai les Noirs enfin je perds jamais
contre des tels contre qui je vais jouer
donc je suis pas censé perdre en plus le
mec sera obligé de gagner moi clairement
bah lui il est vraiment dans la position
où il dit bah moi nul ça me convient ça
me qualifie et puis il est là et puis
contre il contre si sil peut quoi donc
la gestion de tournoi dicarou est
excellente hein là encore c'est on peut
pas c'est même pas qu'on peut pas lui
reprocher c'est que on aurait pu lui
conseiller cette approche même
exactement ou donc il y a rien a rien à
dire on va voir un peu donc il a bien
joué dame
F3 mais après c'est sûr que pour le
public et pour le sport c'est horrible
mais c'est pas eux qui
ou on leur donne des on leur donne des
règles du jeu il s'adapte hein oui oui
bon s'adapte aux règles
he il s'adapte aux règles mais euh bon
ça va revenir à ce que je racontais à la
Coupe du Monde he le seul but de la
Coupe du Monde c'est de se qualifier
pour les candidats et comme ce tournoi
en fait fa ikarou s'en fout de le gagner
enfin s'il peut le gagner il va préférer
mais c'est 1000 fois plus important de
se qualifier au candidat que de gagner
ça quoi de l'utre côté Fabiano est déjà
qualifié donc on a un joueur qui
participe alors que il devrait pas
pouvoir participer mais en fait on
l'oblige à participer en fait tu as
carrément obligé à faire un truc qu'il
était pas censé faire et voilà on se
retrouve dans un cas un peu spécial he
complètement débile mais bon ben c'est
les échec quoi ouis Fabiano
qui qui est déjà qualifié et mais en
fait le truc c'est que si tu t'inscris à
l'avance c'est ce qu'il faut faire euh
bah tu peux plus dinr mais il Savit pas
qu'il était qualifié donc oui et bon la
fite doit juste dire bon bah tu es
qualifié tu viens pas c'est bon et PRAG
pareil bon incroyable non mais ça fosse
vraiment le en réalité ça fusse
réellement le tournoi là bah oui ça
fosse complètement le tourno disons lui
lui lui il ne le fusse pas en fait il
joue toutes ses parties comme il peut à
fond comme s devait le gagner mais en
tout cas que tu joues Fabiano que tu le
joues pas ça change des choses quoi non
mais ça fausse tout ça fausse tout ça
fausse tout mais c'est un peu triste
dans revenir toujours à la même
conclusion sur la feed c'est même pas la
Fed c'est les échecs hein pour moi c'est
les échecs j'ai pas envie
de de dire la feed je vais te dire
pourquoi c'est que les autres tournois
sont pas mieux faits que celui-là HM
pour moi tu vois s'il y avait la fit qui
organisait des choses un peu bizarres
comme ça et les autres qui étaient des
géis je dirais ah ben ouais les autres
sont géniaux c'est vraiment mauvais mais
franchement quand tu asis le Grand
chestour qui à chaque fois c'est
enfin a toujours des problèmes parce que
leur règlement est mal écrit rien que
sur les départages enfin ou non mais je
sais un moment donné je peux pas dire la
feed FL bibi qui dit Carlson aussi faut
la coupeonde bah oui oui enfin moi j'ai
jamais déf il avait rien à faire là et
comme NPO n'avait rien à faire là mais
mais bon qu'est-ce que je te
dise c'est comme ça hein ça se PL ah
mais on se PL pas en fait hein c'est
juste que ça détruit notre sport un peu
plus chaque année mais qu'est-ce veux
qu'on y fassefin c'est pas on se plin
c'est que Ben le constat c'est que moi
par exemple personnellement j'ai passé
déjà entre les analyses et le truc auamo
déjà 75 heures devant le tournoi HM en
quand tu passes 75 he devant le tournoi
pour avir peut-être là aujourd'hui le
feu d'artifice et tu vois une nul en
enfin je sais pas
c'est mais genre c'est toutes les
conditions étaient réunies pour pour que
ça se passe comme ça après j'espère que
kikaro a une petite idée peut-être qui
sait et qui va réussir à jouer mais mais
c'est pas une question de se plaindre ou
pas c'est
que en plus le truc c'est que c'était
attendu j'ai envie de dire céit attendu
non mais je c'est comme si en
demi-finale de Coupe du Monde tu vois
les mecs qui s'assient sur le terrain
pendant 90 minutes et et qui se
regardent en fin de finance fin la
demi-finale mon il y a même pas de tir
au but ou quoi c'est les deux rentr
vaessère et c'est cool et vous plaignez
de ne pas avoir vu de spectacle ENF ce
serait inacceptable dans n'importe quel
autre sport en fait mais d'ailleurs ça
existe pas ou ça ne peut pas exister ou
je sais pas là tu demi-finales de berc
au tennis Dimitrov
passe je sais pas juste il joue quoi ils
sont assis sur leur chaise pendant 3 He
mer
enfin je pense pas que ça réjouirait les
fans de tennis
hein mais bon mais c'est pour ça que moi
je suis quand même globalement
globalement même enfin dans la dans sa
globalité pour les échecs pour les
format coupe parce que il y a trop de
casre figures dans les tournois où les
deux joueurs ont intérêt à faire nul et
ça pour moi ça doit pas exister en fait
ça arrive vraiment trop souvent bah
d'ailleurs en fait les rares quatre
figures au foot tu as eu des des grands
scandales genre Allemagne Autriche ou
quoi c'est pense les deux doivent faire
nul et qui te font la pass à 10 ou je me
souviens de l'Euro 2004 je pense quand
il y avait su Suède Danemark ouais et
fallait fallait qu' enfin fallait qu'il
a de deux au moins bon ben il de deux
quo mais je te dis pas que c'est enfin
c'est pas sûr qu' Mang le de avant mais
le jour où il y a eu de de et que tout
le monde savait qu'il était qualifié on
va peut-être pas prendre le risque de
perdre 32 quoi au échecs il a quand même
très souvent le cas où la nulle arrange
tout le monde ouais donc voilà et aux
échecs le truc c'est que c'est toujours
dans ce format comme il a quasiment
jamais donc donc au pire tu fais tu fais
de nul en lente et puis tu t'arranges en
enfin tu t'arranges tu t'expliques en
rapide
mais mais voilà quoi
donc donc oui là on va espérer que que
Kikar une petite idé que Fabiano fasse
n'importe quoi
[Musique]
mais bon disons ouais Fabiano il a pas
joué l'avant F G4 qui va mais ou des
fois tu peux avoir un pion de moins ça
peut jouer un moment il a juste ligne là
qui doit aller de mémoire je sais plus
trop mais je peux les regarder pour te
dire TR keV fable le livre où il y a 63
365 anecdotes est génial instructive est
passionnant à lire bah écoute merci à
toi mimounette n'hésite pas à le
recommander très beau cadeau très beau
cadeau de Noël d'ailleur cadeau de
nouvel an il est là cadeau de Noël
cadeau de Nouvel An cadeau de tout
cadeau pour soi cadeau pour
d'autres bien pour caler les tables
aussi si jamais il vous manque quelque
chose cadeau moellon cadeau cadeau échec
cadeau
menuiserie
cadeau maçonnerie
VO cadeau toilette cadeau tout ouais
mais aux toilettes c'est bien aussi en
plus c'est un bon format pour les c'est
pas trop
gros
et du coup toi Mounette tu le lis tout
avance ou tu ouais j'ai l'impression tu
fais pas une page par
jour je veux la patience quoi C porte C
flow H3
6 dame F3
C
tour D1 tour D1
normal en général ils font dame C7 les
noirs ou dame
E7 ils font tout ce qu'ils veulent et la
turbine qu'est-ce qu'elle raconte on va
l'allumer ça va être un beau 00 non ou
pas loin pas loin mais
att 010
euh
bon qui sait peut-être Fabi peut faire
nimp he enfin c'est une ouverture pour
faire nul mais après en fait c'est une
ouverture c'est une ouverture avec zéro
risque pour les blancs et alors si tu
veux la ligne de nul c'est d'ame 7 enfin
sils veulent fou G5 h normal
H6 et là tu peux faire k prend D5 h fou
prend D5 fou F6 fou F3
fou 7 fou D1 fou F8 fou
C2 fou C5
C5 C2 et final pour les blancs mais déjà
eu TR parties TR partie nul et
l'ORD tour D8 non tu vas où tu veux t C8
il est pas mécent ou fou
d4av aussi
[Musique]
TB1 euh et puis tu fais un coup genre
tour C8 tour D8 t ce que tu
veux puis tu ramènes ton ro F8 et cetera
bon ben voilà c'est fot cl reposé et
cetera mais en fait disons avec les
Blancs tu peux jouer ça parce que bah tu
perdras jamais ouais si jamais les Noirs
font les cons bah moment tu pousses un
pion passé tu peux CR créer un petit
problème et puis s joues correctement
bah tu fais nul puis puis c'est comme ça
quoi donc ça pourrait être ça la suite
en tout cas dame 7 le coup qui a déjà
été joué à bon niveau et aussi suggéré
par par la turbine mais il doit
connaître non de toute façon oui oui non
ben en fait en plus de fait de jouer F 6
C5 normalement tu joues C6 avec les
ouais ça c'est le grand coup en fait F 6
donc c'est clairwana il rentre dedans en
bah il fait exprès quoi donc voilà après
même si tu joues pas ça ça doit aller si
tu joues un autre coup mais bon si les
blanc commcent à te faire fou G5 ou quoi
je je pense j'avais gagné une partie
comme ça une foisant pas mal
euh donc les Noirs faut qu'il fasse
enfin attention genre si tu joues juste
normal comme ça tout va bien mais tu
peux pas trop te tromper parce
que parce que en plus le fou B4 si les
Blancs ont le temps de faire cavalier2
il va être hor jeu tu pourras faire C3
pour l'expédier et en fait c de
clairement ce que les Blancs veulent
faire pour rebondir là-bas et créer des
problèmes tuas fou G5 qui peut arriver
qui 2 qui F4 ou qui E2 qui G F5 et donc
tour D1 c'est fait pour éviter C4 puis F
prion et donc dame 7 voilà c'est assez
logique par tu t'enlèves de de de
vis-àis sur la colonne
D déjà fait nul oui bon vu qu'il a perdu
hier il joue vraiment plus pour rien
c'estjà cool qui pas du tourno en fait
je veux
dire les français
Maxime
oui si tu veux tu peux un peu les ici là
déjà mettre les Français lead français
par joue un truc compliqué c'est accept
mais c'est une V che pasaccep tout
basique en fait bizarrement il a un
tellement mon départage que CEMI un
microscopique ça qual vraent
microscopique gag aujourd'hui et que
demain il joue Carana ah un truc comme
ça OK et qui gagne encore il peut avoir
en fait il peut vraiment avoir les
meilleurs à départage des 7p etnemis ok
bon mais c'est très improbable hein si
tenté que CNI suffise mais oui
euh et euh bon normalement YF il est
censé connaître un peu tout ça B déjà
parce que ça fait que cinq coups mais
aussi je veux dire ça fait un moment que
Abdou satf il joue le grandameaccepté
alors je sais pas s'il bossent ensemble
ou quoi les oubcs mais sachant que dans
la même équipe nationale qus ont gagné
Olympiades j'imagine d'avoir des
analyses en commun ils ont dû faire
quand même quelques Blitz ensemble ou
quoi donc donc dehors de trois idé voilà
moi je suis pas expert du truc mais
ligne intéressante c'est quoi ça c'est
Bartel contre firou euh ok alors une
petite nage d'ARF avec Dame des3 tu vois
un petit coup mais Bartel il est connu
hein pourouer des petits machins
PAF
mateou alors euh bon pourquoi avoir joué
comme ça
plus qu'autrement je sais pas ce qu'elle
apporte de si bien cette dame ici mais
ma fois peut-être qu'il va jouer pour k
D5 ou G3 F4 on va voir et Maxime c'est
une Espagnole antiberlinoise non non
c'est pas anti 6 de jouer j'avis pas
fait gaffe mais mais c'est un peu
structure enfin on peut avoir dans la
berlinoise juste le pion sera en a 7 à6
quoi euh ce qui change pas grand-chose
mais ça peut changer de trois petits
détails ici ou là ouais
ok
euh Naka car c'est quand même nak
carwana la partie pour nous la plus
importante au final donc on va rester
dessus
et euh puis au cas où si tu
[Musique]
veux si tu veux jeter un œil à je sais
pas aux autres leaders et parce qu'on a
aussi
euh d Hatch contre vidit on
a voilà on a quelques trucs quoi alors
c'est aussi une n nor non enfin c'est un
f B5 échec quoi d'accord il ouais bon je
je regarde vite fait he tant qu'il y a
rien juste on passe et ça c'est
quoi intéressant
ouais alors n'importe qui gagnerait dans
ces parties là il se met très très bien
évidemment Ker fait faitf il a 6 ou pas
aussi ouais il a 6 et kimer n'a pas ils
ont 6 tous les deux ils ont un point de
retard donc eux bah faut qu'ils gagnent
quoi les uns les autres en cas de nul
ils sont pas chos mais ça commence à
plus avoir trop de chance quoi vraiment
je sais pas quel cas de figure
incroyable il leur faudrait mais et il y
a PRK qui est un peu dans le même cas de
figure contre je sais pas qui pr c'est
aussi partie des gens Arjoun svant
Arjoun c'est pas mal on peut juste
cliquer pour cliquer et prê que pour
voilà on s'attardera pas dessus on ira
voir ce fait partie enfin je crois qu'il
a un méga départage mais il joue kzubof
et donc donc ça lui coûtait en départage
mais donc il faut qu'il gagne il est
obligé de gagner là toute façon il oui
ils ont du retard et C s'il venait à
gagner parce que prê que pous trop ou
quoi je c qu' a vraiment un départage
pourri
ou un peu ouais mais bon ouais ça va pas
jouer à grandchose de toute façon mais
Kub faut qu'il fasse 2 sur
de et donc on va voir voilà donc on a
que des parties importantes en fait pour
tous ces joueurs là c'est un peu la
chance d'une vie c'est un grand mot pas
pour Naka et kwana mais pour beaucoup
des autres dont on parle je crois que
c'est que des joueurs qui n'ont jamais
mis les P candidats à vrai dire que ce
soit PRK que ce soit kubof que ce soit
dech ce soit ici Penko sVAN vidit CER et
cetera donc donc il joue avec une
pression parce que tu vois il y a aussi
des scénario en fait si je dis qu'il y a
un petit scénario ça passe 7 et demi
c'est qu' caroana il peut battre un mec
et tu peux peut-être finir 3è à
ConA soit devant donc tu as un tout
petit monde si tu as un super départage
comme je disais Baky ce sera trop juste
parce que là j'avais regardé le
départage de Baky
hier et c'était vraiment ça me
paraissait vraiment plus possible je je
vais le montrer sous le contrôle de Fab
et me le réouvrir euh c'est une
réminiscence hein mais je me suis dit à
Baki c'est c'est vraiment 100 % mort
quoi euh tu vois parce que son départage
c'est 2699 Fab ouais c'est pas mal mais
ouais mais le truc c'est qu'il joue
contre
26 16 tu V te le baisser un petit peu et
quand tu vois devant par exemple lesp il
a déjà 2694 de PA lui il joue fort il
joue fort al je sais pas à quel point ça
va changer mais le truc c'est que demain
ça va continuer dans cette voi là bah ça
va quand même changer dans le sens où
ici pienco il joue qui non mais je ça
fait 80 points et l' de différence on va
dire 80 points sur une partie mais tu
dois le ça do faire 8 au total oui mais
ce que je dire qu' fait peut-êre qu'il
passe déjà derrière mais ce que je dire
c'est que demain apr ça va continuer
mais même
pour le il a 25 POS de retard sur 28
points mais aujourd'hui joue 27 ça fait
150écart donc divis par 10 ça fait 15
points donc
normalementit demain ça continue demain
il vont continuer à jouer plus fort que
ce que va
jouer alors il a pas joué ça j ok qui
doit être possible je peux les vérifier
je va
regarder le
le
prend C3 bonb prend mais je crois que
j'avais vu que c'était un coup possible
avec l'ordi c'est pas trop ce que les
mecs jouaient
[Musique]
euh alors se lance bon il est pas fan
fan il y a quelques
parties ça va mais donc B
prend ça serait pour enlever la dame
alors d 5 a toujours été jou en pratique
ok alors attends juste la petite
turbinette elle commence à s'affoler un
peu
ouais alors bon mais oui bon enfin bon
je vais te dire ce que dit mon ordi qui
qui est pas con parce que là il nous dit
C4 et fou
F1 plus d'écho tout d'un coup ah ouais
il y a Lena qui nous a enlevé bah nous
enlevé le truc de l'écho quoi enfin euh
C4 DC F
F1
ouais admettons bah
faut jouer un coup je pas jouer à tour 8
je sais
pas alors il a pas joué ça donc au moins
on s'en fiche complètement il a fait fou
G5 bon c'est peut-être le moyen
d'essayer de jouer pour l'avantage mais
tu donnes un pion quand même dame 5 fou
G5
ok c'est ce que tout le monde en
pratique il y a CAV 4 ouais et F prend
tatata et un P de plus mais les f reposé
pion de plus de la merde quoi d'aille
jusqu'à quand euh jusqu'à pas très
longtemps qu et tu peux pas jouer tu
peux jouer d'33 ouais
ouais ça joue finalement euh non non ça
va pas jouer
hein en tout cas à moins tu peux faire
d'AM G3 mais bon je le sens faire dame
PR4 ouais ouais non il va faire dame
prend E4 dame pr c'est quoi la ligne du
coup non mais tu fais dame prend C3 puis
bon je sais pas pe importe quoi non dame
D3 et oui dame prend D3 t prend D3 et
nul F6 les tour mieux
h mais c'est clair
que que kwana c'est
que Nakamura c'est complètement dans son
intérêt oui oui complètement non si par
hasard il obtient un truc jouable sans
risque bah écoute il peut faire mais non
mais il va pas faire he juste mais là je
crois qu'il y aura pas
vraiment la tristesse du jeu quand même
bon on va voir s'il essaie d'AM G3 c'est
qu'il essayotte mais
bon on imagine Caron être apte à tenir
une telle position mais bon c'est que
tuessayes jou F reposé et tuesses ton
foot case noire a posé de TR problèmes
au roi peut-être et F pr tu veux même
pas de problème de structure tu ve
entendre parler de rien du tout ça
dépend de ça dit Mo un
max non
[Musique]
mais ah
ouais
c'est ça ça va faire une belle partie
c'est un truc j'ai jamais joué mais qui
qui qui est intéressant chacun a ses
atouts les blancs la perire de fou ils
ont les pions au centre ou quoi mais les
Noirs c'est deux beau pions et puis le
jour o ils avancent ils te font très mal
donc encore qu'ils avancent Fab oui ah
bah sil avancent pas ils avancent pas
mais il y en a eu un dans le tournoi
notre boom enfin au moins un il y en a
eu d'autres mais y avait Douda qui a eu
les blanc contre Bartel Jam G3 ok donc
il estessot quoi j' envie te dire il
fait pas nul tout de suite ça va pas
faire en 10 minutes parce que d' prier 4
c'était une directe donc si ben écoute
on va voir faut pas que Fabi fasse
n'importe quoi avec les noirs pour pas
perdre mais c'est un peu plus à lui de
faire attention j'ai envie de
dire donc Naga qui joue sans ambition
mais quand même il te dit bon si tu fais
une gaffe enfin il est quand même là
pour prendre la win s'il peut quoi ouais
ouais tu as 95 % de chance de nul 5 % de
Win exactement pour les blancs ouais
alors qu'il aurait pu euh rentrer chez
lui se reposer direct mais il veut quand
même poser de trois questions après il a
peut-être vu que Fabi était quand même
pas super précis sur le tournoi
ouais ouais non mais non mais pourquoi
pas pas super précis pas super précis
par rapport à ce que Fabiano peut faire
quand il est en grande forme on voit
qu'il est pas en super forme mais qu'il
est là quand même mais ça suffit pour
faire mieux que tous nos français réunis
mais
euh mais c'est pas du grand Fabiano
c'est du bon Fabiano ou ça suffit pour
être numéro 2 mondial quoi mais euh
il a gagné un peu
sur sur ses sur ses qualités de combat
sec et son son obligation et tout ça
exactement mais hierarou qui a un petit
peu fait pareil he contre chez parinov
ouais qui a peut-être pas été ultra
ultra précis mais qui fait une bonne
partie qui a posé problème problème
problème puis un moment ça ça collapse
en face niveau défense mais parce que
c'est trop dur de jouer parfait tout le
long et puis avec le temps qui ségraine
la fatigue et cetera et cetera
quoi ikaro on sait jamais il peut la
gagner celle-là avec un beau coup de
ball bah écoute s'il gagne il ferait un
petit coup de main à firou
ou il ferait nos affaires
ouais pourquoi carit pas chercher la
victoire bah en fait le truc c'est qu'il
va en fait s'il fait deux nuls il a 99 %
de chance d'être qualifié via le ho s'il
fait une nulle une défaite peut-être ça
tombe à 80 % j'en sais rien moi et c'est
bête de prendre des risques en fait
ouais en fait je pense qu'il veut bien
gagner sans risque mais mais il veut pas
prendre de risque c'est pas évident aux
échecs de gagner sans rien risquer quand
tu joues tuou kwana quoi
mais mais c'est ce qu'il espère donc en
gros c'est pas qu' veut veut absolument
pas gagner mais c'est qu'il veut pas euh
prendre le risque de perdre vu sa
situation sa situation est trop
confortable pour pouvoir risquer la
défaite exactement mais c'est un peu
comme si je sais pas si je vous compare
ça à une partie d'échec c'est genre vous
avez déjà une pièce de plus bon c'est
bien et puis je sais pas c'est con
d'aller jouer de roposé et tout le
bordel vous pouvez juste jouer normal
vous roquez vous échangez les dames jouz
une finale avec une pièce de plus
vous avez le droit de faire grand rock
mais mais je veux dire pourquoi faire
quoi pourquo jouerti les statistiques ce
que fait ikarou c'est c'est juste après
nous c'est normal aussi qu'on reste sur
cette partie à fond he si vous vous
demandez pourquoi on tourne pas trop
parce que c'est c'est vraiment la seule
partie avec un gros enjeu pour les
Français là oui il y en a pas d'autres
bon regarder firou qui fait de temp en
temps faut pas qu'il perde ou quoi mais
s'il maintient même Maxime par curiosité
ou by ou quoi mais euh mais genre c'est
normal de de bah tiens position de Bak
elle est marrante hein donc
B55 Bou bouf
Bou bouf
ok donc euh
ouais ça va être un peu la structure des
carocanes là enfin tu vois ce que je
veux dire avec K F6 pr f où tu as un roi
très en sécurité a cl les
Noir et euh euh et tu peux bloquer ce
pion passer assez facilement tuasas un
beau fou en D6 peut-être les pions qui
peuvent avancer à roit par tuffblis pas
trop ton roi vu que tu en as quatre
euh ok intéressant intéressant je j'aime
bien pour lui
en évidemment il y a rien de fait mais
l'ouverture m'a pas l'air trop mal se
passer et Bartel c'est bien en rock
opposé ou c'est faible ou c'est
fort je sais pas trop c'est un
combattant bel et il est assez créatif
en général là la position mais je sais
c'est un peu bizarre ce fou F2 D3 comme
comme configuration mais en
fait pourquoi pas surtout s'il a envie
de jouer CAH D5 peut-être
possibleme la case normale pour un
cavalier après il peut peut-être vouloir
essayer F4 F5 alors bon peut-être faire
G3 avant mais ouais D5 ça peut être peut
être une option à voir bon c'est souvent
une option dans cette STR quoi qu'il en
ouiement ça réfléchit côté
Fabiano est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un
arrangement entre genur américain non
mais je pense pas plus que ça enfin je
veux dire je pense pas que
Fabiano sera spécialement content que
kikarou il soit enfin c'est pas un point
Surpat pour les candidats donc s'il y a
un moyen quiik soit pas même ça lui ça
lui fait même plus ses affaires pour les
candidats quelque part don je vois pas
l'aider à se
qualifier donc non il va pas lui donner
la partie en plus je pense qu'il qui
tient peut-être 2008 c'est symbolique il
s'en fout mais tu t'en fous pas tant que
ça ENF tu es heureux quoi donc je le
vois pas du tout enfin ça existe
pas donc non faut pas faut pas croire à
ça si ikarou gagne cette partie il sera
aller la chercher mais c'est pas que que
Fabi lui aura fait un
cadeau il aura pas fait exprès de faire
un cadeau quoi
ok c Viant B c'est cette position sera
compliquée prê de que ça vient que de
commencer
DH en contevidite ça voilà
param il s'est rien passé ça va dans
l'ouverture pour le moment Ker c'est on
est toujours au même point Maxim on est
toujours au même point bcky on est
toujours au même point et Bartel on est
toujours au même point voilà c'est déjà
la pause mais
euh et juste d Hatch c'est quoi alors
fou B5 je j'ai vu que c'était fou B5
mais ok enin
ouais c'est celui-là
ouais estce rest une chance à Maxime de
jouer les les candidats euh non non
ouais non non ce malheureusement
mais c'est comme ça cela il y a même pas
de porte de sortie
quoi il n'y a même pas de porte de
sortie param qui envoy une prépa il a
l'air bon hein il a l'air bon en ce
moment param s'il gagne aujourd'hui il
rentre dans le top 10 mondial ouais on a
peut-être pas le bon iranien mon Fab non
ça fait un moment qu'on se questionne
hein à ce
sujet
param non mais param très bon joueur
très bon joueur qui euh qui
euh jou pour le gain toujours qui qui
est actif
qui
[Musique]
voilà tu as des idées euh
qui beau joueur quoi beau
joueur F qui prend ass 200 K par an avec
son niveau bon avec son niveau tu prends
peut-être plus avec les contrats de
sponsoring et tout j'en sais rien mais
c'est peut-être plutôt dans les 600 700
K après si tu parles en net en France
oui ça doit faire 200 can net mais c'est
déjà pas mal pour jouer quatre tournois
par an quoi non mais non non mais c'est
même pas mal pour pour quoi que ce soit
quoi non mais je sais euh mais là oui
pour pour le peu qu'on le voit c'est
c'est très très très bien même
hein on est en attente Fab
tranquillement dans cette partie kwana
Nakamura h non mais kou en fait je pense
qu' peut être très content de ah ouais
il est bien sorti l'ouverture un peu au
hasard quoi ouais ouais ouais ouais
parce que euh
il a aucun risque et il va mettre une
petite pressionnette cette colonne D il
peut pas la contester Fabiano euh ça va
être le roi de fabino qui va être un
poil plus faible donc c'est petits
détails comme je vous dis normalement ça
se défend c'est bon al mais je juste
dire un petit truc tu vois qu'il a est
et ça c'est un truc que Vlad m'avait dit
tu vois le truc c'est qu'en interview il
dit vouloir se qualifier je pense qu'il
veut le beur à l'argent du beur et
réalise pas que c'est compliqué de faire
mode et échec alors moi c'est un truc
que Vlad m'a expliqué comme il était
beaucoup au contact du haut niveau euh
surtout il y a une dizaine d'années on
va dire il m'a dit en fait tu as
quelques joueurs je donnerai pas nom une
fois encore mais qui disent qu'ils
veulent être champion du monde que
machin que objectif principal
euh c'est que pour les sponsors ils
prendent du fric en fait ils ont pas il
m'a dit tu les VO en privé ils en ont
absolument rien à mais euh et
donc Vlad c'est plutôt des joueurs
russes donc ça a pas de de rapport avec
des gens d'ici mais il dis en ont
absolument rien à mais mais ils
prennent du fric quoi donc il ils vont
toujours te dire en interview oui je
vais être champion ch du monde machin je
travaille énormément pour l'être ou quoi
que ce soit oui après comme ça les
sponsor le filent du fric et puis puis
voilà après tu as jamais intérêt à dire
l'inverse donc en fait si un jouur je
veux être champion du monde machin ou
quoi faut pas forcément le croire mais
après vous pouvez plus j les actes ou
quoi mais ça peut être vrai mais je dire
c'est pas c'est pas parole d'évangile
quoi c'est pas parole
d'évangile
rapport dit qu'il en a rien à
ouais mais lui il a réussi à prendre la
kayas en changeant de nationalité en
plus quoi on s'en foutant quand même on
s'en foutant quand même donc c'est
extraordinaire lui ce qu'il a réussi à
faire je crois qu'il a dû prendre
énormément de fric pour s Chang
nationalitéou mais c'est vrai que lu est
super bête là donc c'est le truc rouain
euh il pas mal de
fricin mais c'est beau ouais ils
organisé une étape du Grand chest tour
ils ont leur équipe bah qui est en Coupe
d'Europe là avec
ais est super en coupe d'e dégueule de
2007 pense enormément de fr et euh bah
il sont sous le capot quoi puis tu as
seenkoenko qui qui a du rouain bon ben
tuas rapporte enfin donc ils ont fait
leur petit mercato les Roumains quoi
donc oui rapporte c'est sûr qu'il s'est
bien il s'est mis bien quoi
mais sans faire de fau semblant sans
faire de ouais Ren à du fr je
vais quand même jouer un peu jouer un
niveau quand même très décent et euh et
donc donc ouais tant mieux hein tant
mieux pour eux
hein est-ce que Maxime pour tenir un
jour championond bah il est pas favori
après tout est possible hein faut pas se
fermer de portes hein bah en fait disons
c'est devenu plus possible qu'avant avec
l'absence de enfin oui Carlsen qui les
joue plus
euh ça reste très très dur mais
évidemment tu as plus de chance quand tu
vas aller jouer un match contre Ding ou
contre peu importe qui sera le suivant
euh si un suivant Ding pourrait très
bien défendre son titre mais voilà ce
genre de joueur que si tu as Magnus qui
a l'expérience des matchs et
qui qui est plus fort quoi qu'il en soit
donc donc il y a toujours une sorte de
chance quoi mais bon faut se qualifier
au candidats faut gagner les candidats
et puis après bah
après ce genre de joueur que tu aurais
en face peut-être tuas 50 50 après
contre eux mais bon donc je c'est un
énorme chemin hyper long mais tu vois on
peut pas te répondre non c'est
impossible terminer il y a plus rien à
voir mais c'est pas c'est pas probable
quoi mais mais c'est pas c'est pas
interdit de de TER sa chance et de se
dire bah qui
sait il a fait H8 ok bah il fallait hein
faut faut enlever comment dire visavis
face à la dame donc c'est le coup normal
et euh peut-être tour D6 là puis tour D1
et essay un truc quoi ou au moins tour
D6
ouais t j'aime bien tu te mets dans le
camp adverse parce que peut-être qu'il a
envie de faire F6 ou quoi un moment mais
mais attendez son toi aussi tu tu l' tu
l' l'interdit quoi
voilà
au moins tu
l'interdit'estce qui se passe les autres
parties là il s'est rien passé là pour
le moment il se passe rien de spécial là
non plus ici bienenko param param qui a
l'air de bien connaître mais c'est
encore en train de se décanter
Ker CER peut être intéressant le pion
qui peut arrive en
E4 qui sait ça peut être une bonne
position pour lui
Maxime blordy kiif VO check mais bon on
sait pas trop pourquoi pas trop pourquoi
en fait il aime pas le fou en
G3 donc c'est à partir de là qui a pas
aimé mais bon Maxime en fait il joue ça
chaque ronde la clé blanc quasiment
ouais euh donc c'est sûr qu'il a
travaillé un peu ce setup et et voilà on
verra après c'est très solide pour les
Noirs ça quoi qu'il en soit il y a cou
fbaki
ok sement que les Blancs aimerait jouer
F F4
débarrasser peut-être de ce fou
des6 et
matou l'idé que j'avais Mo
F4 ok
voir mais
ouais ça joue quoi non mais finalement
bon on pas nul en 20
minutes
on aurait
pu que Fabi a pas forcément joué le truc
le plus ouais le plus fin non enfin le
plus direct avec l'ordi quoi ce qu'il a
joué ça va vra dire mais
ou on va voir une
partie il a joué a
4 ok bon pourquoi pas enfin en fait
c'est vrai que peut-être ce pion à 2 ça
l'embêta
A4 considère pas F6 comme étant une
menace aussi oui non mais c'est pas je F
F4 c'est pas F6 une
menace tu peux avoir envie de le faire
avec les Noirs juste pour consolider un
peu les cases noir pourquoi
pas mais c'est marrant sur F6 fou F4 tu
vas menacer fou C7
quasiment qu'il y a pas de tour des v
pas trop ouais
ouais ou il veut pas trop empêcher enfin
si F6 te gênne pas c'est normal de pas
commencer par tour des6
quoi
bien
gagne il très bien il se met très bien
aussi 99 à 100 donc pour lui c'est quand
même pas pas idiot de faire et et
pu chance
quoi plus que 10 points
d'écart ouais ouais ouais surtout en
embuscade pour se qualifier via les via
les tournois
là c'est c'est ça qui est magnifique en
fait pour se qualifier à rien mais par
la force des choses B si quand même tu
es
là ça
pourrait après tous les trucs sur Calif
et tout les amis c'est pas qu'on veut
pas r répondre c'est qu'on a déjà
répondu peut-être 250 fois là en 10
jours donc expliquer qui qui est
qualifié machin et tout faites un petit
peu des recherches sur de votre côté
parce qu'on peut pas vous faites trois
clics vous trouvez ouais on peut pas
répondre tous les jours 10 fois par jour
quoi bah je comprends que c'est la
première fois que vous demandez hein
ceux qui ceux qui viennent et qui
demandent mais juste à un moment donné
peut pas passer juste tout le live à
répondre à la même question quoi tous
les jours bah après on comprend que le
système est très compliqué et que et
c'est pas simple de suivre surtout que
moi je l'ai expliqué dans la toute
première vidéo que j'ai faite de recap
oui du Grand minut passé 3 minutes à
vraiment tout expliqué donc vraiment
alleer voir la vidéo c'est tout expliqué
en une
fois mais une mais encore une fois c'est
pas contre vous dans le sensù on
comprend tout à fait que c'est pas
facile à de trouver les
informations on a vu des systèmes mieux
faits
ouais surtout il y aurait pu avoir une
page créée où c'est vraiment bien
expliqué visuellement et cetera mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas le
cas pas facile surcupéia fr tout est
expliqué écoute si tu comprends comment
marche
le le la série des points feed tu
m'appelles parce que moi j'ai toujours
pas complètement compris al leors leur
truc ouais tout comme l'éibilité des
tournois àelo c'est un peu la
galère
fait tour8
hein va peut-être faire H4 avec les
blanc
ouais tu as bien envie de l'envoyer tu
peux l'envoyer jusqu'à H6 tu es tu es le
roi du monde il va se faire stopper dans
son élan un moment les noir front H6
même mais peut-être on des idées de
sacrific dessus un jour ou l'autre et
puis peut-être si tu fais H6 F6 tu es un
peu plus faible pous pousse que un des
deux je pense pas spécialement
mais mais donc H4 très bien on peut
songer à tour des6 toujours peut-être ou
pas
réc positionnel des avantagesc de chacun
B en fait il y a pas vraiment
d'inconvénient quoi il y a juste des f
couleur opposé ça favorise un peu
l'attaque c'est les blancs qui ont un
petit peu d'initiative mais en soit sur
un bon jeu ça se voit que c'est égal
après c'est plus au noir de faire
attention parce que F C opposé
favorisant l'attaque l'initiative est
côté blanc donc c'est un peu plus simple
à jouer mais c'est pas beaucoup plus que
ça non et Bahou tu as la dame qui est
mieux dans les
parages voilà quoi
ouais ça se résume un pas ça ce pion E4
finalement qui peut pas on préférait
qu'il soit E5 avec le pion F6 quoi il
vient un peu se mettre sur case blanche
donc il est pas
forcément au
top
il n'est pas forcément au top
ouais tu peux naviller
autour mais bon ça reste très léger
hein très très léger
même il y a du Domingo qui commence à
souffler tu es où hein
Domingo commence à souffler je le vois
pas ben si regarde il écrit Domingo qui
commence à
souffler du coup il doit être en
Bretagne non en vendit
is mais ça il est par là-bas quoi
Domingo à fond hein il va être puissant
ce
Domingo je crois qu'il est puissant
Domingo un peu
comme
par rapport à l'autre la Chara ou je
sais pas quoi Sharan non
sharanaran moins ils
disent et après il y en un troisème ou
ça va ça s'arrête un
jour je crois que sarrête
jamais
plus au sud ils disent
ah mais euh côte là-bas vers Bordeaux ou
La Rochelle ou je sais pas
quoi
Domingo bon streamer par ailleurs
Domingo c'est pas le même c'est Viant va
avoir sa chance c'est incroyable s'
gagnep serait fou de voir un tel que lui
au candidat non ouais mais bon il serait
bien arraché
je sais mais bon un tel que lui quoi là
ce serait vraiment un tel non je dois
dire que par abasof il y a plus de T
quoi çaabas c'est le joueur le plus
faible de l'histoire des candidats je
pense
ou
quoi je crois que même le Wild Card
AVeco c'était plus fort quoi ouais mais
il Luts ah Luts ouais ah ça être un
autre Phat ça do être un truc bizarre
que Luts bon mais Luts c'est ouais ouais
ouais je savais même plus quoi mais
c'était pas parce qu'il jouait Dortmund
et que peut-être un quelque chose non
c'est parce que je crois que les
candidat étaient en Allemagne ouais mais
c'est je comprends bien que CIT un truc
mais bon un tel que lui quoi mais
c'était quoi c'était des des trucs de
match non peut-être mais c'est un tel
oua
ça je fais un petit tour des stades bah
qui est peut-être pas mal
ouais non ça va très bien euh ça va très
bien mais ça va
jouer allez il nous faut du
ikarou ikarou qui joue à tour en
D6
il a bien plu ici he Fab ouais mais je
pense que nous c'est aussi un peu du
Charan non
là ris de Chiran tu veux dire ouais je
pense non peut-être bon après ça fait du
bien des fois un peu la pluie pour pour
arroser recaver un peu pour la
nature mais bon quand tu es tu dis ouais
bon bien marcher dehors sans me faire
mouiller
quoi
c'est beau de se dire ça en fait
March complexe en tout
cas complexe ce
tournoi mais pour moi il va pas aller au
candidat de toute façon vu com il pas
trop je sais pas comment dire quoi ben
je sais pas c his de circuit F là enfin
de ouais c'est hyper bizarre je sais pas
comment so pourrait lui marquer des
points ou je sais pas qui guérit
quelqu'un je sais pas les coefficients à
combien temp enfin donc je j'en sais
rien en fait ça j'ai pas trop la rêve
c'est vrai qu'on risque d'avoir un
plateau un peu bizarre au candidat avec
trois joueurs vraiment dominants carwana
Nakamura et nepomiashi et C joueurs un
peu des des faire valoir quoi que
pragananda bon pas non plus ça a l'air
le plus beau en ce moment des des
qualifiés souugiri s'il passe au au
au au machin au circuit feed c'est pas
mal il devrait pas gagner mais ils sont
ils seront dur à battre et bon tu sais
jamais tu as cette abasof là qui est un
peu bizarre en imaginant par le hlo tuas
firouja mais bon sur la saison on pourra
pas dire que il a impressionné quoi que
ce soit et un autre qualifié via le
grand Suisse mais
là ça peut plus être du gros calibre sur
le grand Suisse qu même tu aurais vidit
qui est peut-être celui qui mérite le
plus ça reste quand même on t'aurait dit
à 2 ans il va avoir vidite au candidat
bon pourquoi pas oui t'impressionne pas
quoi mais tu t'attends pas ce qu'il
gagne les candidats non mais même tu es
pas impressionné non non non mais bon
après il est insté depuis longtemps au
dessus de 2007 c'est pas c'est pas un
plot quoi non mais c'est pas un plot
mais
mais mais non
pas pas top 10 mondial non plus quoi
évidemment mais c'est un gars qui est 30
depuis depuis un moment depuis un bon
moment j'ai du coup j'ai mis
aussi si Naka passe pas par le Suisse et
qui passe à l' au Suisse tu peux avoir
du PL
ou c'est
SEM pas mais euh
ouais parce que si Penko encore c'est
c'est un beau joueur mais c'est vrai que
tu peux avoir des Hatch et il prê de c
quoi là bon ça bah même kimer tu vois
bon il est pas mauvais mais il a jamais
rien fait quoi non il a gagné une fois
un tournoi voilà oui non enfin il en
devenir quoi h c'est pas encore un
joueur établi
euh pas c'est viance aussi quand même to
top non non mais je suis d'accord
championnat des état me la même pas de
gagner c'est enfin je sais pas comment
dire c'est wou il y a même pas ikarou
quoi
mais je pense qu'il ah oui pardon au
championat des
ÉtatsUnis même au championnat des
États-Unis tu sais qu'il va pas
gagner après si il y a pas Ikao il a pas
Fabi il peut non il a encore sa oui oui
mais B sa normalement il comme ça
l'intéresse
pas AR gagner malgré le plateau
incroyable non il y a pas Magnus à la
stinfield il y a par contre il y a de
beau joueurs ah il y a ding qui a
confirmé viik ah bon ok bon ben tant
mieux enfin en fait je suis content si
s'il rejoint un petit peu et bon il
avait confirmé la signe que fil Cup
avant donc bon ouis quand même attend
qu' soit mais bon
apparemment
c'est par qu'il choisit quand même pas
le meilleur endroit parce que va en
début janvier pas
terrible en gros c'est un tourno où vaut
mieux bien jouer sinon la FAB l'ordi
commence à donner plus
1 bon écoute petre que Fabi va faire une
partie absolument
dégueulasse ça peut ouais bah le
problème de H6 c'est que tu commences à
te faire des faiblesses il a même pas
besoin de perdre de temps à faire H4 H5
tu dones ble et du coup en plus tu tu
redéploies le fou vers5 ENF il voulait
quasiment y aller en fait ouais dans ce
qu'on P al sur fou F4 ça veut dire qu'il
veut tour D8 pour moi
ouais c'est tu dis a tu dis B fou E5 et
là il a oublié quoi il a oublié F6 tour
prend E6 tour prend E6 et
C7 pour moi il a raté ça enfin je vois
pas quel est l'autre intérêt de H6 que
de jouer tour D8
h ça cas c'est vu instant donc tour8
fou5 F6 t prend6 puis on prend5 oui bon
ça on va quand même la jouer un petit
peu donc ça peut être une bonne nouvelle
tuis j'ai été mauvaise languef
fare Fabi fait mais bon il a l'air quand
même très erinté Fabiano Carana et là
c'est vrai que ça ça mettrait très très
bien certain
Nakamura bah ouiou par la force des
choses
c'est qui qui va gagner sans le vouloir
quoi
mais il est tellement fortarou ça fait
du bien d'être d'être supporter d'Arou
là pour une fois dans sa vie ça donne
envie d'acheter le costume
ananas ça donne envie d'acheter le
costume
d'ananas ça va faire quasi un mois qu'il
joue nonstop
ouou joue énormément Fabiano
çaon
toute façon ça se voyait déjà dans la
partie contre Baky je l'ai trouvé quand
même Fabiano évidemment très fort parce
que c'est Fabiano mais volontaire mais
dans le jeu il était quand même
tellement au dessous de ce qu'il peut
faire
euh donc je suis pas étonné de le voir
en dessous dans dans cette partie après
c'est le choix d'ouverture d'ikarou tu
dis bon il veut juste faire nul mais bah
il là bah là l'ordi déjà plus 1002 et il
te donne E3 meilleur
couput3 mais en plus je comprends même
pas le délire je pense
que sur F tu doir jouer dame pr C3 et
sur dame PR3 tuir jouer fou F5 mais bon
oui bon don un pionou5 du coup prend H6
sur F6 F6 prend dame prend ro G8 F prend
F6 et dame C7 je moner jusqu'au bout d
F7 et c'est Ciao revoir monsieur écoute
ça peut finir hyper vite
marrant ça pourrait être une des
parties les plus dégueux je sais pas si
on continuera à streamer après jusqu'au
Boutou pas on vous
demandera on a les autres à voir quoi il
y a beaucoup de parties quand même
Fab en tout cas ikarou qui se placerait
royalement bien il aurait besoin d'une
nulle demain simplement pour pour se
qualifier
ouais honorway avit perdu contre un
cavalier G5 dans l'italienne contre iar
mais est-ce que c'est pasaro en fait le
favori des candidats
ouais avecp il quand même fort bah nepo
c'est fort aussi carwana ça va être fort
parce que là il est quand même en
difficulté enfin physiquement c'est sûr
qu'il être un peu dans le dur aprèsarou
vient de jouer l'OP du Qatar mais il
était plus en prépation en préparation
qu'autre chose
ouais
mais est-ce qu'il a pas une chanson
genre IKA
ikarou je crois qu' ça s rendu compte de
sa connerie ouais ouais ouais il est
complètement explosé non mais là une
position
dégueulasse
ça peut faire nos affaires Fab it
canair comme disent les Américains après
faut pas qu'a fasse n'importe quoi il en
est capable quand même aussi de faire
nimp on va se retrouver
avec on va se retrouver avec
qui donc du coup ça nous arrangerait que
Penko
gagne pas quoi en gros perd en fait
pourquoi par que c'est le seul qui a un
meilleur départage kik
Ikar Ikar est-ce qu'il a déjà joué
contrepen pas sûr parce que s'ils ont
pas joué ensemble ça nous arrange au
contraire qui gagne il font nul demain
par alors que param par oua fait
victoire de param victoire
d'Arou on est bien contre
ikarou
que victoire de param après il a un
salale départage il peut se dire je suis
obligé d'encore
gagner non non mais il va pas êtreigé de
gagner tout le
temps tout le temps obligé de gagner en
fait elle a tellement mauvais départage
quand même
par mais ça serait con de perdre et que
personne gagne
derrière
cap surou doit quand même perdre 25 K
est passé derrière rppor bah attention
il y a encore sa il y a encore Guir il a
pas que il y a pas que
rapporte ça que la s f Cup ça va être un
super tournoi à suivre avec beaucoup
d'enjeux C VI eu ils sont ok ils sont
derrière les ils sont derrière ou
B Maxime c'est Mo 11 12
ouais bon je sais pourquoi s'éve mais là
ça commence à se voir quand même parce
que quand tu commences à faire ça que tu
ref fous ton fou que tu reviens en H
fait ça sur que F6 c'est pas du tout un
coup que veulent pas faire oui mais en
fait tu vas faire peut-être après G5 h
ou et F8 qui G6 tout d'un coup tu
l'imession que les blancs ils sont juste
en train de faire fou G5 fou H4 fou G3
fou H4 G3
ou mais bon après il y a peut-être aussi
une une baisse de
tension côté Maxime Fab he il y a quand
même mentalement il faut quand même
l'encaisser ouais tu es déçu enfin mais
bon après le truc je veux dire ok comme
on disait c'était pas mathématiquement
fait mais normalement tu sais assez tôt
que oui mais
une fois il y a une différence entre 0,1
% de chance et Z0 ou surtout qu'à un
moment donné pendant la partie contre
sindarov tu crois quand même un petit
peu et si tu gagnes tu remontes pe-être
à 5 6 % de chance c'est un peu brutal
non non bien sûr mais bon
aprèsf là tu joues plus pour rien enfin
tu es venu pour te qualifier Mach non
mais dire c'est tu as le droit de sécher
qu' et ave cavalier
oui mais tu as le droit de tilter aussif
oui tu fais comme tu env mais si tu te
sens pas de jouer bon tu nul quoi
et MAM BL c'est vrai qu'il a pas du tout
joué ce tournoi mais
non pas trop ce qu'il fait je l'AV vu la
Coupe d'Europe il était là avec mon
[Musique]
équipe une super un gros Championnat du
Monde rapide blit il peut passer VI le
circuit
quand Mme pour Maxim
c'est enfin tu as aucun résultat dans
l'année jusqu'à maintenant en fait
non après si tu si tu gagnes la s f que
tu es champion du monde de rapide et de
Blitz je sais même pas avec les
coefficients si ça suffit mais bon
c'est Maxime il a c'est sur 5 t que ça
se joue il a zéro résultat
ou ou après je sais pas ce que c'est je
sais pas j'ai pasé son parcours mais oui
je l'ai pas vu trop bien placé dans dans
la liste des non non il est il est trop
loin
Maxime après si ça le fait écoute tant
mieux ou après faut gagner rap Blitz
pour peut-être avoir une
chance ouais ben il s'est rendu compte
de sa bêtise oua c'est sûr qu'il voulait
tour des 8
il
et maintenant il
su bon c'est pas encore gagné pour
ikarou mais ah ben écoute tu pouvais pas
être mieux que ça après 20 coup surtout
en ayant joué cette
ouverture Fabi qui craque mentalement
enin physiquement même
plutôt
Maxime il a fait que un un événement qui
enfin il a marqué des point que une fois
dans l'année quoi
c'est pour ça qu'il est si loin au
classement alors ouais parce qu'il a
trop mal
joué il a vraiment pas l'air bien sur la
non mais là la partie de carwana pour le
moment enfin hor théorie c'est 1600 ho
enfin c'est c'est ridicule c'est partie
pédagogique mais déjà de de jouer ça et
pas fou G4 je sais pas ça je sais pas
pourquoi oua pour commencer et après
quand tu joues ça tu vas savoir pourquoi
tu le fais et en fait tu vra dire non
donc c'est il fait il y a même pas de
théorie ça fait n'importe quel 1600 il
connaît HM
ouais en fait je veux dire tu connais
fou B4 machin quoi donc donc là pour
l'instant c'est niveau ridicule là il va
il va rehausser le niveau en fait hein
par que le 1600 a fait tour des V8 il
aurait perdu tout de suite donc là lui
il voit il va pas faire il va te mettre
des barblés tant qu'il peut mais il
s'est déjà foutu dans la sauce tout seul
quoi non mais ça peut pas être un
arrangement entre américain parce que
nak quasi qualifié donc il a pas besoin
d'arrangement mais non c'est Fabi bah
s'il pouvait évincer Naka des candidats
bon enfin il pouvait pas vraiment je
veux dire mais mais au moins VI ici et
puis que il aurait
pas c'est pas un sport d'équipe quoi
c'est c'est un truc individuel où tu
veux être champion du monde
donc et puis je suis pas sûr que ce soit
les meilleurs amis du monde non plus
quoi
pas
sûr est-ce que serait pas l'heure de
faire une pause Fab ah bah si ça fait
déjà très longtemps qu'on est là allez
petite pause les amis on se retrouve
dans une une dizaine de minutes à
toutite à tout
[Musique]
suite
he he
[Musique]
he
alors les amis ne vous inquiétez pas
vous n'avez rien raté et c'est ça le
plus important euh nous on a un peu
calculé d'après nous euh d'après nous
d'après ce qu'on pense on n pas vérifié
la turbine mais serait tout r le coup et
sur dame prend à4 on imagine qu'il a fou
prend H6 puis on prend H6 dam H4 touche
la tour la tour qui doit partir disons
D7 pour s'échanger et dame prend H6 3 G8
tour E3 et mat ou perd matériel colossal
donc il semble que si carou joue tour E1
qui est pas le coup le plus difficile de
l'année la position serait déjà proche
de l'abandon pour carwana et c'est
confirmé par ma turbine euh plus
puissante qui donne carrément
3,30 après tour 1 donc sur tour 1 il va
jouer un coup comme F5 bah ouais mais
ouais ouais mais quand même quoi et
F et dam G6 enfin mais sur tour il peut
quoi faire quoi d'autre ça c'est faut
prend
H6 au pire d' H4 ouais non je monre une
petite ligne ou mais une PARM T
d'autrees
ou et il y a quelqu'un qui a poussé
encore plus loin et qui voit plus 4 10
donc ça pourrait être une partie euh bah
profondeur 35 c'est 336 mais bon un
niveau de jeu là de carwana j'ai même du
mal à lui mettre 2000 Llo quoi ah non
mais on avait 1600 mais je ouais c'est
une partie à 1600 je suis très sérieux
en
fait mais ça fait nos affaires donc on
va pas on va pas se plaindre c'est juste
c'est très étonnant à ce niveau de la
compétition se qualifier au candidat
devoir gagner une partie aussi simple
mais bah voilà c'est comme ça les
joueurs sont fatigués rintés on devrait
même pas être là en fait car en a déjà
parlé mais voilà
bah qu' a épuisé ouais ça c'est
intéressant ça c'est quoi près que il se
passe rien de SP encore là non plus je
regarde s'il y a eu des écarts qui ont
été faits ici bienenko param
j'ai
5 alors je ce qu'il a déjà il a déjà
joué Cararo ici bienenko c'est ça
oui
Ker il essaye une position solide hein
de part et d'autes mais tuas le centre
et les Noirs bon ils sont solides il
espère avir à long terme leur majorité à
dame mais c'est
pas car pourrait jouer fa CF à la
prochaine là il aurait un point de
retard point ouais mais qui qui pe
attends qui peut jouer
Maxime bon ça a pas l'air terrible Baky
by leur dit donne avantage pour Baky on
va Voirin
ouais et matou tiens on va un cavalier
en
D5 bon on verraour compliqué en tout
cas je vais retourner voir le classement
moi pour pour moi entre
guillemets non mais Koo il va plus jouer
des viit des mecs comme ça au cas où des
DCH des machins il font tous nul je veux
dire h après si si Penko gagne euh benah
je sais pas il a jamais joué des Hatch
par exemple carou je pense donc il
pourrait jouer des
hatchou donc il jouera un mec en must
twin
il sera
enn c'est ce qu'on a montré en premier
il et damage 4 si joue je pense abandon
d'ici très rapidement
encore une nulle quand même pour ikarou
demain ça va aller surtout s' joue un
mec qui a gagné genre si par gagne ça
prend pas le chemin mais
Maxime il est pas
bien non par contre ça peut faire nul
qui sont
fous
mais ok aussi jouer et que tu es pas
bien tu as raté tu as raté
mais on va attendre en tout cas
ouais on va voir si si trouve je ser
étonné si trouit pas mais
bon paraî
simplissime
gag faudra encore
qu'ikarou se qualifie c'est qu'il faut
il sera très bien mais faud encore qu'il
perde pas demain on va
dire et que après bah
firou fasse pas n'importe quoi
h
mais il serait très bien tout d'un
coup
dois vérifier tourur hein bah je pense
qu' calcule faut pr H6 direct
déjà d'aller regarder bon tu sens que ça
marche pas de ta fait et que tu es pas
loin et donc tu as bien envie d'inclure
tour 1 pour que ça
marche si aujourd'hui est fait nul
demain il est quasi qualifié
ouais Ikar ah non mais Ikar c'est fini
ou il y a quelques cas mais rarissime
ouis
bon ça va aller en fait il a pas un si
mauvais départage ikarou à vrai dire
puisque là dans les mecs à 6 et demi il
a le deuxème départage et là il prend
encore des points aujourd'hui et il va
ouais encore l'améliorer aujourd'hui il
y a que du prê que en fait qui pourrait
le gêner départage et potentiellement
sindarof ah mais sindarov
nan tout façon ils peuvent plus faire
h donc non en fait s'il gagne
aujourd'hui et qu' fait nul demain c'est
sûr il a trop
d'avance fait que pr que fasse de sur
deux et qui siipienko fasse un et demi
il a
raté c'est
incroyable bon il reste mieux mais c'est
incroyable quand
même c'est incroyable de rater ça quand
même écoute je sais pas ce qu'ils font
dur à dire jou pas à leur niveau ni l'un
ni
l'autre quand même très simple non
ou benah je sais pas on a vu on sait et
ça a été bqué par l'ordi donc gen la
Seale variante qui est challenge c'est
dam prend à 4 mais bon faut prend h
prend h H4 c'est quand même très facile
he c'est fini sur le
CH rien sur toi là je vis pas prendre
des gros risques aujourd'hui mais fait
c'est pas c'est pas risque c'est TR
coups
quoi là pour moi le niveau de la la
partie il est en dessous de dem000éo
hein là c'est ouais là c'est grotesque
ouais c'est pas
beau bon après je comprends ce qu'il
veut faire hein bah tu D prend4 et prend
H6 pu on prend H6 dame dame G5 mais mon
tour c'est le coup naturel et enfin
quand le coup naturel est le bon
c'est con de le
rater
bah il va peut-être pas gagner alors et
nos rêves de candidats vont peut-être
s'envoler
avec sur un tour
raté bon la qualité de la partie elle
est cataclysmique mais c'est beau quand
même ce truc de caps
98.3 tu sais
presque la
perfection donc sur tour à 8 il veut
quoi ça c'est loin c'est lo d'êre gagné
c'est avantage c'est loin d'être terminé
c'est pas la même chose mais tant qu'à
faire pourquoi pas jouer tour D8 en
fait tout à l'HE ça nous fa mais dis
ça tu
souffles ah mais tu souffres
complètement ouais là tu as quasiment
pas de pion de Mos enfin tu as un pion
de Mos mais c'est les de pions
doublés comment c'est possible en fait
on a vraiment pas le Rob bonneur dans ce
tournoi parce que là on était quand même
sur du très très simple Fab
ouais mais en plus pour un gars comme
ikarou qui qui voit tout hyper vite et
non c'est étonnant c'est étonnant je
sais pas trop quoi en dire en fait enin
c'est là c'est vraiment
étonnant là c'est vraiment très
étonnant alors il est éclaté aussi hein
physiquement et que ouais peut-être
personne voit plus rien ouais on l'a dit
il enchaîne les tournois aussi hein donc
c'est pas
facile mais oui mais c'est pas leur
niveau échec là
c'est j'en sais
rien il a eu un compte dangereux non je
pense enfin c'est impossible enfin nous
on sait qu'il y avait pas de contre et
puis en plus il se trouve qu'en fait
tour on l'a trouvé sans ordi
bah c'est le coup tu mets ta tour en jeu
tu atttaques un pion au milieu H6 c'est
un coup que tu peux avoir dès maintenant
disant ti dam H4 j'attaque la tour
j'attaque H6 qu'est-ce que ça donne ça
donne rien là parce que tuas une dame
toute seule qui fait des éch roi donc il
va aller mais dès que tuas une tour qui
vient coulisser en plus qui va venir en
E3 ou E4 bon
bah dam tour contre un ro se bon là
c'est une autre histoire quoi mais
surtout gagner4 tu as vraiment envie bah
déjà hop c'est pris et puis après bah ça
t'offre encore un passage pe pour aller
vers E5 H5 ou bon donc ouais mais
dommage
quoi
complexe bon après il reste bien quand
même il plutôt mieux parce que tous les
avantages dont on parla au début il les
a toujours mais SAF c'était fini et là
tu es juste un peu mieux et sachant que
même si une C5 bon bonne chance pour
gagner quand même
donc donc là il y a rien de fait du tout
du tout du tout du
coup on est pas à l'abri d'une autre
gaffe non non non
oui le
festival
enfin c'est pas très emballant à suivre
une partie longue comme ça c'est
vraiment pas emballant parce que non
seulement c'est long et en plus tu as
pas la qualité de jeu au rendez-vous
donc pourquoi alors tu su
quoi bon Maxim moins bien mais comme tu
disais ça devrait aller by ça a l'air
d'aller firou c'est complexe
ouais donc fou qui a donné un pion mais
pour ouvrir le jeu et les cases blanches
et
cetera c'est chaud c'est chaud c'est
intéressant mais intéressant ce Bartel
comme joueur de toute façon il se cache
pas il vient toujours au combat et il
joue
ouais ça ressemble plus à des parties en
3+ 1 là que qui a des parties longues en
terme de qualité enfin je parle de la
partie
carou carwana et encore même pour du
Blitz ce serait pas exceptionnel
ouais mais là ce serait déjà la 20e
partie qu'on regarderait quoi
normalement HM c'est on reste scotché
là-dessus quoi
c'est c'est à partir du profondeur de 15
coups que Torin est supérieur à Dame 3
c'est n'importe quoi de dire que c'est
du 1600 ho
écoute pense que tu veux que c'est dur
ouais non bon si tu veux en fait mais on
est quand même là pour parler d'échec
ici hein bah ouis c'est bien d'avoir des
gens quand même sérieux
he on est là pour par c'est rien mais en
plus ça va rien dire et en plus le truc
que tu comprends pas c'esten fait les
hommes on calcule avec des schémas en
tête voir en fait des variantes très
longues mais où tout es forcé tu fais
échec tu amènes ta dame échec échec tu
prends ta tour qui vient en fait tu
c'est c'est une vision instante l'ordi
en fait il est capé par sa profondeur
c'estàd si je fais profondeur 1 euh je
peux jouer dame prend C5 en fait là avec
les Blancs parce que je vois pas qu'il y
a dame prend dame je je suis un ordi je
suis bloqué je suis à 1 donc si jeis
prof 2 je le fais pas par contre je peux
faire un autre coup débile mais qui va
aller mais profondeur 15 en fait les
ordis l'ont instant enfin je sais pas
comment te dire moi j'aiallume mon ordi
déjà profondeur 25 en en SA quoi
et enfin je sais pas quoi te dire
c'est bon il y a rien à dire c'est pas
grave ça me fait penser tu sais au truc
sur RMC avec Rolo me qui est supporte de
saintétian et Lyon
enfinen borde bien Bordeaux ouais bon
voilà
ENF non mais c'est possible mais juste
c'est desmion sérieus ici c'est voilà
ici on parle d'échec
quoi c'est une émission sérieuse
mais mais après je sais pas c'est comme
je te dis c'est c'est il y a pas
d'explication rationnelle quoi c'est une
histoire de fatigue
de je sais pas mais carou il le voit
tous les jours ça mais en claquant des
doigts il ferait il serait là en
blitzant et l'autre chat il parle le
chat et il te il te le joue en fait
normalement pourquoi tu dis à la
condescence c'est pasre condescence
enfin bon on te parle d'échec si tu as
pas envie d'écouter que tu penses que
des gens qui sont grand maîtrre ou quoi
peuvent pas te tu pense ton avis est
audessus bah mets ton avis fais ton
stream et raconte ta live ENF je sais
pas quoi te dire en fait c'est
pas c'est pas grave en fait hein ouais
puis on verra les gens ilont peut-être
t'écouter ce sera peut-être mieux en
fait ce que tu
dis en tout cas c'est étonnant un raté
après dame 3 c'est pas un mauvais coup
hein bah c'est c'est euh B fait si tin
n'existe pas c'est très bien ouais je
pense que c'est le deuxième meilleur
coup mais bon t existe le problème c'est
que T 1 existe donc
comparativement je crois que dès qu'on
est pour un joueur en fait il fait n
dans ce
[Rires]
tournoi c'est vrai
que non c'est dommage par la partie
était fin en C coup là ouais et et
là on porte la poiss Fab pe faut pas
qu'on regarde qu'on on va ailleurs
et on regarde des Hatch on est pour
personne bon bon on est là
quoi est-ce qu'on pense que si ping cou
peut gagner bah si tu veux on va
voir alors
bah ouais il
peut il fait n
non il
noo fait fait il y a plusieurs trucs que
j'aime pas bon évidment que le P ser en
G5 mais quand M il sera en G7 j'aimerais
quand même pas parce que il y a la paire
de fou pour les blancs dans une position
ouverte il y a de colonnes central
ouvertes et des pions sur les deux a
donc en fait quoi qu'il non ça ça va pas
mais al avec le P
G5 on peut à tout moment faire je sais
pas fou D2 fou C3 ou bouger la tour B3
fou B2 et on va taper sur la grande
diagonale faire des batteries on a
peut-être H4 qui peut arriver aussi ou
F4 ou je sais pas donc ça peut ouvrir
donc le roi noir est pas bien et en plus
quandbi même on raterait le mat parce
que bon il va pas se laisser mater comme
ça par et que ça se passe pas bien mais
toutes les finales vont être super
bienimagine une finale où tu mets le
fond E3 tu paralyses le cavalier le P B6
derrière et cetera donc
euh bah gros gros gros avantage pour
pourpenko ouais et sipenko une victoire
ça le qualifie quasiment parce que il a
le meilleur départage du tournoi
euh ok bah faut peut-être pas perdre
demain mais ça se trouve même g défaite
ça peut peut-être
suffire euh ça dépend qui
joue j'ai l'impression qu'ils vont être
plein à 7 et demi en
fait de cferer il peut il peut il peut
pousser s ça je pense pas pourquoi je
sens bien faire nul les
deux prê que kzubof bon ça c'est un peu
débattu
mais ça va sûrement faire nul S
viantig c'est
chaud
il en a un cas toujours ce dame
3 j'avais annoncé la qualification à 8
ouais mais c'est pas sûr que ça passe
pour tout le monde parce que là ils sont
vraiment en train d'envoyer de
partout non non non c'est H8 hein on est
d'accord mais bah disons les deux
dernières éditions c'était 8 après il
peut yir des cas de figures où ça sera 7
et demi mais
j'ai peut-être même l'impression que
pour certains ça pourrait être 8 et demi
mais bon
mais norm doit suffire mais mais mais
bon je commence à être moins sûr queag
se battent tous pardon non mais si et
ikarou
gagne et qui se retrouveent tous les
deux à 8 en
fait il faudra 8 et demi en a un 3è qui
qui veut
faire non mais là si les de G ils auront
que 7 et demi non oui mais il font nul
demain donc ils auront
et du coup si tu veux passer FA faire 8
et dem parce que tu peux pas avoir le
même départage que mais je suis pas sûr
qu'il y en aura beaucoup qui pourrait
bah Ker par exemple il pourrait avoir
ben
non parce que là CER je crois qu'il a
que 6 si gagne il a 7 et si' gagne il a
8 benah tu pourrais avoir qui non enfin
je dis conneries tu pour il 6 is donc il
va à 8
k alors ça qu'il faudrait être à 7 et
battre ikarou Naka ouis mais par contre
ce qui peut se passer c'est que H ne
suffisent pas s'ils sont plus de deux
ouais évidemment
mais donc ça on n pas trop prévu qu' qu'
a un troupau à 8 non plus hein
mais ah non mais 8 émissions c'est hyper
dur tu as raison j'ai 8 c'est à 8 c'est
Stratos ENF c'est bah en fait regarde
les enfin voyez pas l'écran mais en gros
là les mecs qui sont en tête du tourno
ils ont tous des perf à plus de 2800
ouais les 7 premiers donc c'est déjà il
font des trour de ouf
quoi 28 33 il spin quoi 28 45 VI 28 28
et cetera enfin donc bon il trou à 8
c'est quand même qualif 8 ouais mais
enfin ce qu'on veut dire c'est que tu es
pas sûr avec 8 points d'ê qualifié c'est
qualifa 8 mais pas pour tout le monde
c'est pas
garanti
euh ça dépend comment il s mais par
contre si tu as j'en sais rien je dis
une bêtise imaginons tu as ici piano
Nakamura et vidit qui gagne qui se
retrouve tous à 7 et demi en a vraiment
un qui passe à attrape he avec
oui donc c'est pas dit que H passe
quoi Carana est super fatigué je crois
qu'il arrive plus à réfléchir t ils
disent mauvais alors déjà première
question F prend
H6 bon il veut pas pion prend dame prend
roi G8 dame MG5 F8 F8
bon à voir fa calculer plus loin mais le
dit juste F
56 il veut fou prend c'est ça F6 il veut
fou prend puion on prend dame prend
ouais bon c'est pas si clair
ça sur PR6 t C8 bon au pire tu perpètes
déjà
ok parce que si tu ref 5 tu jou un truc
comme ro G8
ça recommence ah rame G3
si tu vas faire H7 c'est d pr 4 sur
échec et là je veux bien comprendre que
ce soit grave en plus 3 tu vas pas faire
tu non mais fa 5 c'est F6 100
% donc F prend g prend dame prend roi
G8
dame prend F6 ça paraît logique tour ce8
seul
coup alors le meilleur coup c'est pas
dam pr F6 je te dis c'est tour à1 enfin
dam PR6 c'est bien moi j'ai tour à
D1 évident alors je pense tu veux tout
reprendre a 6 c'est tour des7
ouais
et etmett qu'il fasse tour C8 alors
ouais tout à fait tu fais échec échec en
prendre un
F6 donc tu REP enang g vite j'imagine
ouais
euh là tu fais tour des
n'importe ouais c'est pas évident non
non c'est ratable c'est ratable surtout
que tu as raté avant mais le truc c'est
que tu peux y aller disons au pire je
fais échec échec avec Madame tu vois
enfin tu dis s'il y a rien il y a rien
j'ai nul et que tu étais venu pour
enfin donc ça a l'air de mettre KO après
même finchis m' l'air très fort parce
que le meilleur coup c'est de pas le
prendre et si tu prends tu as perdu dame
prend ro G8 dame échec ro
F88 dame F6 mais
F6 bah tour non tour t 8 non mais tour8
t prend 6 dame H8 dame C8 ouais mais il
y a que des trucs comme ça en fait mais
là disons que non disons que je
fasse j'ai pas de coup ben c'est
dire trouver des coups en fait j'ai pas
de
coup ok donc faut prend H6 je veux dire
c'est déjà suffisamment fort et c'est
pour ça qu'il va peut-être pas faire
l'autre par tu vois que l'autre va pas
te prendre enfin s'il te prend c'est
fini donc donc si tu prends pas il fait
tour D7 mais tu fais tour prend fou
prend et fou F4 ouais bon ça ça en fait
tu as plus ou moins le même truc il a
plus de pion et tu es content alors
peut-être tu vas pas gagner pour je ne
sais quelle raison hein et et je ve dire
c'est pas le meilleur fa prend H6 mais
là je je pourrais comprendre si rate F 5
parce que l'autre est trop tentant après
peut-être il va avoir F 5 et que bah que
bravo hein mais c'est pas 100 % gagner
ça c'est quoi les vales de la turb x 6ou
ouis il vaêtre à plus 5 quelque chose
hein je pense
mais fr dit qu' priori fa tour plus3 à
plus 13 sur tour mais tour quasi forcé
les aut déjà 250 machin mais ou j'ai
senti qu' partir c'est trop
facile en plus tu jou dame 3 tu te mets
pour faire quoi
mais qu'il voit juste rien dans la
partie là c'est costaud qu'il peut
peut-être qu'il est
malade juste pas en capacité de jouer
une partie du jeu
d'échec est-ce qui car peut passer
numéro 2 mondial 27 live fais
voir parce que il va lui prendre plus 5-
5 non mais bon il sera apporté de de
fusil
quoi par contre il se garantit la qualif
à Lélo là cette fois-ci à 100 %. il est
qualifié de tout en fait de tout
oua il a joué F6 ok donc bon déjà il a
pas pris ouis bon ouais bon là il a
juste d PR4 ouais bon
ok d PR4 la ligne ça d pr 3 ouais tour t
ce que tu veux euh T1 VI très bien 3
dame
5 D pr 5 F pr 5 fou G5 t 8 bon ben il va
s'accrocher pour pas perdre mais il a
une finale pourrie quoi il est vraiment
horrible ça va gagner pour les carou je
pense on peut se mouiller on peut pas
vous dire mais après d' prend C3
peut-être même tour est plus fort hein
ouais ils sont les deux sont très
forts mais bon tu peux peut-être te dire
il fait tour ce8 ah mais tu as fout des
deux en plus ouais bon bah tu as tout ce
que tu ouais
ouais non on est très content hein ça
devrait aller quand même je crois que
l'ARE j'aim encore mieux mais oui
ouais ouais non mais
Kana pas dans son élément aujourd'hui du
tout bon bah carou en profiter hein
écoute c'est alle caroun en profiter
c'est serv sur un plateau bah faut faut
juste se baisser mais faut faut encore
se baisser quoi c'est qui cette partie
là où il a
F5 ok bon lui laisse faire nul s'il
envie bon de toute façon vu qu' damage 5
de tu avais pas trop le choix mais je TR
pas qu'il pas nul hein c'est évent non
mais bon le problème c'est qu'il a 23
minutes contre 1h30 quoi
enfin il y a 1 heure d'écart et du coup
c'est peut-être un suicide de jouer et
tant pis peut-être tu dis ben tant pis
pas de candidat pas de candidat mais tu
cas tu es si bien préparé B c'est à toi
de prendre le risque
hm je sais pas trop quoi dire je sais
pas ce que je feris à sa place ça me
plairait pas mais non par contre param
ouais ouais param qui et ça va ça va
qualifier
quasiment comme Fabi en fait la partie
euh j'ai pas vu le contenu mais pour
être comme ça après l'ouverture euh au
bout de moins de 2 heures de
jeu c'est que ça va pas trop de pression
peut-être pour param c'est que Fabi
c'est autre chose l'explication je sais
pas com on dire parce que il a pas la
pression il s'en fout en fait euh param
param je les candidats je pense c'est un
truc énorme pour lui et il joue beaucoup
mieux que ça aussi hein ENF donc je sais
pas bah qui sait bien bah qui jolie
petite position mais bon là pour les
candidats bah qui enfin c vraiment fini
mathématiquement mais je par là il y
avait peut-être 0,001 % là avec victoire
icipienko et victoire Nakamura
c'est bah ouais non enfin non mais mais
normalement C demi tu arrives pas en
fait non non non mais genre c'est déjà
fini genre là en fait le scénario genre
tu pouvais même pas enfin moi j'y
croyais pas du tout mais peut-être un
cas de figure mathématique de génie où
tu avais 4 les bons appariments le bon
truc le bon machin pe-être mais là en
fait
c'est terminé fallait prendre les
risques hier
ouais pour avoir une chance ah ben
fallait TR sur 3 c'était le même cur que
Maxime juste bah on n'y croyait pas trop
vu le le style de jeu et et tout ça mais
bah il c'est vient qu'il va jouer le gar
h bon ben très bien bravo c'est bien en
plus peut-être la position lui le permet
hein je je te dis pas queil devait pas
le faire même objectivement mais quand
tu as une heure de moins un truc si
compliqué tu rates un coup il y a B2 à3
qui t'arrive dessus je sais pas s'il
l'aurait fait fait dans un autre tournoi
en
fait là en fait c'est vrai que lui aussi
hein si si s'il gagne pas celle-là il
dit adieu à la
Calif donc ici
qui peut-être avoir une
chance oh que oui
que oui le Fab en gros fallait que tout
le monde fasse nul à part Caran
éventuellement tout le temps et que bcky
fasse deux sur deux contre grelo ouais
je crois qu'en fait je crois que son
appariment d'aujourd'hui enterré
complètement malheureusement euh mais
oui là en fait en plus si c'est ikarou
qui gagne enfin si c'est en plus carwana
qui gagne pas c'est c'est kata
oui en gros ce que tu veux c'est qu'il
est de sur deux pour carwana et que
ouais et que tout le monde fasse nul à
côté et tu croises les doigts
is il fallait tenter hier à fond pour
avoir une chance
mais B après je peut-être qu'il est pas
la capacité physique hein quand on voit
Carona ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui ouais
tu te sens pas tu te sens pas
hein mais Cararo il doit alluciner
quoi bon
non il a kuboyef JX ouais il il enterre
quoi en
fait c'est qui ça ah
c'est qui fait peut-être nimpe hein
ouais mais bon c'est bien comme il joue
kuzubof Kub il a 6
quoi il veut gagner il veut gagner mais
bah c'est comme Baky quoi s'il avait
gagné hier je veux dire c'est le qu de
figure ou même en faisant de sur de tu
es tu es pas sûr
quoi
mais il donne tous tout quand il peut
avoir pas mal de joueurs à 7 en fait
ou ouais ça
PE et du coup de kwana ils vont des che
vidit ils vont peut-être être en sueur
parce qu'il voit tout le monde gagner à
côté
ouais
du coup tu te dis bah merde il va
falloir qu'on joue là un peu à se bouger
quoi
et ça peut partir en en Impe quoi ouais
bien joué de prendre 4 donc on s'attend
à Dame prend C3 bon on est pas sûr mais
paraît logique hein tu as un pion à
prendre tu atttaques une
tour mais parti cata de de Fab B ça
arrive hein non mais comme quoi ça
arrive même au meilleur et puis bah
quand ça m'arrivera j'aurai un peu moins
ENF je seraai quand même très énervé de
moi-même mais je pouris me dire bon il y
a pas Mo ça
arrive pour avoir un cas bizarre où tu
as TR mecs à 7 et dem qui sont déjà
joué tuas chercher les bas fond duas les
a à 7 maisas tout le monde qui va jouer
le
gain et du coup tu peux avoir un
scénario un peu débile pour
nousen font nul vid qui gagne serouve à
8 et dem les r meilleur départage
pass ça une journée de folie demain
pr g il encore la course avec son ouais
ouais ouais ouais prê que bah faut qu'il
gagne mais là il est pas top top he prê
que et puis pr que en plus oui en plus
il joue à 26 25 donc son départage va
prendre un petit coup dans les pattes
peut-être qu'il reste bien mais
attention
et a bien été cata dans le il joue
contre ça fait un moment qu'il est cata
GCH contre darda non il joue contre
darda ouais c'est pour ça j'ai on peut
jeter un
œil que c'est alors qu'est-ce que c'est
que
ça bon il est plutôt pas mal gouach bon
verra il allit CER bien quoi mais en
face c'est paire de fou il fait F5 il
veut F4 il veut ouvrir pas clair
quoi
bon en tout cas ikarou ça ça se passe
très
bien c'est Ker CER ils peuvent vraiment
gagner non non mais il a raison il faut
qu'il
essaye bah de toute façon il a gagné
hier il é obligé dans la station de
Maxime en fait lui donc voilà puis
aujourd'hui il réessaye quoi il tombe à
G4 et il pousse les
pions Maxime ça a l'air d'aller
mieux Baky ça a l'air d'aller
bien et alira c'est
compliquéa faut pas qu'il s'amuse à
perdre encore aujourd'hui hein parce que
sinon même àéo même s' n' qu' se
qualifier tout enfin ouais peut-être
qu'il va avoir toutes les planètes qui
s'alignent mais trop nul
quoi mais euh quand même faire gaffe
hein ouais ouais non mais il joue il
joue une partie et puis il est pas mal
mais oui ça peut mal tourner aussi hein
genre de partie
peut-être peut-être qu'il faut serrer la
vie enfin là bon c'est c'est facile à
dire après coup he tu joues des DP trop
tu fais des nuls tu perds pas trop
et puis
bon perd
c'est plus se rapproche de saut plus
c'est chaud quoi va falloir espérer
que c'est très sa quoi il va falloir
commencer à espérer que so se qualifie
au Grand Prix truc prix que gu joue mal
enfin vraiment tous les cas de Figur que
tout se passe bien et joue g contre
ikarou bah aprèspen le truc c'est que
ils sont déjà joués hein mais mais oui
c'est pas comme je disais c'est pas sûr
que H pass en fait enfin que tous les
joueurs à H pass par contre je pense
qu'il a 100 % àéo c'est gag aujourd'hui
ouais il peut faire nul faire 3è et ok
chat doesn't matter to
me I
don't
275ting
[Musique]
for une candid
oui ça il y a 14 points d'écart mais en
fait du coup 14 points d'écart ça veut
dire que so doit faire un point et demi
de plus que fou la singfield alors je
dis pas que c'est impossible mais bon
après si fierou joue mal ici joue mal
là-bas joue mal partoutah après tu m'es
pas d'y aller et puis bah c'est tout
enfin mais si ça se passe plus ou moins
normalement et que même tu vois fou il
fait allez 50 % des points 4 dem sur 9
fa queass 6
je dis pas que c'est impossible mais
c'est pas trop ce qu' fait en général
quoi mais par contre
si per une partie qui était plus plus 6
sur dem ça se
rattrape ça c'estutre chose
d'ailleurs non mais il
peut est
plus parce que je
pense il est quasi favori en fait ouais
tu peux penser que nepo va refaire à
avir mais en fait c'est bass qui doit
pas être
bien mais lui oui lui oui on s'en fout
complètement
number magn c'est Magnus en plus trou il
veut juste pas les gagner mais pas qui
les gagne donc il va peut-être faire
tout ce qu'il faut pour essayer de lui
mettre 2-0 et HS my
queen jus qu pourcep il a plutôt dit non
mais mais en fait vu que c'est pas
officiel il peut changer d'avis
donc je sais pas jusqu'à quand il y a
mais
bon au candidat on va tuer quoi on a un
demi sur 4 bon il encore des ch chance
mathématique non mais s'il joue comme ça
au candidat mais bon moi j'espère qu'il
se remett à bosser comme un fou et qui
joue des tournois ai fa de la pratique
un
peu il a pris C3 cétait prévu donc tour
ou tour D1 on sait pas trop les deux
coups sont bons donc il peut pas rater
laarou ça tour attaqué il va la
bouger quand même fou que la
Fed
euh se plus autant de voilà c'est plus
se plier à toutm he là c'est là tu tu tu
tu tu te mets en crêpe quoi devant tu
t'étales
quoi à genou
ouais mais on sait très bien de quoi on
parle
hein
c'est
complexe c'est VI c'est chaud mais ça ça
joue tout tempo côté côté mais il a
raison ouais c'est
vid c'est par il a pas l'air bien non
mais il su complet
là ça c'est fedos ça c'est Maxime ça
devient chaud ça c'est Baky ça a l'air
plutôt bien il a vraiment bien B h et ça
c'est alirea
ok pas clair enfin je là on peut pas
vous dire qu'il joue mal aujourd'hui
hein c'est juste c'est pas clair et on
verra ce que ça va donner
[Musique]
hein c'est beau quand même quand même
côté français c'est le tournoi a été
complètement raté quand même c'est
W complètement passé à côté quoi bah
Maxim ouais ouais voilà après marquan a
joué plus ou moins son niveau je crois
enfin il fait une perf à peu près il
était bien parti après moins bien mais
bon ok c'est correct et puis ettienne
plutôt bien mais mais disons nos deux
espoirs avant le tourno de Calif bon
c'est clairement alirea et Maxime
ouais eux c'est tournoi tournoi manqué
quoi et puis bah c'est comme ça marquan
va gagner pas mal des je crois pas pas
tant que ça enfin ça dépend comment il
finit évidemment il reste deux parties
donc ça va décider mais je crois que là
il est que à plus enfin que c'est déjà
bien il a plus 3 en fait après ne round
il a gagné des belles parties mais il en
a aussi perdu
beaucoup je vais vous dire je vais
regarder le
h après marquant il a pas l'habitude de
jouer des tournois comme ça non plus
aussi élevé donc c'est très bien ça va
le faire progresser ah c'est très bien
ce qu'il fait euh et donc c'est bien il
y a pas c'est pas une critique ouais il
a plus tr points et demi quoi donc bah
déjà très bien et aujourd'hui il joue
contre pouria et
et ça va enfin il pion de
plus h il est une position très correcte
en fait je veux dire donc il peut finir
le tour plus 5 + 10 si ça sourit bien ou
zéro quoi donc en fait ça sera pas un
tournoir raté de sa part ça c'est clair
quoi qu'il en
soit bon on va voir ce que fait ikarou
ah mais c'est déjà l'heors de la pause
mon Fab ah magnifique non on se retrouve
une petite dizaine de minutes les amis
pour pour la suite là ça avançait pas
trop on va on va faire une petite récup
et on revient bientôt à tout de
[Musique]
suite
he
he he he
[Musique]
he
bon les amis très bonne nouvelle on a
absolument rien raté pendant la pause de
10 minutes il ne s'est absolument rien
passé et donc ça veut dire qu'on va
pouvoir se délecter de du prochain coup
qui qui nous
arrive bon s'attend à tour ou tour 1 de
coup sont très
bien avec un avantage décisif pour les
blancs mais pas falloir ch pour les car
et
conclure les candidat sera en avril
prochain je crois que c'est genre du 5
au 25 en gros ENF 20 ou par là quoi mais
oua c'est surt avril quoi
quasiment et ce sera à Toronto donc ça
vaê bien à suivre ce sera le on aimerait
bien avoir un joueur français quand même
h donc fautikarou
gagne là il fait pas une grande partie
pour le moment mais Fabiano c'est encore
pire un joué bah très bon
coup donc il men tour
D8 et T PR
6 donc il a joué tour
ah là il y a un truc qui est fort c'est
tour D8 ouais je crois que c'est le
coup c'est le meilleur coup mais alors
attends tu as peut-être Fouché 8 encore
al ça gagne pas mais tour D8 bon coup
fou G8 foug8 il faut faire dame G6 tout
à fait t prends D8 tu es obligéend t
prend D8
et tu dois revenir un peu la rescouse de
tes
pièces tu es mal
quoi tu su mais c'est pas encore terminé
tu su quand même D 2 dame
5 G3 ouais c'est la ligne que j'avais tu
fais dame 6 tu t'arqueb un P de MO tu es
faible tu cl partout ENF tu per 3 ouais
bon tu es mal ah tu per un deuxème P
après les finales sont perdantes aussi
donc
F 3 tu peux quasi rien faire enfas 5
attaquer tuas damage 5 tu vas
faire prise faut prend C et là toutes
les finales sont
perdu non mais ça fait quasi aucun doute
va gagner faut juste pas qu'il se trop
trop ouais maisend
a prend C2 prend A7 tour
A2 voà celle-l pile poil
oui faut quand même être encore un peu
prudent mais bon dame F7 tu pou aussi
jouer dame g4f à vrai dire tu as aucun
intérêt d'échanger les dames non mais tu
peux faire et si tu fais pas Fran C5 tu
fais t C8 et ok
euh bon ben voilà bon normalement tour
D8 a l'air attends tour D8 fou F7 on n
pas regardé ah dame prend7 ou bêtement
oui d' fou G8 pour pour déclouer oui en
fait lu de fou G8 cétait juste de faire
t PR8 t PR4 de mon côté mais mes dam G6
du coup c'est logique tu tapes là tu
tapes partout il prend tu prends puis on
prend il y a dame pr G8 mat là tu
faisais le petit chic Chac qui est quand
même assez malin pour te ramener pour
gagner un tempo et là tu remets le fond3
tu menaces mat dame F7 et comme tu
disais au pire prise prise et du coup
tour C8 t prend C5 et il faut gagner la
finale qui est gagnante d'ailleurs mais
oua je crois qu'elle est vraiment facile
oui ou
t D8 j'ai prend
H6
G6 pr H6 tour D3 tour G3 des choses
comme
ça7 il a des ressources
t fait tour
des
Carème c'est sur dame 5 tour G3E pour
dire et tu on en parlait pendant la
pause c'est tour estou mais elle échec
quand
mêmeion tu menacera
F4 F4 la dame
etche mais oui t coup coup brillant
parce que ça laisse une pièce en PR
je pense qu'il va tenter g H6
personnellement parce que F G8
bon je sais
pas pas grand chose à
tenter
[Musique]
c'est un bon résultat après pour nous
mais ouais bon la partie est pas super
intéressante alors que svant l'ordi aime
pas trop mais on disait il prend il
prend tous les
risques peut faire
[Musique]
JECI que il était pas trop
bien bon en fait ça va ça va ouais d
Hatch cont viidite un peu de retard à la
pendule pour des Hatch je crois qu'il y
a plein de mecs 7 et 7 et demi en fait
VO
spinko ça va gagner
keer il a l'air d'être de mieux en mieux
contre fedos h M euh égal
enfin
l'pa et c'est quoi ça c'est fou il paraî
que c'est pas un bon coup mais bon c'est
la petite turbinette donc c'est hyper
complexe là
logique le G5 là-bas et
darda par il sa de fou quoi il est pas
mal il peut Batt
gvageable pour l'enterrer un peu plus
qui pourrait perdre quasiment 30 places
en un classement
qui se fait
déper pas la Meille partie de sa vie
malheureusement pour
luiana qui
réfléchi encore une chance candidat
alors là non plus du tout là à ce moment
de la journée c'est on est sur du
0% le tournoi est terminé pour les
Français en réalité plus
[Musique]
que mais via VI le H via le
hlo en fait tu aurais peut-être dû jouer
la Coupe du Monde essayer d'aller au 3è
tour qui non ala jouer ça et puis après
plus jouer la S field quoi ah ouis pour
le parce que là en fait il peut pas se
retirer il a pas joué assez de tournoi
oui retir tu tu ne te qualifies
pas
c'estme bien pour une fois la f bravo je
critique assz souvent mais de forcer les
gens à jouer pour PIR se qualifier
c'est c'est quand même non parce que la
FD ne fait pas aux échecs pour ch de
France tu as des gens qui ne jouent pas
une partie en un an et qui sont repris
chaque année ouais non ça la feed il
demande qure tournois et encore c'est
même pas n'importe quel tournoi ou tu es
obligé c'est des tournois qui sont dans
le circuit
feed
donc donc ça c'est normal comme règle
c'est bien
tu ASIT de te retir un prénom rondin euh
je crois pas non après peut-être qu'il y
a un trou dans le règlement alors
peut-être tu peux s'il un trou dans
règlement mais ça sera mal vu et je suis
pas sûr qu'on va trop teèiniter à
l'avenir c'est même pas ça c'est
peut-être que tu as même une commission
de la feed qui peut te te dire oui
bon
carou sous côté bah en fait le truc
c'est qu'il avait vraiment baissé de
vraiment en fait il était descendu il
était autour de
2725 30 il jouait pas bien enfin pour
déj de ce niveau hein je
m'entends dans deux grands pred ouais
deux fois éliminé par topalof et voilà
donc il gigotait encore dans les
événements sur Internet et trucs comme
ça mais il faisait vraiment plus rien
puis chez pas il y a le covid qui est
arrivé les tournois en ligne il s'est
remis à bien les jouer ceuxl à très bien
les jouer même euh peut-être ça lui a
remis de la confiance il s'est mis à
très bien gagner sa vie avec les stream
peut-être lu met de la pression quand il
a joué les tournois et c'est un nikarou
2.0 qui est revenu et qui qui est
ressuscité quoi enfin qui rejoue
sûrement mieux que jamais quoi en fait
même quand il est plus de 2008 à une
époque j'ai l'iMon que là il est plus
plus dominant à l'époque il était un peu
dans une ass de joueurs mais tu avais
encore les cramniqu les mecs comme ça tu
vois il après pour moi le le le haut
niveau a régressé hein par rapport à ce
moment-là h je trouve mais c'est ça
progresser via les ouvertures et tout ça
mais sinon la densité elle est bien
moindre he par un moment tu avais bah tu
avais Levon qui était au top de sa forme
tu avais déjà Magnus tu avais carwana
qui était là so qui était motivé tu avis
Maxim tu avais Medov qui les a franchi
2008 tu avais tu avais CR qui était pas
retraité tu avais qui était encore actif
ouis c'est qui était en forme ouis qui
qui
croyait bien et donc c'était très chaud
tu avais vraiment toutes ces joueurs là
qui qui dis les tournois et c'était et
voilà et donc ouis effectivement c'est
moins danse et mais donc ikou qui depuis
là pas grand chose à dire il joue
vraiment bien et Rajab aussi qu' jouit
bien non non il y avait du monde he là
en fait tu as l'impression qu'il y a
quand même beaucoup de gens que les
échecs ont saoulé
ouais gritchou oui bien sûr il y avait
du gritchou qui était fort là tu as
l'impression que les échecs ça saoule
tout le monde en fait et puis tout le
monde a vieilli un peu et puis bonah les
nouveaux qui arrivent ils sont pas
encore à ce niveau peut-être qu'ils le
seront un jour peut-être pas je sais pas
je sais pas quoi vous dire mais il
jouent bien il y a pas mais mais que ce
soit Gouch Prague CER tout ça voilà
c'est prometteur mais c'est
pas c'est pas de l'équivalent des
joueurs qu'on a cité prime quoi mais ils
sont tous très jeunes encore dans cette
mais c'est
génétion intermédiaire il y a pas
génération intermédiaire genre Douda ou
quoi il a bloqué les joueurs un peu à la
Douda je veux dire
ouais même rapport ou quoi c'est ouais
mais c'est en dessousah il y avait Ding
aussi que tuas pas
cité qui a quand même été très fort très
fort toujours pas mal mais joue plus en
faitou il joue plus en fait c'est
marrant tu as les meilleurs qui ont
régressé et les jeunes qui les
rattrapent qui sont pas encore plus
forts queux
les ordis ont peut-être dégoûté du
travail à la maison bah ouais peut-être
que devoir apprendre trop de lignees ça
a dégûé pas mal de gens en
fait ah B c'est pas pour ça que tu es
devenu du joueur d'échec de base c'est
pas pour apprendre par cœur peut-être
maintenant si maintenant si oui mais gen
les gens de cette génération c'est pas
pour ça qu'il sont devenus joueurs
d'échec donc tout ouais et euh ça
dégoûte clairement c'est un autre jeu
ouais ou je c'est pour ça que beaucoup
de Fort jouurs demande le 960 mais qui
est pas bien compris par la masse quoi
ouais
ouais non mais après ça se comprend
enfin 960 c'est trop compliqué
hein c'est quoi le 960 c'est le Fisher
random chess c'est tu tires au sort la
position de départ en gros avec deux
trois règles quand même hein qui é deux
fous sur deux couleurs différentes les
tours des deux côté du roi mais bon ça
te fait 960 positions possibles de
départ et donc ça t'enlève toute la
prépa dans les ouvertur et le côté ordi
et cetera et cetera qui qui peutre jugé
comme pénible par pas mal par moi par
exemple mais d'autres joueurs que qui
qui aime pas trop ça
et et voilà et tu joues au déchec dès le
premier coup
quoi mais oui on a été mauvaise langue
ouais on a pensé que ça fa en 20 minutes
mais malheureusement Fabiano a faitop
mal joué pour ça il a peut-être fait sa
pire partie depuisis bien longtemps
ouais bon c'est pas mieux que nul en 20
minutes en fait fa parce que c'est en
terme de qualité de jeu voilà mais mais
au moins il se passe un truc et en gros
ça nous arrange ça nous arrange bien
tour pour mais c'est l'intention
d'ikarou de faire un nul enfin sans
prendre de risque et le scénario de la
partie aller vers ça mais bon si ton
adversaire joue aussi mal si la donne il
te la donne he ouais si t'en fait cadeau
il t'en fait cadeau
hein après Fabiano qui a joué beaucoup
de tournois il jouait pas super bien
après on est nous d'avant la partie
c'est ce qu'on espérait mais le le choix
de d'ouverture d'ikarou c'était pas pas
ambicieux mais après ouais c'est ton
adversaire je trouve que c'était parfait
en fait jou si mal tu
prendsin mais bon ça faisait un moment
que Fabi c'est quelques parties où il
jouait moins bien et là aujourd'hui il a
complètement
explosé c'est comme ça hein
nous ça nous arrange
mais ça pas lui faire super
plaisir bon après c'est mieux pour lui
ça Tom dans une partie sans enjeu pour
lui si cétait ça candidat
qu ilrouve pr de la fin et il fait ça
is je pense pas c'est mieux de de le
faire là c'est le meilleur des moments
pour jouer une partie aussi mauvaise
ça arrive à tout le monde la fatigue
mais ça ça sentait un Fabi depuis
quelques Games comme je le dis qu'il
était de mur mais il semblait qu'ikar
essaie pas d'en profiter non dis cétait
très bien pour les nul en fait vu le
scénario et le chemin qualificatif ou
quoi bon après gagner c'est encore mieux
que nul si on te la laisse tu vas pas
cracher
dessus la place décidé au 1er
janvier
mauvais coup ici une grosse croix
[Musique]
rougeali
on'envoyer un petit
peu
Victo un très joli coup qui termine la
partie sur le champ très
blanc là il y a du
joli a plein de bon coup très be très
très joli cel les deation ser pas
galv ça
men voir ce qui se passe sur les de PR
on prend
la on gagne une qualité s prend du R
fait d D4 et des c'est un C
magnifique sur 5
non roi prend dame D4 le
5 prend et roi s'en va mais du
coup zigz oui mais faut le sinon ça a
été dommage que 5 nous dévie qu' prenne
pas la tour ah bah il plus rien très
joli fou G7 je pense qu'il va trouver je
suis pas sûr mais c'est très beau très
très beau euh par en fait tu peux faire
mécaniquement tour à D1 et tuécrase ou
bon mais oui F G7 ça ça que so le coup
qu' le qualifie au candidat en quelque
sorte ouais parce que c'est un très joli
coup il pourra en imprimer un tableau à
mettre chez lui CER qui est en train
d'exploser fedo CF très bonne partie
pour l'instant de
CER Maxime Maxime c'est toujours bon
çaattend à nul mais bon on verra enfin
ça se trouve il va se passer un truc et
et voilà B qui ça joue il est plutôt pas
mal après bon tout peut arriver en fait
dans cette
partie G4 bon je sais pas n une croix
rouge leur dit mais bon on le croit pas
trop genre ça joue quoi c'est pas un
coup kata du tout et et darda AC les
noir qui fait sa partie contre GES et
tout va bien mais encore il peut se
passer des
choses et on revient sur sur Ikaru ça a
toujours pas répondu côté carwana
ouais mais là le problème c'est que tous
ces coups sont mauvais
quoi soit tu te fais smatcher sur le
champ soit tuas une finale avec de pion
de Mos et bah bon
tuas pas envie
quoi parti
cataclismique les spingo candidat bah
écoute c'est ça devient très bien parti
pour lui bah il a le meilleur départage
du tournoi il va être leader non c'est
bien pour lui ça fait il avait un peu
disparu enin on savait que c'était un
très fort jeune il avait fort potentiel
il jouait très bien mais il jouait d'un
coup moins bien depuis quelques années
depuis il décè de son entraîneur en fait
et
euh et euh allez vas-y vas-y tu peux
changer et puis bah là on dirait que
peut-être un renouveau qu'il va se
remettre dedans je sais qu'il a un
partenariat finalement avec la féérus PE
s'est remis à bien bosser ou quoi donc
bah écoutez content pour lui ça peut le
relancer et l'amener un peu vers les
vers les sommets qu'il était censé
côtoyer après attention he c'est reste
un tournoi non c'est un tournoi bien sur
un tournoi et puis en fait ça
redisparaît instantanément donc il faut
être prudent très prudent
là-dessus pourquoi fabino pe bah F F7 tu
fais dame prend tour parce une tour en
fait elle est
cloué non non mais c'est c'est position
trop du pour
fabiie je suis intrigué de l'interview
d'après partie de ikaro
ouais j'ai envie diref je vrais juste
savoir ce qu'il va en dire je pense que
ça va être le premier surpris
quoi h le gagnant qualif les deux
premiers et s'il y avait Carona dans les
de premers le troisème il aurait été
mais là ça prend plus de chemin pour
Fabi non Fabi normalement mais je prend
H6 ouais ben j'ai pris6 peut-être c'est
ce qu'il doit tenter mais ça va pas bien
marcher il y a la dame qui va arriver en
G6 je crois qu'on est changé d'abord la
tour h en E8 et dame G6 attaque la tour
attaque H6 ah il y avait un joli coup de
défense c'était fau F7 pour sur dame pr
F7 faire tour1 ouais c'est joli hein r
H2 machin on prend on prend F2 mais ça
allit quand même pas à cause de dame pr
H6 décale le rang G8 et tour D3 et la
tour vient à la rescous ou et
malheureusement quand on cale cette
échec en E5 c'est la tour qui vient
s'interposer et pas le pion et ça permet
de de terminer la
partie et du coup c'est trop dur quoi
bah il y a pas de coup en
fait et on dit sur dame C4 bah au pire
prise attaque la tour attaque G7 tu vas
devoir revenir ici et bon tu as déjà un
pion de moins une position cata il y a
pas de tour D8 Mo j'ur fait tour D8 et
je pas quoi ouais oui oui enfin on va
mais tu retoures en fait dans la même
position que c'est la que dame prend
dame et et C8 et et on va avoir de pions
de plus voilà donc ça c'était l'autre
scénario dont on vous parlait on peut
avoir une finale avec de pion de plus en
fait en gr pour le nord c'est le plus
résistant mais tu te sais condamné à
perdre après en soit tu es censé faire
ça et et prier quoi
mais pas trop il paraît qu'il eu nul
chez Maxime pas étonnant vu la position
ouais voilà c'est signé Maxime
tranquille qui continue son petit
bonhomme de de chemins plus qu'une avant
de rentrer à la maison plusune avant de
rentrer à la maison avant de partir vers
les États-Unis hein avec les grandes
chaises
tour7 raté ouais je je sentais pas le
jouer en fait pas évident comme coup F7
surtout qu'en faisant juste tour à D1 ça
l'air d'être oui ben voilà d'être trs
bien était joli par contre oui su
était
des 8 on attend le le coup de Fabiano
plus 12
minutes ma 50 POS de non non non pas de
me après il y a les trucs d'agent
de partir sur le délire des agents
Fab il
faitield les
autres machin et voilà c'est ça le monde
en fait dans lequel c'est possible après
il y a tout le monde des parties
truqué mais Maxime ne mange pas de ce
pain là donc faut faut le faire à son
insu va lui organiser des tournois
hein est-ce que Maxime perd pas mal
d'élo bon il doit perdre ouais mais même
pas je pense en fait il dont perdre de
il a qu Mme tris parties heinais non il
fait pas pas un beau tournoi mais en
fait le le le ressenti est pire que ce
qu'il a en fait je pense qu'il perd que
deux points ou trois donc non per deux
tu vois ils disent donc voilà tu vois
euh donc en fait ça va c'est il a joué
équivalent à son classement ho on
espérait mieux et voilà mais mais écoute
voilà c'est fait c'est fait
ok vidit qui envoit hein donc ils sont
vraiment sur la tronche les deux là
ou non mais ils voient ici P n' qu'à
gagneré ils comprennent que en fait nul
ça peut te mettre koos allez mais c'est
le jour où il faut gagner donc on essayé
ça veut pas dire qu'on y arrive mais ça
tente
ouais tout le monde se met sur la gueule
en fait mais c'est pour ça que ce
tournoi peut être bien parce que en fait
tu dois en fait à un
moment sauf que c'est trop arbitraire au
niveau des départages et que du coup du
coup
euh je sais pas trop qui doit faire quoi
pourquoi et puis tu as aussi le truc que
quand tu as un gros h enfin on a parlé
hier du coup c'est complètement
illogique
tu dois l'assumer ton gros hlo quoi
c'est plus dur en fait mais tu es plus
fort donc oui mais c'est normalement
c'est un truc qualificatif c'est pas si
tu es plus fort ça do pas être plus dur
quoi pourquoi en fait non mais c'est
plus dur c'est les adversaires rendre la
vie plus dur mais en fait c'est un peu
par au foot tu tu une grosse équipe on
te garde le but on est contant de faire
00 SAU que tu as pas un meilleur
départage à la fin tu as pas un meilleur
Go àérage si tu étais moins fort quoi ah
ça il y a un truc à un moment donné qui
est complètement illogique mais bon ça
ok c'est
pas en fait je pense qu'on va même pas
avoir tellement le cas de Figur dans le
tournoi ah je pense qu'on va l'avoir en
fait moi je pense qu'on peut
l'avoir tu tu verras mais je pense qu'on
peut l'avoir ou en fait le fait qu'ils
aient joué l'un contre l'autre celui qui
a le plus gros hlo il peut finir
derrière parce qu'il avait juste un plus
gros hlo dans le match si on l' on l'
oui mais c'est complètement juste ou
c'est
complètement en fait faudrait qu' qu'
dis ok c'est
comme on enlève l'affrontement direct
dans le calcul de la moyenne et on
prends que vos autres parties parce que
si tu prends l'affrontement direct en
fait ça devient stupide mais ça va
arriver
hein
terrible
le plus fort ach de tous les temps c'est
pour toi la question et pas pour moi
fidor je dirais
ou
alin fidor ou alekin ouais ça dépend si
tu prends français que né français entre
guillemets ou si tu prends les joueurs
naturalisés si tu prends les naturalisés
j'is quand même à kinus de fidor sinon
fidor
mais fav en plus qu' va perdre a temps
quoi bah écoute ça ira plus
vite m la son prime pas meilleur
qu'alikin bah alikin il était champion
de fois il était champion du monde
plusieurs fois plusieurs fois
combien combien TR contre capanc deux
fois bogolobov une fois ouais donc 4 oua
j'avais que TR moi j'avais oublié qu'il
Ava battu deux
fois donc enfin qure fois champion du
monde quand même ça ouais ça te fait un
petit un
petit et il aurait sûrement si ça
existait pu gagner des championn du
monde rapide ou quoi à
l'époque et pas
qu'un
des spectateur pour il me semble qu'il
en avait je crois qu'il 20 mais ouis non
moins moins mais sur le lien en fait
French Fighter tout bêtement c'est écrit
en fait vas-y mais il y en a plus
beaucoup ou non faut que tu te dépêches
si si tu veux dépl spectateur faut faut
vraiment
que que tu les prennes maintenant à
niveau à l'époque le niveau était moins
moins ha ah ouais mais et alors en fait
comme je disis dans ces CASL au tennis
le meilleur joueur sera toujours le
dernier en vélo pareil enfin dans tous
les sports tu compares avec ce qui est
comparable mais ce qu'a réalisé alikin
c'est nettement supérieur à ce qu'a fait
Maxime il y a même pas de débat
oui puis alikin là 100 ans plus tard on
s'en souvient toujours je sais pas dans
100 ans B on sera plus là mais euh
jefin champion du monde marque
l'histoire C échecs il Kin par son style
de jeu par le nombre de parties
brillantes et et cetera il a vraiment
mis l'empreinte sur le jeu
ou déjà pas capable en ouis c'est un
sacré exploit ouais dommage d' qu' pas
eu de match retour parce que j'aurais
bien voulu voir normalement Cap Blanc
était quand même favori du match quoi il
avait gagné avant ce match le tournoi à
New
York il était censé être le meilleur et
puis bon le match s pas passé comme
prévuin a montré une grosse résistance
en fait
défensive alorsanc l'habitude de balayer
en fait don il était mieux bon ça
bien c'était le premier joueur à
vraiment bien défendre non de l'histoire
pour le coup il bien défendu le premier
non à le faire c'était
pas des parties avant mais c'était pas
leur fort à l'époque de
défendre
et donc et donc quoi bah
voilà jeis pas B Bou si c'est le plus
dur de faire un grand chlem ou c'est le
nombre de grand chlem lever c'est un des
grands du
tennis on va pas on va pas dire que
c'est un con parce que c'était avant
quoi les gens qui sont pas d'accord avec
moi mais moi je crois que défendre par
le calcul comme le faisait alin c'était
le premier à faire ça
ouais enfin après comme je dis ouais
c'est V que lesc il sauvait pas mal de
pouBell quand même c'était pas la même
mais mais bon du coup tu avais pas
capable Enka en match en face quoi c'est
et à ce niveau de défense je crois que
c'était le premier à l'équip
ouais enfinon fa qu'on regarde
exactement mais ça
c'était un gros ouais il a fait un gros
match contre Cap Blanc en tout cas mais
comme je dis dommage qui a pas eu de de
match revanche il eu des pour parler
machin je pense qu' n'ait pas
spécialement envie ça l'arrangea de
jouer plutôt pogolubov que CAPA Blanca
quoi et euh après rien dit que cap
Blanca l'aurait battu la seconde fois
mais il aurait pu peut-être travailler
ce point faible du coup de vouloir
gagner trop simplement euh et je sais
pas ce que ça a
donné en tout cas si on compte les
Français naturalisés comme
oui dans le Lotin c'est forcément le
numéro 1 pour moi non non non mais
champion du monde
c'est pas par accident cétait le
meilleur joueur après du
monde pendant quelques décennies
quoi chione une fois mais très fort
aussi bien s
maisigé de
mettre et en plus au moment où il a joué
le match contre fishcher il était pas
encore français non donc ça jou c'est
dire que était français sur le tard
alors que alikin quand il est devenu
champion du monde il était déjà
français bon après ça c'est des débats
on pe les avoir on dit pas que c'est une
vérité absolue c'est un ressenti c'est
subjectif chacun pense ce qu'il veut
d'illeurs pr que va gagner ah ouais euh
peut-être mais la position m l'air assez
compliquée mais c'est une bonne tête
parce qu'il a un pion d'avance il est
rentain dans le camp adverse après F H 3
est-ce que c'est un
[Musique]
coup c'est sur ça qui compte
hein bon ça ça va il faut prend
H3 ah il se prend ça mais aussi en fait
tuas pas le fou qui revient ok donc là
tuas F5 qui te
fait dans les deux cas ok bon il peut
avoir ça c'est pas c'est pas invisible
peut-être pe qu'il a raté de
loin il fait un sacré tournoi ah bah
ouais quand c'est par de sur de en
battant Douda nul nul nuler ban nul Naka
nul fa CF nul
Étienne il manque Carana en fait en gros
dans les gros du tournoi et lui sont
despartages il est monstrueux de il
sonêt bon 2700
ouais donc là il a joué moins fort mais
mais oui il avait une telle différence
mais c'est que Naka tu vois à 8 c'est
pas sûr qu'il passe hein parce que prête
que gagne demain et si pienko fait nul
oui oui non mais il faut beaucoup de cas
de figure mais ça peut ça peut ça non
mais enfin victoire prête que demain
c'est pas non plus alors qu' gagne avec
cl noir ouais mais il jou contre un mec
qui sera obligé de s'envoyer en l'air
aussi non mais ça je veux dire mais on
sera on sera de nouveau dans le cas de
figure ou ce sera enfin si lesé l av été
dans l'autre sens passé oua là je suis
pas sûr mais mais si parce que 2625 B on
fera les calculs mais on verra bah si tu
inversé lesé je suis quasiment
sûr ça change pas des masses mais
peut-être que enfin si ça joue à trois
points de moyenne à la fin oui ça ça
fera que 27 100 2670 il y a quand même
tu vois oui mais là il joue caroana donc
il va monter à
2781 et prês il va il va descendre à
2007 19 points c'est quand même
mais demain Naka il va rejouer ah ouais
quoi que on verra enfin comme je dis on
va voir je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
le mais c'est pas du tout dit que
ikarous Calif par contre ouais ça peut
il reste pour l'instant c'est le mieux
placé pour se qualifier vu la tête des
position est le mieux placé mais mais
qui gagne c'est moins gagnant kikao il a
rien en plus en fait c'est juste qu'il a
une super position mais
ouais pourquoi pas faire de mat de
départage ben je sais pas çaa été plus
logique tu as bien raison Colasse
mais aller voir
fouja paraî que c'est pas bon ouais bon
je sais pas c'est l'ordi qui met mauvais
à chaque coup mais bon c'est le petit
ordi et il ve quoi tu reprends 4 C3 C3
D4 il F3
il encore qui prend F4 et fou prend mais
c'est pour ça qu'il veut B pranc ouais
et pas fou
prend c'est pas
facile bah il peut l'avoir l'autre he
quand même c'est pas impossible sur
passant mais c'est pas facile pour
autant non
plus du coup tu reprends le 4 s'il y a
pas k C3 c'est que bah ouais c'est un
peu il fait quand même des grosses
erreurs parce que là du coup en plus le
pion 4 il était utile il prenait la case
du Fou D3
bah du coup fallit jouer n'importe quoi
d'autre en fait ouais bah peut-être même
D5 ou je sais pas quoi mais ok bon on
verra si le Bartel le
trouve CUB bcky ça donne quoi par
curiosité ça ça donne qui paraît que
c'est pas bon je sais pas pourquoi ça
leur dit qui bon c'est compliqué hein et
oui ça reste compliqué mais il a des
pièces bien placées tien le calf6 va
sauter en le 4 à un moment c'est pas mal
ok euh Maxime donc il a fait nul on le
sait k toujours sa belle position contre
F CF on peut penser qu'il va gagner et
si
PKO aime pas tellement le coup mais il y
a une logique il ouvre mais il a raté
donc le fou G7 qui mettait un gros coup
à l'adversaire donc il faut encore qu'il
gagne quoi ça fait penser à la théorie
de mtas en fait quand tu rates un
gain qu'est-ce qu' fait là prend 4 et
sur cavalier
prend ah ou des tu tiens plus le
F pourquoi tu es pas plus pardon que ça
que
tuas es moins bien mais tu devrais être
foutu en fait le il est beau
okit le prince du
Gange ah il a futé le
garçon et vidite il va passer à 7 et
demi
attends mais il a pas encore gé aussi là
il a pas de chance que ce soit pas fini
parce que6 et machin en fait tuas quand
même la paire de fou les enfin mais mais
là par contre tu peux être le cas où s
rattrape Naka comme ça va se jouer à un
DEM non mais ça ENF je suis d'accord
avec toi ça peut arriver ce truc
d'abruti peut arriver qui est
complètement débile pour le
coup mais vraiment complètement débile
c'est wou mais ne pas y avoir pensé
quand tu as écrit les règles c'est
qui réfléchit on avait vu que dam G6
c'était pas mal c'est la fameuse finale
avec de pions de plus bon peut-être pas
qu'il s'embrouille he parce que c'est
pas le seul coup d'AM G6 mais peut-être
d'autres un peu moins bon
euh what C Viant ça donne quoi un peu
embrouillé C Viant mais c'est chaud en
fait c'est compliqué le problème c'est
sa pendule en fait qu'il a il joue
vraiment un truc chaud en étant mal au
temps il peut se faire planter par par
ici pr que donc il est bien il pourrait
gagner enfin il est favori pour gagner
voilà hat il est mal mais il a de la
chance donc il est pas encore foutu mais
il est moins bien et si Penko B on verra
faut qu' faut qu'il la gagne il faut
qu'il tienne ses ner faut plein de
choses mais il est toujours très bien je
pense qu'il espère pu on prend H3 F
prend H3 et peut-être planter F F5 h je
pense c'est ça son idée en
fait bon il quand même très bien ENF
c'est assez logique comme
mais bon plus que 13 minutes plus je
sais pas il peut il peut avoir un pas de
chance quoi enfin
c'est chaud cette fin de tournoi ouais
ça chauffe à tous les
étages pas les étages tricolor mais les
autres
étages ah bah nous on est on est
inexistant
juste il a fait bel mais ouais c'est
pour
ça mme si se
qualifie ah ben là c'est per là for
derrière avant le tourno quo ça devient
très serré le problème c'est que c'est
aussi le niveau de jeu c'est pas que
juste tu perds des points tu as pas de
chance pas de réussite ou quoi
c'estah tu es cataclysmique en
fait
juste mal en là il est très mal en fait
il est très mal dans la
position parce que il y avait des
compensations avec les histoires de pair
de fou casse blanche ou quoi là
maintenant tu as même plus de pion de
plus en plus tu as perdu un P vraiment
important tu as plus de pion de plus et
tuas tous les autres
problèmesas les pions qui t'avanc sur le
roi non mais cavalier D5 c'est grave
ça après peut-être sa position éit déjà
chi bon en fait mais euh en fait je sais
pas est-ce que D5 ça va est-ce que tu te
prends à valangeche des G5 F5 et
compagnie ça fait quand même peur mais
je veux dire c'est moins grave enfin
tuas un pion de plus et puis bon ouais
mais euh mais quoi qu' en c'était mieux
ok tellement bizarre par qu' il faisait
vraiment un bon début de tournoi hein
ouais il a eu il a eu euh il a eu une
bonne ouais ouaisouais ben je sais pas
peut-être qu'il s'est épuisé euh
peut-être qu' a un coup au moral
peut-être bah j'en sa je suis pas là je
l'ai pas
h que là ça paraît quand même très
compromis hein
la position affreuse après bon bah faut
encore finir pour pour Bartel mais sa
position l' de se jouer tranquillement
tu m fous en D3 tu pousses G5 faire
cavalier F6 il bouche sa tour tu fais D5
mais le cavalier en E4 enfin ouais ouais
mais bon tu bah non mais oui oui oui oui
non mais oui il faut se ressaisir aussi
se remobiliser trouver des idées mais
c'est peut-être eu un coup je vois que
ça pour le tourne il
F6 mais donc oui c'est que ça va pas la
même position avant avec un pion 4 et tu
l'as plus et B qui qui cque à côté ouais
mais ça va enfin c'est pas je sais pas
trop qu' était le clic pas à côté mais
là en fait il fait tour B7 pour doubler
ses tours sur la colonne ouverte il veut
transvaser c'est un coup qui a l'air pas
mal il pas mal il joue joue il joue sa
partie làtienne c'est pas mal dame 3 bah
ouais ça va vers le roi
là-basci po on a toujours même truc il
est
bieno je suis pas d'accordrogation de
l'ordi moi je trouve son coup
logique qu'est-ce qu' nous a fait
il va
ou ça t'énerve oua oui parce que c'est
pas mérité tu do juste perdre la
partie s Viant écoute il se
bat
et nakaka bah faut qu'il concluse tu on
fait la petite pause on va revenir comm
ça un petit peu plus s'emballer allez
merci le Fab pour cette
idée propre j'ai envie de direite et on
retrouve tout de
suite
[Musique]
he
he he he he
[Musique]
et on est de retour les amis il y a eu
un coup de jouet donc on a raté ce tour
des TR bon qui aussi un coup possible he
de toute façon on peut pas vraiment
prendre à vrai dire Fabien ce fou en H6
c'est un peu les même raisons que tout à
l'heure on prend la tour couvre et puis
échec on prend la tour 8 on env un
moment c'est la même chose c'est un joli
coup euh a priori il faud ESS FO h 7
pour s'accrocher mais Fabin toujours
dans les mêmes salles drap il a plus qu'
minutes 26 à la pendule il a minute 24
maintenant Fabien plus que 2 secondes se
sont écoulé depuis que je dit 1 minutes
20 aïe aïe aïe
on peut faire le décompte si tu veux ah
il va nous jou un coup un moment mais
bon une
15 j'attends pour dire une 10 en fait h
une
10 il va jouer avec ses 30 secondes sur
14 cou exactement avec une position pas
facile que des mauvais choix
possibles joue pas maintenant évidemment
elle ét décidé avant bien
avant une terrible série de coup
catastrophique
Fab on on va rester sur cette partie
puisque elle va elle va se décider
là mais est loin d'être qualifi en
réalité encore c'est pas de B pour alza
surtout qu' est peut-être en train de
sombrer
aujourd'hui on va voir il a plus que 30
30 secondes 30 secondes
attention falloir jouer ou abandonner
ou tomber c'est F h jouer
jouer
carou de répondre à ce coup peut-être
par tour 3 des 7 pourquoi pas qui met de
la pression joue sur tous les clouages
là-haut c'est une clouante on va jeter
un vite fait ala vu que ça a joué et ala
qui est de nouveau avec la avantage
parce qu'il y a eu tour prend E6 pu on
prend E6 G5 dame prend E6 ro H8 et là
maintenant il y a du cavalier F2 qui rôe
et oui qui va pouvoir reprendre D3 et
enlever toute l'attaque et rester a
qu'une qualité de plus la partie qui est
peut-être en train de retourner côté
alirea ça ferait nos affaires Bartel un
petit peu de réussite si ça se passe
comme ça la qualité de jeu aujourd'hui
et pas au au au rendez-vous Fabien non
non non pu qu'il y a des gaffes quand
même assez hallucinantes là le cavalier
des5 était assez terrible mais Bartel
qui était encore plus mauvais j'ai envie
de dire et là ça continue aussi les
erreurs mais là c'est plutôt l' qui
raconte fait plaisir onou on sait pas
pourquoi ouais non là c'est corer ouais
bon ça va gagner côté
allemand et il a pas encore gagné mais
c'est bien mais
paracretion par
s'accroche qui a une chance pas
possible difficulté prête que qui est
presque gagnant même il est mais il va
falloir encore terminer menacera du
damage 5 dam F5 mat mat il devrait
gagner pr triangulaire Sam séviant Sam
séviant qui a tout donné pour aller au
candidat et qui a pris tous les risques
contregalis ça fait pas nos affaires
faut prendre les petites Nules messieurs
ça rese de mal se passer pour Sam sévant
Naka Mura qui est encore en jeu et Gou
Gouch qui a pris l'avantage notre ami
belge qui a peut-être le se il a joué
des qu et ouais le pion qui s'est juste
fait qualité croqu ouais on sait pas
trop pourquoi il a fait ça un peu comme
comme Bartel
quoi
exactement exactement on va rester sur
Nakamura la partie qui nous intéresse
pour le moment notre grand format de la
journée nak mour mour
pas en tout cas pour le moment il est en
muré dans ses
pensées
propose dam h 5 ici pourquoi pas et
pourquoi pas dam h 5 avec l'idée sur
foupran d'aller prendre en8 de tout
échanger et de ne plus avoir
d'attaque et laisser peut-être le pion C
dévaler en tout cas Fabiano qui a
défendu pour le
moment il a peut-être pas fait le le
plus simple nak ouais que ce P son H4
quoi sur G tour 3
D7 il veut
G5 dame
G4 paraî fort quand même hein ah ça a
l'air très dur enfin je vois pas comment
il s'en sort mais écoute sil trouve la
défense maintenant pour avoir tellement
mal démarrer la partie ça serait
incroyable mais ça ne ferait pas nos nos
affaires HM h
HM bah qui gagnant on nous dit
ouais c'est qu' donne plus
3 qu'est-ce que son adversaire a
raté
reprend bon ben c'est le qu' n'importe
quoi parce que c
c'est pas faire F ça m'a l'air bizarre
mais tu
reprends
non bug mais par contre il est bien je
ve dire il est pas
gagnant c'est absolument n'importe quoi
mais il a une belle
position leur dit qui Ron n'importe
quoi on va rester sur notre grand
format de la
journée on dit même dans un mauvais
match de fout de rugby ou de d'autres
chose il y a plus d'action alors c'est
bah c'est marrant parce que en fait
c'est vous rebondissez beaucoup sur nos
discussions disait que un match de
national en football de deux équipes qui
t'intéresse pas et plus excitant
euh et on était en train de se dire ça
avec Fab
que je préfère me faire la journée de
prod D2 en multiple enfin non mais je
suis plus capable ouais mais je suis
capable de regarder trois matchs de Pro2
d'affilé en fait jeen suis vraiment
capable normalement je fais pas mais je
suis plus capable que de regarder
euh ça ça
ouais alors que je vais nettement plus
regarder des parties de rapide avec en
jeu que de la
ProD2 mais là oui on est je suis tout à
fait d'accord Didier fricher je peux pas
dire l'inverse en fait en étant
honnête même n'importe quel match
amateur dit David mais ouais je oui
probablement en fait faites n'importe
quoi mais en fait oua la cence est trop
lente quoi B en fait c'est long sur le
Tour long sur la durée et puis là quand
la qualité de jeu est inférieure à
beaucoup de parties en rapide qu'on peut
voir dans les tournois ça devient
embêtant quoi parce que tu passes
beaucoup de temps tu sais pas trop
pourquoi en
fait mais h mais
bon même badminton mais c'est sympa de
badminton ça va vite ça tape j'ai vu des
points sympas de ping-pong aussi là
récemment pingpong ouais depuis qu'il y
a les joueurs français la mais même le
padal hein moi j'ai des trucs de padal
alors que c'est bon pas j'ai bien envie
de m'y mettre ouais ben j'ai joué un
petit peu en j'ai joué deux trois fois
je sais pas mais mais cool en fait et
pas enfin bon à notre niveau de con
physiquement ça va par tu fais des
doubles ou quoi après eux là regard la
télé oui ça ça va 1 à l'heure c'est
c'est autre chose mais tu peux jouer
sans être trop éclaté mais moi j'ai
jamais essayé en
fait ça pousse partout hein j'ai un peu
le se parce que le club à côté de chez
moi il y a pas de cours il dis ça fait
trop de bruit pour le
voisinage
je pouro fer plus de bruit qu'autre
chose mais je CIS que ça fait du bruit
quand même oui enfin tout fait du bruit
quoi mais j'espère qu'and les candidats
on pourra aller faire un enfin c'est Mao
et tout en plus Mao il aime bien ben moi
je je sais même pas à quoi ressemble la
raquette en
fait elle elle est bizarre il y a pas de
corde en fait il y a pas de cordage
c'est c'est un truc un peu en semi un
bois léger donc je sais pas
euh assez
épaisse dis le pas et c'est c'est tu
sais sur Canal plus parfois c'est
nul après c'est sûr que quand tu es pas
attaché au joueurs machin et tout c'est
toujours moins
marrant j'avais vu un sport exceptionnel
aux États-Unis avec les épuisettes il
devent épuiser quoi mais ils ont une
balle dans l'épuisette et tu tu cours
avec ton épuisette qu à fond pour la
contrôler en fait après tu tires avec
ouais je sais pas ce qu' mais tu peux
courir aussi avec l'puisette mais les
mecs pe essayer de te bloquer je sais
plus comment ça s'appelle le la crross
ouais
ok je connais pas ah c'est exceptionnel
épuisette ball moi
j'ad j'ai toujours pas trop compris
pourquoi tu vouais pas courir comme un
abruti avec ton épuisette et aller mar
que dans les cages ouais mais mais je
crois juste que les autres ont le droit
de te défoncer avec leur épuisette aussi
enfin
mais c'est beau sport quoi mais c'est
l'équipe des fois qui passe les sports
chelous
ouais comme le chat ou
quoi sympa le
chat chat c'est sympa ouais bah en fait
c'est plus intéressant que les échecs
quoi regardz on av vu nous on sétait
arrêté on avait regardé le tour de
chat à la twitch
con c'était bien ils sont bons les mecs
hein fléchette évidemment c'est hyper
intéressant à regarder cette année je va
all les voir normalement les plac sont
acheté en je les reçoive les demiinales
champion du monde à
Londres B ouais mais c'est
intéressant bizchettes Mo moi j'aime
bien
auss sport une ambiance de ouf en
plus et puis tu sens la pression montée
quoi que tu dois jamais tromber chaque
fchet de
compte mais ouais les échecs mais en
fait le truc qui est dommage avec les
échecs c'est que c'est vraiment un beau
jeu il y a vraiment moyen d'avoir des
matchs intéressants et excitants à
suivre et c'est juste que tout est très
mal dirigé enfin genre ce serait si
enfin tu prends n'importe quel sport
connu tu ferais comme avec les échecs ce
serait instant instanément nul c'est pas
les échecs le problème en fait à vrai
dire dire tu ferais les fléchettes le
premier à 45000 points enfin et que
entre deux fléchettes et 10
minutesattente enfin personne
regarderait pareil avec le tennis tu
ferais le match en 457 gagnant tu dois
revenir tous les
jours ce serait irregardable les matchs
de foot avec 8 mi-temps de 90 minutes
enfin non mais je ve dire c'est tu
ferais des choses aussi ridicules avec
les autres sports il serait aussi
inregardable donc c'est
c'est pas les échecs le problème en fait
c'est ce que je veux
dire les échecs c'est un très beau jeu
et c'est hyper intéressant et nous on
adore faut pas remettre la faute sur le
jeu sur le jeu qui lui est très
bien c'est comme le cricket ouais mais
le cricket ils ont justement changé h
les règles pour s'adapter ils ont fait
évoluer
mais dame G3 c'est ce
tour pourquoi al dit que c'est plus
gagnant sûrement qui défend mais je
pense que on sa Pasi il a de petites
pour moi c'est complètement gagnant ça
bah les ont pas évolué ouais la terre
tourne mais les échecs resteob rest PL
quoi golf insupportable et je connais
des gens qui aiment bien mais moi je
regarde pas du tout je connais vraiment
rien
mais
mais ça contre un ordi je veux bien
croire que tu gagnes pas par contre non
mais les sont trop forts tout le temps
non mais genre c'est typiquement le
genre de position relou à gagner ça non
mais contre un humain tu penses que
c'est instant contre un ordi tu penses
l'inverse tu penses que tu as juste pas
gagné en fait je propose n à l'ordi
j'espère qu'il qu' sympa pour
accepter c'est un peu comme contre Joko
tennis dur tu as l'impression que tu as
de Doig de gagner mais tout d'un coup
euh il sort de sa boîte ouais tu mets
une 65 dans le deuxème set et le mec
défend tout
quoi il fait dame B1 ben voilà ah c'est
pas de bol c'est une
gaffeage
2 joué il a joué avec 2
secondes AC la D1 tu es perdant
peut-être qu'il a fait dame B1 parce qu'
tomber il fallait cliquer un truc
[Musique]
quoi
dame là maintenant c'est complètement
fini à
cause que j'ais dire ou on a vérifié ave
du coup tu vas devir faire d
f4change
pire je crois que c'est même pas au pire
je crois que c'est la ligne
mais V regagner tu
V encore finir tout ça mais oui très
très très bien engagé pour
ikarou
[Musique]
ikarou et dis abandon de
carwana peut-être sur les images carwana
qui ne gagnera pas le grand Suisse non
mais ouais s'est complètement écroulé
aujourd'hui ah il s'est écroulé
ouais il est monté sur scène il a sué il
a sué il fake news possible aussi on va
juste jeter un œil aux autres parties
bah du coup bah il s'est quand même
écroulé ala qui qui se sauve hein bah
ouais mais elle est peut-être pas du
tout anecdotique cette partie non non
non mais c'est 5 points et l' d'écart
voire 10 ouais voire 10 donc
bon sur chess res ouis comme ils ont 15
minutes d'avance sur chess reuls ah et
oui forcémentils ont pas le délai donc
c'est possible qu'il a abandonné euh bah
qui qui a l'air bien écoute hein il
ouvert son fou D6 vers le roi adverse
fait la journée peut-être super cool à
la fin ça ouais oui si tu as victoire
d'ikaro et victoire d'aliireza surtout
par par où on est pass fait ça
ouais elle te fait du bien mais bon
faudra encore assurer à la S que field
il faudra encore qu'ikarou gagne le
tournoi en second mais ouais gamer ça va
il est bien et si P il en est où bah il
est peut-être plus
gagnant t des 4 alordi n'a pas apprécié
sec coup euh je sais pas pourquoi il l'a
mis là maintenant mais
écoute admettons mais écoute il
s'accroche comme un fou pararemment
ouais il a pas l'air bien mais il se
sauve pour le
moment DEAC qui va s'accrocher comme un
fou aussi c'est loin d'être fait ça B on
lui souhaite de perdre vu vu sa
chanceêtre que lui qui va sûrement
l'emportter Sam séviant malheureusement
pour lui il va perdre il aurait dû
prendre la nul hein mais ou c'est ce que
je te disais ouais mais r il a fait le
truc qu'il fallait faire ouais le truc
de con il a plus de hlo mais il l' quand
même fait c'est ce que ben c'est ce
qu'il faut faire ouais mais ce qui a pas
marché pour Maxim et gkch qui va
gagner alors on nous dit que c'est gagné
ici on va on va quand même attendre hein
de bah dev voir de nos propres VO tout
ça
ouais c'est quoi le D dire de mettre du
délai sur all t en mais tu peux pas les
avoir en temps réel en
fait ça le délire il demande pourquoi
mettre du délai si tu peux avoir les
coups en temps réel mais tu peux pas
avoir tu peux avoir les résultats en
temps réel
je pense pas que donner le résultat à la
fin de la partie ça t'aide à
tricher non en fait le délai c'est juste
pour pour éviter la triche pendant les
parties que tu es un une personne tierce
qui te donne l'écoou à
distance devant son ordi après peu
importe comment le processus ou quoi
voilà là tu as un quart d'heure d'écart
entre ton éventuel complice et la
situation réelle dans les Chiquet moi je
trouve que c'est pas assez après
personnellement moi j'aais mis plus
parce que tu peux attendre un quart
d'heure en fait et avoir mais euh mais
bon moi je te mets une heure de délai et
puis voilà mais moi aussi j'aurais mis
un gros délai et je mettrai dans le
contrat interdiction aux joueurs de
d'écrire leur résultat 1 heure avant la
fin et si tu le donnes ben 150000 €
d'amende et zéro et zéro point mais
jeaurais mis 150000 € et ch rés tu
donnes pas les résultat tu donnes les
apparèments à la fin de la journée et
puis voilà beau 150k j'espère que le mec
écrive après 50 minutes tu pirates son
compte tu écrit pour lui quoi 590000 €
j'ae j'aimerais bien mettre des énormes
à mande en fait un peu comme les
États-Unis mais c'est qui c'est Gaston
au tennis qui s'est pris une amande de
fou non ouais mais c'est pas il avait
vraiment fait un truc incroyable et
marquant et marquant qui est foutu hein
c'est sû
ais du coup qui va faire un tournoi plus
ou moins à jeu qui peut peut-être même
finir négatif ça se passe pas trop bien
demain apparemment param qui a raté la
défense supposé mais c'est chaud
maintenant la partie enfin chaud ça
reste beaucoup mieux pour pourenko mais
c'est plus facile mais par en fait il a
fait un truc bien c'est qu'il a bouffé
un pion ouis donc peut-être qu'il va se
faire défoncer le roi ou quoi mais au
moins s'il se fait pas défoncer le roi
ben il a un pon de plus donc il sait
pourquoi il joue mais il a fait un peu
la technique de Murtas
ouais on dit qu'on croit on dirait que
la partie est nulle là pour Naka euh pas
tellement tu as quand même de pion de
plus quoi c'est pas
mal tu en as un là mais bientôt deux
quoi que à 7 va sauter donc de pions
c'est un peu beaucoup tu as le pion H
qui peut avancer tu peux faire tour G7
d'abord F reprends à 7 tour D2 fou
échec ça fait TR tu as beaucoup de
scénarios tu vas en avoir TR ouais donc
je pense que ça doit gagner après il y a
F couleur opposé donc c'est
jamais P de
plusosé non ça doit gagner et ça va
faire nos
affaires le serve de mer demain le H per
carwana pas dans les de PR bah demain
même niuliko en fait peut ne pas le
mener au candidat vu les mais bon vu
tout ce qui se passe normalement ça sent
bon en plus tu as prête que qui gagne
c'est pas trop nos affaires non plus il
y a pas mal de trucs qui font pas trop
nos affaires quoi non mais l'essentiel
c'est kikou gagne en oui mais imagine la
même journée avec nul Cararo gen car qui
fait pas cette partie
bon non non mais c'est sûr mais gen rien
ni fait mais tu imagines même ikarou qui
gagne et et firou qui perd
euh
mais ouais mais firou je suis pas sûr
qu'il gagnera ça on verra mais si je
suis pas sûr qu'il gagne non plus
hein dis qu' en fait s juste levé après
F prend
F6
G7 mais il a raison il il est parti
ouais il s'est barré mais technique de
murtass en fait
pour il non il a rejoué il s'est barré
après F pr F6 il a fait ça tend 7 et
mais c'est ouais technique de mais elle
est bien en fait tu laisses désespérer
dans sa position qui peut plus faire
d'inertie qui ve de contempler son
désastre oua ouais ça le saoule trop
quoi pu en plus sur les parties
prochaines que tu Jas contre lui tu l'as
bien enfon mis son nez dans sa merde
quoi non mais regarde comme tu es nul
regarde comme j' tis battu réfléchis à
ton niveau déplorable mais ça marche
très
bien non mais là clairement puis en
plus joue celle oui j'ais dire elle doit
être complètement gagnante aussi parce
que tu dois faire fou C7 je pense que
sur F3 G4 3 G3 tu remets le fou et tu
pousses comme un
fou on fait tro grimass à la seconde
bravo
Monsieur bravo Monsieur de grimassé hein
c'est tout ce qu'on veut voir la grim de
partout surtout pas j'ai Pr
F3 qui gag peut-être quand même ou quand
même
pas quandme pour plus ça
F j'aur
j
aussi mant tu te fixes bien là tu te
mets le pion à 5 pour max
de passé vous avancez jamais sur noir un
un sur deux ouais jamais les deux sinon
vous faites bloquer et c'est une autre
mayonnaise il y a plus de mayonnaise du
tout elle est elle a tournée elle est
dégueulasse est
pourri d'acheter de la mort en tube quoi
pour rattraper quoi
mais bonas raté ta mayonnaise quoi
dégueulasse et ça va
abandonner il a pas déçu ah le fou des
deux qui fait mal
signent il do avoir les cam il do avir
les cames ouais signado bon c'est un
premier
pas bon ikarou il est calife pas
forcément à 100 % par le grand Suisse
mais en comptant le ho là c'est voilà il
il a il a il a fermé le il a fermé le
job écoute qui essaie de s'en
sortir beaucoup réussite pour
l'instant de bien joué à
priori ça restre compliqué mais bon il
est toujours bien notre
amipenkoenko keer qui est bien Baky qui
est
bien qui ont d'autres et ala la partie
est quand même très importante mais elle
est vraiment pas facile à gagner ENF il
a une qualité d'avance mais je pense pas
qu'il va gagner l'autre est bien en
place quoi il y a pas de faiblesse qui
tient tout il a une belle Cason 5 jour
pour le il a déjà un pion pour la cale
he ouis donc nul probable mais en tout
cas ça aurait pu être plus
catastrophique que ça et puis qui
sa moment la réussite
ça y cararou est signé prè que pr qui a
deux chevaux contre une tour le RO
adverse dans
saldra il fait son temps le prê
que
oui darda c'est bon important quand
même bon on peut aller voir un
peu il a plus 3
minutes jou par B je sais pas exactement
ce qu'il veut en faire option hache il
dis que demain ça va êtreigci contre
yatengaki contre ikarou les couleurs
correspondent il ça
peut il qui sera en
twin une partie difficile he pour ikarou
ouais
mais oui oui non ça peut bien sûr une
partie on sait
jamais
B qui qui va peut-être encore gagner
ouais malheureusement 7 et demi il y
aura vraiment 0 % de chance là vu les
résultats qui se prof
prof l'ordiador stage
4 je suis pas sûr que suffisent
forcément il aurait mérité les candidats
Baky après on peut pas ou non enfin
regarde le parcours des autres c'est
beau aussi hein mais by il fait vraiment
un beau tournoi hein fait un super
tournoi mais bon quand regarde cingo son
tournoi regarde ikarou regarde pr cur
regarde gazy regarde les tous en fait tu
vois il ils font tous des gros tournois
quoi
HM faut pas exagérer il fait un super
tournoi à Baky il fait une très très
belle performance mais bon ceux qui sont
devant euh ils font un truc de ouf hein
par rapport à son élo ouais mais tu
penses pas par rapport à ton élo enfin
sinon tu mets un dou sinon peut-être
Colbus il le mérite quoi gar 2002 dans
le tournoi il a peut-être deux et c'est
incroyable d'avoir de avec 2002
quoi mvl il a fait
nul
voilà partie pas très inspirante
ok ça pousse le
pion je même c'est pas les blancs qui
sont mieux au
final un peu all TR avec mais après je
sais c'est quoi le plan en fait il a il
ve6 tour 5 pour t'attaquer le pion ah
non non mais je parlais des blancs il
vou les mett lui-même hm je pense
ouais non mais super beau parcours
d'Étienne évidemment mais bon en fait
ceux qui sont devant enfin genre par
exemple prê que il a joué une manière
une plus fort que moyenne hlo plus forte
que bcky jusqu'à maintenant et il va
avoir un demi-point de plus donc euh
mais euh il y a rien à Red dire sur le
parcours des tienes enfin je mais mais
tu peux c'est juste pour revenir au fait
de mériter ou quoi la Calif c'est
fait la Calif c'est bon c'est hyper dur
quoi si de prè de ce temp et même quand
tu fais un truc de hyper bien bah faut
plus que hyper bien en
fait c'est ça qui est dur là tu vas avir
des gens qui vont faire des perfs à 28
50 qui vont pas se qualifié en fait
ouais donc euh bon en tout cas il
revient
à 7 points il a fait le truc qu'on enfin
que Maxime a voulu faire hier mais qui a
pas du tout
marché enfin mais c'est pour ça ouais
qu'à un moment donné tu es quand même
bon on va pas refaire le débat une diè
fois non mais le problème c'est que
Maxime il l'autre n'avit plus le choix
non plus à ce moment-là oui oui
certainement ouais là en fait tu as
espoir pour s vient tu as ton C qui
arrive la dame le machin et l'autre
aurait fait aussi en fait dans la même
position c'est
il a quand même un super départage B qui
à 7 et demi bah déjà 8 c'est pas sûr que
ça passe donc autant dire que 7 et demi
c'est même pas la peine en fait et super
départage oui non il a pas le meilleur
départage du tournoi en fait vous êtes
un peu délu en vrai il a un très bon
départage B qui mais il a un moins bon
départage que d'autres moins bien que
Yakub que Niman que
sindarof que pr que que ici pienko et ce
soir ça va être remis à jour d'ailleurs
notamment donc non non il va être
derrière il va être derrière de que
beaucoup après B en fait il peut finir
top 10 du tournois donc évidemment c'est
un parcours magnifique enfin comme je
vous dis hein c'est pas pour ah non le
parcours il est exceptionnel mais juste
là pour pour la Calif c'est juste plus
possible tout petit peu pas ça
quoi en fait ce soir tu vas probablement
avoir déjà trois joueurs à 7 etnemis h
donc et qui ont déjà joué ensemble pour
la plupart d'entre eux donc qui vont
jouer contre des gens àass donc en fait
ilit juste qu'il fasse nul enfin s'il
perd il y en aura d'autres qui seront à
8 s'ils font nul ce sera eux qui seront
à 8 C ennemi déjà mathématiquement ça
passe
pas n pas le dernier coup de Baki c quoi
son coup F G3 l'autre a fait quoi il a
fait ro F1
ok je sais pas trop quoi prend f2end F2
et les blancs sont
mieux bon mieux c'est un grand mot mais
ils ont avion pour la qualité F cas noir
quoi mais mieux j'aurais pas dit mais
que ça puisse tenir je vaux bien croire
très bien joué r f alors enfin moi
j'aurais pas et de c'était quoi F G3 il
aime pas alors tout reprendre deux-ê
c'est encore l'ordi qui s'énerve à dire
de la merde
de fou G3
dans ce senslas si je prends de la tour
il y a dame D4 ok bon ça oui tu dois
prendre du Fou là fou G3 et je peux plus
te donner la qualité pareil ouais si je
fais fou un ou de la la connerie comme
ça tu esent très clou ou ouais ok ok ok
ok hper dur mais ro F1 je pense c'est
venu comme une surprise pour bcky
ouais l'rea trouver un trucouis W et fa
il s'enlève des dames des4 HM
euh ok bon il peut quand même gagner by
enfin faut non non attention c'est mais
ok gros coup de défense et bah un peu
chanceux d' de de oUI NON NON chanceux
mais il l' vu à l'avance quoi qu'il a
fait tempo
ok ça ça reste chaud euh ça près qui a
gagné donc comme vous disait il fait un
tournoi très
impressionnant B c'est pas TR s'en fiche
un petit peu en même temps CER c'est pas
encore signé mais il devrait gagner donc
je c'est je vou voir bon ça a pas joué
depuis tout à
l'heure ok fa rester un tout petit peu
sur by parce que c'est 420 ouais
allez donc c'est c'est une belle partie
mais le roi F1 franchement il vient
comme une surprise pour by mais pour
tout le monde en en fait c'est que se
dire que tout d'un coup roi F1 et les
Noirs les Blancs égalisent c'est c'est
très volu quand même et puis en plus de
pas trop se faire contrer avec ce foot
cas noir et la grande diagonale et pr
que peut espérer se qualifier bah oui
parce que lui il a 7 donc il peut faire
8 et il a un très bon départage donc il
y a des cas il est pas favori hein
attention mais
euh il y a des cas et près de que Ben
demain il va avoir les noirs et en fait
al alors le cas horrible pour lui c'est
s'il doit monter sur un mec au-dessus
c'est avec les Noirs bonne chance par
contre si joue contre un autre mec à 7
qui doit gagner à tout prix tout risqué
c'est un peu un combat de rue et il peut
il peut peut-être gagner et raser Ikaru
au poteau et au passage nous sortir des
candidats aussi ça va être une journée
passionnante demain on va sortir les
calculettes oness de calculer tous les
qu après on connaîtra les départages
avant finalement puisquon pourra
calculer le la moyenne au
final et Ben qui qui fait F4 le meilleur
coup des fou H3
quie bien joué de la part de by qui sait
pas précipiter sur la tour est-ce que tu
peux tour
F4 je pense que c'est ce qu'il va faire
ta mais mais tu touches pas touch
pas
l'impression d'être très bien avec les
noir mais
bon de rentrer
ici non mais tu as deux doigts que ça
gagne pas ça parce qu' y a ça ça et
ça bien jou F4 on va voir très bien joué
de la part de
by je pas ça joue pas ça joue
pas ici c'est
important 2 40 on peut peut-être un peu
rester c'est important pour nous
vaudrait mieux Queen gagne pas je pense
ouais parce que param en fait s'il a 7
de toute façon et kikarou fait nul 8 en
fait param il a un trop mauvais
départage donc là on est vraiment
pour pour param on est pour param pour
la
nul il en
tête on est peut-être pour la nulle mais
toute façon il est tellement mal que on
na pas l'air d'être
bien euh et attends on va mettre Baky à
côté Baky ça va jouer aussi on va être
sur les deux échiquiers on est sur tous
les
fronts on est sur absolument tous les
fronts et ça a pas très bien joué
apparemment de la part des cpienko mais
bon fou5 c'est un coup logique et là
apparemment param peut tenter un tour
prend E4 mais c'est ce qu'il va faire de
toute façon
c'est sûr qu'il va faire tour prend4 F
prend fou prend cavalier prend c'est ce
qu'il veut hein
essayer de s'ouvrir le fou là pour
attaquer
qui va
tomber non non mais pas
bien une bonne
partieb4
ok échange massif
Destour
c'est qui ça ah non
ok 5 l'ORD pas 9 minutes che param 9 ça
va
réfléchi il peut peut-être la sauver et
Bak qui 55 secondes contre
250 il vient de gagner le catar Open en
plus il est il est chaud en fait mais
lui aussi peut-être fatigué du coup ouis
ouais peut-être épuisé ouais mais on gag
avec carlen Naka et c'est un peu comme
gagner ça en fait ouais c'est à peu près
le même niveau bah comme quoi he
peut-être un peu moins fort mais
ouais mais lui non plus il peut plus
aller au candidat même s'il a peut-être
le meilleur départage du tournoi en fait
yakubof je crois qu'il a joué genre tout
le monde ah non c'est pas lui c'est pas
lui en plus il a joué colbous donc lui
c'est la catastrophe autre c'est un
autre c'est pas yakuboyev qui c'est
sindarov c'est
qui c'est sindarof 27704
7 pour 2702 je sais
[Musique]
pas mais peut-être que c'est la moyenne
moins le
plus fait le plus mauvais il en
fa c'est la moyenne avec le plus n enlev
et le plus fort et le plus ça serait
quand même un peu
mieux
bon on sait pas comment ça marche on
connait pas les règles en
fait ouais c'est ça c'est moyen moins le
plus fA ou c'est pour ça bah c'est quand
même normal quoi oui mais
bon en tout cas c'est chaud et si pienko
ça réfléchit côté côté par mais c'est là
qu'il a peu de temps il reste 12 coups à
jouer va sûrement faire tour pr de ici
quand même mais bon il doit vouloir
enchaîner un autre coup derrière parce
que tour pr 2 tu sais que tu vas le
jouer en tu sais que l'autre va te faire
tour Pr surt prend de il y aura pas de
surprise MV a fait quoi MV a fait une
petite nulle j'ai envie de dire allez B
qu'il faut clic il v en CLI de d'affilé
des coups il va en clique de
d'affilé il va sûrment faire tour tour 2
tour 2 tour D8
non tour 2 tour 2 tour
D8
il reprend de une deè fois ah il veut
peut-être prendre
H3 prendre du roi mais tu prendsamage 5
et quand même tu prends du Fou tu mets
le fou en
F3 et tu blindes hyper complexe belle
partie belle fin de partie là en plus
donc il prend du Fou H3 blinder avec
fouou bar en après
son F qui peut être un peu bizarre du
coup ce que j'ai envie de te dire c'est
quelê le plus faible peutêtre tout d'un
coup le RO nover
fa prendre g courir
c ça peut être
chaud bien
jou c'est sûr ça blind tout va regarder
à côté ça toujours pas joué d c'est
toujours chaud CER c'est toujours
gagnantou apparemment maintenant c'est M
gagnant pour les Noirs mais bon on prend
H5 t H3 je sais pas ce que le H6 ah et
tu casses tout je sais pas je sais pas
non plus
ok on verra bien on verra
bien 55 secondes en face le fou F3 a
l'air assez forcé façon pion prend tu
vas prendre dame prend mais tu mat roi
G1 dame H2 roi F1 roi dame F2 matin donc
tu pense pas
forcé là du coup tu menaces probblement
de prendre H3 par contre maintenant donc
il faut s'en
aller il le
faut est-ce qu'on vaus est-ce qu'on va
en D7 bloquer un peu ce pion qu'on va G4
est qu'on va même en ouais en G4 en F5
pour venir vers D3 moi je fer je viendra
en F5 je pense mais bon peut-être de ou
mais mon que c'est si grave tu fais dame
G5 il a pas
dame5 je pas c'est
complexe alors que ça pas jouer al qui a
pris ce sera incroyable pour de gagner
cette partie ça ferait vraiment 10
points de différence entre ce qu'on pens
et ce qui peut
arriver pour refa un écart sur
Westley et ça lui mettrait du du beau
mur Bak qui qui réfléchit elle ve elle
vaut cher la partie entre victoire et
défaite il y a tellement de place au
classement et tellement de killas ah
ouis ouais parce que tu fais tu fais du
top 10 tu vas prendre du 20k je pense
ouais peut-être même plus je sais pas
trop mais oui non c'est que 80 au je
sais pas comment ça passe mais bon si tu
fais entre entre top 10 c'esttap 30 je
pense qu'il y a une énorme
DIF faut aussi se
jouer donc il garde un sur le pion C4
veut faire D7 pour dévier et faire dame
B2 ça va pas être joué non je pense
qu'il va jouer dame C3
moi raisonnable
mais d je pense Mo tu t'accroches ton P
d tu vas pas le donner tu vas pas le
donner par plaisir ton pion non non bien
sûr que non non non mais D7 c'est
impossible
20k à partir de la 12e place
is donc il y a pas mal d'argent en jeu
pour les
deux mais qui sont fous en fait il a
jouer à
fond pas voulu assurer parce que c'est
que vu son départage il aurait pu
vouloir assurer un peu le coup il a jou
RO2 aime pas trop mais bon après tout
c'est hyper
logique dame5 quand même on imagine dame
C3 c'est compliqué les noirs on quand
même un pion de
plusin pour laif au grand Suisse il
gagne aujourd'hui ben il a 4 points de
retard sur les premier donc ça va pas
être facile
ah bon ça a l'air de prendre forme pour
vidit
bieno ça joue pas en face mal autant ça
réfléchit à fond et Cu allez on reste un
peu là-dessus voilà les prix de Pascal
Go il nous dit 80 60 40 35 30 ah ça
doucement apr ok 25 20 18 15 et demi
8 5 3
2000 c'était
46e
allez B qui qui réfléchit a plus
beaucoup de temps après c'est pas énorme
2046e mais donc on rappelle quand même
que les joueurs sont tout frais payés
donc c'est vraiment 2000 dans la poche
2000 dans la
poche 10 erreurs de
param
euh il prend sa chance B qui qui fait
dame F5
ok va
peut-être je sais pas il solidifie
peutre ve fou H4 fou F6 aussi revenir
par là-bas et puis qui sait un J les
verb je sais pas pourquoi pour l'instant
mais ça peut être un chemin B1 G1 F2 ou
quelque
chose faire dame D3 côté blanc et
simplifié espérer fou C1 ok il espère il
espère fou B2 c'est pas bête je fais
quelque chose
quoi
complexe
pienko tour D1 il a bien joué C coup
voulaitz vient défendre la première
rangée gagner un temps sur la dame
adverse et pour prendre ensuite la tour
probablement un jour faudra la prendre
cellel poursivre avec peut-être dame
dame G5 ou
quoi il vont ils vont être il vont être
ils vont être trois en tête he
probablement fous c'est un B qui qui a
fait F6 ah il veut fou B2 roi F7 h je
trouve que c'est très bien joué fa
regarder s'il y a des fou H5 qui
traînent ou pas ah non mais il a dans
prier Chac pardon
ok ça peut pas pour le
moment moi je trouve qu'il est quand
même mieux encore he
Baky ah ro G7 tu vas faire
pour
peuttre ça ser coup pour coup
maisasre
ouaisg5
semi euh peutêtre éche intermédir D3 VO
du coup si tu fais fou E4 et la dame en
G5 tu peux repartir sur dame a 5 c'est
moins
graveêtre queun meilleur déage de Naka
ouais
ouais Naka en fait il est très loin
d'être Calif il est bien mais c'est pas
fait en fait loin d'être fait en
vrai très loin d'être fait même
déjà faire nul demain mais avec la
victoire des cpienko mais bon est-ce que
cpienko va vraiment la gagner c'est pas
fait encore non il a l'air bien mais
ouais mais on sait pas on sait pas donc
on s'attend F prend G4 dans sa position
dame B3 dans la partie de Baky il veut
partir par làhaut faire des échecs
peut-être fou qui couvrira des à ce
moment-l c'est très Chud en fait ça peut
déraper Norte quel coup ils ont moins
minute chacun il reste 4 coups ça peut
déraper pour les deux en plus c'est
hyper compliqué 10 secondes pour B allez
faut
s'accrocher grosse game grosse game
aujourd'hui pas mal pas trop aller
s'aventurer sur éche je
CIS P aussi
ça l'air
solide
ça a l'air très solide
Fab
yakoboyev qui s peut-être un poil trompé
15 secondes il est mal auant en plus
maintenant je penseil va faire fout des
5 échecs
ouais ok G6 peêre d d pour souffle quoi
il va se retrouver avec un pion de Mos
F sur dame D3 peut-êre tu fais F3 tu
changé dame tu prends D6 HM peutêre pour
ça fa 5 était pas génial en fait parce
que troquer ce pion F4 le pion D6 c'est
pas le rêve pour les
blancs j'ai l'impression que ça se passe
bien là pour by ce Z
not là il a l'air vraiment bien
ouais bon ben moi je fais c'est ce qui
va se passer truc avec F3 et bon après
faut gagner la finale c'est c'est une
autre débat mais mais c'est cool enfin
c'est est-ce qu'elle est
gagnante pense qu'il a de bonne chance
qu'elle le
soit ça a sué un côté
yakubf position était vraiment
compliquée mais finalement elle s elle
se goupiait plus facilement pour les
Noirs je
crois vou faire l'ordi il a bien il a
bien vu prend les trois prises et F3 là
qui va être fort
faire avant que les Blancs referment le
couvercle si les blancs mettent le fond
F3 voilà bien joué joué B ça c'était
facile f Il F6 ce sera le 40e dur ce qui
était dur c'était fou des7 et ro G6 ça
c'était vraiment dur je pense qu'il l'a
vu he quand il a fait
ça donc là il va prendre du fou pour se
garder le ponger qui défend tout
maintenant 13 chez cpienko aller voir
alors il ou la tour là-haut bien jou
c'est abandon ouis ok bravo o et param a
failli défendre un truc dur mais ok
euh et le trème Laron il est là on se
fait pas du tout nos affaires he ces
résultats le trème Laron qui doit jouer
son 40e coup on fera une pause après le
trème Laron
vite qui est mieux qui est bien mieux
qui a un pion de plus aderse l' assez
faible par que G5 tient le pion H3 il a
la colonne D beaucoup de bonnes choses
dans sa position
J qui commençait si bien pour nous Fab
il fait dam G6 propose d'changer d'AM
pour jouer une petite
finale il faut sûrement aller làdedans
parce que si Adam arrive ver4 ça a l'air
d'être un peu inquiétant F3
ou de double changeant D1 et de mat il a
joué contre qui il a joué Nakamura il a
jouépenko moi ça c'est fait en fait ils
se sont tous jou ceux qui sont à 7 et ça
va flotter à fond ils vont se prendre
des mecs qui jouent pour le gain de tous
les côtés vont devoir
résister mais c'est sûrement le mieux
pour ce aura les blanc ouais mais il
aura le moment des partage ah après si
tout m
g nul il passe pas en
faitout fa serre obligé de forcer c'est
mais bon il peut pas savoir si faire nul
nul en
fait
j'espèree
CER par
mepartage aussi
sera palpitant tout ça pour faire un peu
tous les quatre figures ce soir on
calculera et euh on verra euh ouais donc
Bartel qui a fait des choses bizarres ça
va êtreizi ikarou et si pien Kok Meur et
visit prê
que pr que qui va être en must twin
absolu
ouais
mais en fait on est on est un peu dans
la merde P est pas du tout favori pour
se qualifier en fait c'est
terrible c'est terrible mais mais je
crois que c'est le
cas déà
J qui va jouer contre
pr
et
contre contre contrere petit fou
d'allemand
[Musique]
quoi
il a joué ou pas je pense
pas
non mais il peut redoubler les blancs ou
pas non pas sauf si déjà doublé ou je
sais pas quoi
mais tourner il vient il peut tripler
pour la dernière mais bon faut se calmer
quoi il noir jusqu'à maintenant donc il
a forcément les
Noirs non mais je crois que c'est sûr
cararou c'est sûr
ouais erigizi ikarou c'est sûr donc
ikarou maisigizi pour son départage il
est pas trop mal
ah bienenko il va jouer qui alors le prê
de que il a déjà
joué il jou CER il a déjà joué prê de
que ben il vaer choper je sais pas qui
et il va peut-être jouer un mec qui joue
rien il a joué vidit il a joué tout le
monde en fait tout le monde il va aller
choper du du 6 et demi il a joué carwana
euh il a joué carwana mais il a
joué vraiment tout le monde en fait non
il choper du 6 et demi en fait
alors mais bon faut voir sil font un 6
et demi he je sais pas ça peut être ça
peut être Baki ça peut être peut être n
re ça peut être param mais ça peut être
turbodro en fait ouais c'est quelqu'un
qui joue pour rien
donc lui en fait il est déjà qualifié
bah non parce que siarouan VI gagne
ouais il va faire nul il a un trop bon
départage donc B donc en fait ikarou il
est hyper mal bah non bah
si pourquoi bah s'il fait nul en fait il
est pas qualifié ça il peut être visite
paire ple ou pas oui si visite paire
enfin si pr que gagne il y est pas enfin
c'est terrible en
fait en fait on est dans la merde je
crois
ou ouais enfin irigisi il peut tenter le
tout pour le tout il faut qu'ikaro gagne
en contre quoi
ikaro peut gagner aussi
oui
per non il est bien là tu as pas gagné
encore ça nous arrangerait qu'il gagne
pas en
fait non non il a pas encore
gagné une belle position voilà mais B
qui pas encore gagné bah qui c'est pas
encore gagné non plus hein bon du coup
on fait une pause mais il peut voilà
ouais on fait une pausez on fait une
pause à fin une Z not on va on va
réfléchir tranquillement à tout ça c'est
fini he il y a plus de là oui c'est oui
on revient après ok allez à toute
[Musique]
he
he he
he he he
he
[Musique]
les amis on est de on est de retour on a
l'impression que B a complètement craqué
mais
une position difficile quoi qu'il en
soit faut encore finir pour évidemment
mais il a son pion de
plus son P dépassé maintenant en plus la
tour A8 à2 il fait autre chose F5 il
attaque latéralement le pion B5 c'est
pas mal jou
c'est la position gagnante tu V encore
la jouer quelques coups mais je vois pas
de scénario ça gagne pas là normalement
non ça ferait que rejoindrait les deux
autres
leaders ça a l'air bien je pense qu'il
va
gagner pas
facileant c'est gagnant parce que tu
fais à
bon fa encore la gagner mais je pense
que avec sa technique légendaire il va
la gagner pour gamer il va ouis bon
c'est terminé c'est 40 pion de plus et
donc on va rester sur la partie
d'Alia qui elle va durer un petit
peu
qui va durer un petit peu bah écoute on
va attendre hein que les coups se jouent
on est un
peu est toujours à la mercie des coups
en fait hein norement il y a plus
grandchose à raconter après 4h et demi
de jeu ni avant
ouais c'est
pas c'est pas facile un moment donné de
de
commenter faut que les coups se joue
quoi mais Bak qui je pense qu'il va
tourner il va finir par gagner à mon
avis
en tout cas la dernière les deux
dernières parties qui jouent encore pour
la Calif au candidat c'est la partie
DEAC quand même même si ça va se
terminer quand même et la partie d'alira
puisque ça joue par le hlo le reste dans
la bataille des candidats est terminé
ouais fais voir les parties restant dans
le grand tableau VO s'il a un truc nous
a échappé que il va rater darda quoi ok
bravo darda enfin bon il aura un P de
plus il va quand même la jouer mais
ouais euh
[Musique]
marquant ça c'était marquant ça joue
encore non ça joue encore bon il est
foutu mais qui sait c'est pas encore
abandon
et alors ouais donc vidit F son sait
oker c'est gagnant g sert à rien pour
son ho il ouis va faire nul tu peut-être
la gagner le roi des blancs est quand
même mal pl c'est bon on voit pas trop
la position donc on va rien dire il y a
eu mass de nul il y a Baky qui
joue une partie mais bonà c'est des gens
qui sont
pluson on a rien raté on a rien
raté juste rappor il jou qui j'ai vu
qu'il a
fait mais c'est pourir contre qui donne
ses
point c'est B en
fait je vais
juste ah contre ok bon après il avait
les Noirs non non mais cétait
[Musique]
pas en fait il fait ce qu'il veut il est
battu non
complètement mais ikarou c'est pas dit
que même avec nul il soit qualifié
demain par un un jeu de de pass-p c'est
assez
complexe Fab la SSE tu es pas très
content du résultat et du contenu euh
ridicule aujourd'hui honteux mais bon
les mecs se croient arriver on fait la
fête et puis et puis tu joues comme de
la merde quoi bah ils font un peu les
malins parce qu'ils sont deuxiè non
ouais B je sais pas à quel point ils
font les malins mais je dire là dans le
match tu sens qu'il y a pas eu le
l'implication qu'il fallait le coaching
très mauvais déjà peut-être de
reconduire la même équipe alors que les
mecs ils ont pas forcément la caisse
tous pour faire de matchs semaine et là
le match bon ben ça se passe mal et puis
tu fais tes remplacements une minute
après tu prends tes buts en faisant
rentrer un mec qui perd le ballon direct
quoi en changeant en défense centrale
enfin je veux dire je peux pas être
content de ça de ce que j'ai j'ai vu de
rien en fait voilà c'était naz donc
voilà le
PFC mériter sa victoire malheureusement
euh et puis ben c'est con mais c'est
comme ça après bon écoutez ça remet rien
de spécial en cause sur la saison
toujours en course pour éventuellement
monter mais il faut jouer différemment
de ça faut faut être plus compact plus
solide avoir plus d'envie parce que on
n'est pas meilleur que les autres et
donc le jour où tu as moins envie bah tu
as plus rien de plus même temps moins
donc que ça serve de leçon on verra bien
quoi mais je t'annonce que vous n'allez
pas monter non mais le contenu fa de ce
que je vois c'est je sais c'est de la
merde mais mais le truc c'est que les
autres c'est pas ENF c'est la Ligue 2
quoi ang a mieux jouéin que
nousxer ça joue pas mal je sais
d'ailleurs c'est prochain match pour
nous
mais mais bon ça joue pas ouf la Ligue 2
faut dire ce qu'il y
a
la c'est pas
ouf mais je pense mieux vous êtes
barragiste écoute baragiste déjà quelque
chose
après bar ne monte
pas demoisonn on va
dire é monté fait y a que qui en équipe
de ligue per Ann 80
c'est la seule équipe à perdre des
barrages je crois si vous en avez une
autre dites-moi mais je crois qu'on est
le
seul c'est un peu long là ah bah ouais
alle reste plus que de main après mon
Fab
et après on souffle ouais oua non mais
là en fait en plus je sais pas trop ce
qu'on regarde
quoi on regarde quand même les
parties non non mais je sais mais
importante mais oui le problème c'est
que ouais c'est un regardardable en fait
irregardable on unregardable ou
irregardable un inregardable
ouais c'est trop bon nous ça fait trop
longtemps qu'on commande plus moi que
toi mais même to là ça commence à faire
trop en fait c'est au bout d'un moment
tu décroches un peu
mentalement on s'ennuie trop
quoi pendant trop longtemps à un moment
donné tu non le problème en fait c'est
que en fait la partie importante pour
classement c'est celle-là mais elle est
finie en fait en c'est gagnant pour les
Noirs non pas grand chose à dire et les
autres c'est parti qui vont mettre 3
heures à se décanter pour 5 points et l
quoi ouais pour un tournoi éventuel on
sait pas si ça compte pour quelque chose
ou pas tu que peut-être ricardo est pas
dans les TR ouais c'est trop hy donc là
regarde cette finale là si tu veux c'est
pas ma grande passion là d'être là ou
[Musique]
mais mais du coup
euh ça peut ça devrait gagner pour pour
firou quoi mais ça peut durer encore ça
peut durer en fait le scénario qu'on
pourrait avoir c'est que les nor V
mettre le r G6 vont faire H6 qu' aura un
échange les fous vont s'échanger tu vas
gagner F6 tu auras le tris P TR de
l'autre côté le cavalier qui va essayer
de venir te faire un petit raid machin
et peut-être c'est très solide et cetera
et cetera bon ça doit perdre ça va
perdre à mon avis
mais mais pas tout de suite est-ce que
les candidats c'est l'enfer pour
nous
non non mais il faut qu'il y ait de
l'enjeu évidemment si tu as un joueur
qui a caracole en tête et que ça dure 8h
par jour pour rien bon oui mais tant
qu'il y a de l'enjeu enfin là
aujourd'hui ça va demain il y aura de
l'enjeu mais euh en fait c'est comme si
demain on a nous deux qualifiés et puis
qu'on doit regarder des trucs jusqu'à
plus d'heure
quoi HM ouais mais c'est vraiment la
pire cadence hein la celle-là genre la
cadence de la Coupe du monde c'était
quand même 1h30 ou 1h40 plus 30 secondes
tu avait que 30 minutes de rajout une
fois donc ça allait en fait là ça ce
serait déjà quasiment fini en fait h oui
mais là c'est la cadence la pire
celle-là elle est vraiment et c'est la
même au candidat mais c'est vraiment la
cadence
ouais il y a il y a tu peux pas faire
pire en
fait voah la K frentre bon moi je fais
surtout plaisir à lursaf hein donc ça me
fait ça fait très plaisir ça fait très
plaisir ouais moi je fais ça pour le
collectif hein toi tu as un peu mieux
LTI que moi
làdessus enfin ou moins bien
LTI tu mets beaucoup moins bien
l'URSAF ce qui est grave en ce qui doit
être je je fais ce que je peux hein mais
oui ça va t'embêter non ouais ouais
ouais tu dois être faudrait changer de
statue ouais tu dois être un peu écuré
quand même
c'est terrible pour Fab
issu à très très haut
niveau la cadence saifie quand même
c'est c'est la pire pub pour les échecs
quoi en c'est rien est mieux en fait en
terme de publicité c'est dommage parce
que le tournoi est vraiment beau sur le
papier hein non en fait le le la course
devant tout ça c'est cool mais comment
ça se passe
quoi et puis à ce départage qui pour moi
ne permet pas l'équité du tournoi donc
pour moi c'est pas normal quoi et là ça
ça peut se jouer à ce truc d'équité à la
fin et problême d'équité aussi flagrant
je trouve ça un peu embêtant si on a le
cas
après ouais Yanis donc qui nous pose une
question est M joue m en 3 + 2 sur
interneten longue en fait c'est pas le
cas il joue très bien en 3+ 2 contre des
advers qui jou en 3 + 2 mais le contenu
ça sera quand même mieux ce qu'il fait
en partie lente mais ses adversaires
aussi quoi donc son
différentiel là dans ce tournoi ce qu'il
a fait par rapport avant
bah c'est moins bien mais c'est pas qui
joue moins bien à cette cadence quoi
c'est aussi une autre adversité en face
machin
et qu' a plus de temps pour trouver les
coups et et voilà quoi et en plus il a
pas fait son meilleur tournoi dans ce
qu'il est capable de faire quoi ma
disait quoi ouais lui c'est deux parties
ouais lui bien le 45 + 30 ou le 30 + 30
mais jouit des des allers-retours h tout
à tuas ton appareillement mais tu joues
deux parties contre le mec tu joues pas
du coup il y a pas l'histoire blanc noir
ou quoi il a pas l'histoire blanc noire
et puis peut-être que en cas de 11 on
peut réfléchir à bah au pire nprs tu
fais match en 3 + 2 quoi pourquoi pas
mais on a le droit de faire nul non
pourquoi en fait faire nul quand on peut
ne pas faire nul dommage mais pourquoi
pas en gen ça existe dans beaucoup de
sport enfin ça existe pas s'il y a des
des éliminations voilà même là tu bah tu
as un gagnant tant mieux bien tu as
quelun qui pe ou pas enfin là pour le
coup j'en sais rien c'est pas évident B
parce que c'est plus
marrant nul aussi quoi bah tu peux faire
nul dans le 30 plus machin puis après tu
ou tu enchaînes
quoi ah ouais 20h45 il y a l'homme qui
joue tu le sens comment ce match c'est à
domicile ou c'est à lî
d'ailleurs j'imagine qu qui veut du S
ouais mais qu'est qui veut des audiences
quoi qu'est qui veut faire rentrer de la
caillass en fait moi je sais que le
départage c'est ce qui te rapporte le le
plus de d'audience donc c'est dommage de
sans privé si tu peux le mettre quoi
parce que sinon tu as tout un tas de
mecs qui de toute façon vont se dire ah
bah nul c'est bien j'ai fait nul avec
les Blancs à machin moi je suis content
enfin tu vas de nouveau avoir ce
problème des échecs ou tu as trop de ça
donc quitte à faire un truc au MO tu
enlèves la nulle au moins les mecs sont
obligés de jouer quoi à un moment donné
vos échecs sinon tu fais for coup viol
alors tu pe enfin tu peux le faire en
coupe en Suisse tu fais comme tu veux
quoi tu peux faire en double élimination
enfin tu fais ce que tu veux déjà tu
changes la cadence en fait non double
élimination ça va bien c'est pas mal
hein le double élimination mais il faut
que ce soit bien fait ouais voilà ce que
je vois oui parce que c'est très très
très mal fait mais sinon c'est pas
mal ça offre un vrai truc mais en fait
faut que le truc de ta première
élimination après ça speed quoi pas que
ce soit long comme
ça faut que tu joues direct en 3 + 2 en
fait quand tu a été éliminé une fois tu
ça dégage tu dégages un peu
ouais non double élimination ça peut
offrir des beaux trucs mais évidemment
ça ça doit être ça pe pas être que H
joueurs au début quoi faut que ce soit
puis il faut que ça bouge un peu le le
tableau des
éliminations
faut quand même regarder le format des
lentes ah mais en fait 45 + 30 tu sais
le niveau de jeu à s mentier je pense
qu'il est pas mauvais
ouais en bette Maxime joue mieux queun
amateur en longue quand même il faut
faut quand même imaginer quoi donc en
45+ 30 ils sont quand même hyper forts
enfin tu peux leur enlever peut-être 50
60 points lo par rapport à leur force
mais ça veut dire que Carlsen ça jouait
encore 2785 enfin ça suffit quoi c'est
pas non plus différence elle est pasque
on a pas un gage
[Musique]
de enfin on voit dans ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui par exemple ça des parties
lentes ça veut pas dire qu' V forcément
toujours très bien joué alors dans
l'ensemble bien mais on va perdre
marginalement je pense pour un énorme
gain de
d'intérêt et de de plein de choses ouais
non la perte de niveau elle est
marginale j'ai dis 50 point c'est
peut-être 25 c'est peut-être 60 mais
c'est peu quoi mais par contre au lie de
t'embêter 7h devant une partie ben le
truc il est fini en 2h max et pour moi
45 + ça devrait être les longues en fait
he déjàant h ils connaissent tellement
la théorie il connaissent enfin si tu
compares aux années 60 longue en fait je
pense qu'ils ont plus de temps pour la
réflexion tactique en 45 + 30 qu'à
l'époque avec 2h 40 coups d's on pour
faire 45 + 15 ou plus 10
30 mais en fait faut vraiment se rendre
compte qu'avant les mecs il découvraent
des trucs qui machin maintenant souvent
ils connaissent les plans ils savent
tout ce que disait l'ordi sur la
position enfin c'est tu as quand même
une assistance de jeu qui est tellement
importante et qu'on avait pas du tout
avant
ouais deutant que les ordis sont
meilleure la partie longue n'est plus la
référence exactement ouais donc oui
c'est un truc qui fait plus aucun sens
c'est pour ça que c'est si bizarre en
fait quand tu regardes c'est juste que
c'est un truc d'une autre époque qui
avec les évolutions technologiques et
l'évolution de l'humanité n'a plus pluse
d'être quoi mais il y a un truc spécial
hein c'est queche c'est hyper
conservateur le milieu
[Musique]
h beaucoup de joueurs vont pas du tout
être contents
de très longue ça joue l'endurance aussi
ouais mais bon du coup tu leur fais
jouer deux parties tu vas jouer
l'endurance aussi hein de parties de 45
plus 30 tous les jours oui mais je enfin
l'endurance après je sais pas est-ce que
c'est est-ce qu'on doit avoir de
l'endurance enfin on doit en avoir mais
je est-ce que c'est une en je veux dire
est-ce qu'on doit faire des match de
foot de 10h alors pour que les mecs son
endurant enfin ça suffit comme ça quoi
non mais un moment donné quand tu fais
un truc qui est quand même un
divertissement et un loisir tu dois
quand même garder le côté divertissant
quoi ça peut pas être une purge
oui non non mais c'est un truc c'est en
genre les échecs c'est un jeu ça existe
pas pour
c'est pas fait pour ça quoi mais
ouais c'est fait quand même pour
partager comme toute activité humaine
humaine pour moi c'est fait pour
partager du plaisir avec les autres en
moi je pars quand même de ce principe là
qu'une activité humaine si elle fait de
bien à personne ou bon après bon écoute
peutêtre ceux qui jouent là ils sont pas
je sais pas hein ce qu'ils en pensent
mais je pr conna quelques-uns ils
seraient pas contre le fait soit un peu
plus court
quoi et euh on peut juste checker by
comme
ça la finale ce qu'elle donne elle va
durer elle bouge pas trop ok je pense
qu'il va la gagner mais elle va pas être
facile non ça m'a pas l'air simple en
fait je sais pas trop exactement ce
qu'on
veut toute façon par les échecs à partir
moment où tu arrives à haut niveau tu
joues pas trop pour le fun non mais ça
oui même peut-être en rapide mais du
coup faut au moins que ce soit fun pour
les gens qui regardent au moins pour le
public je sa pas moi je pars du principe
que quand tu fais du de la compétition
et et que tu es payé quand même pour un
truc comme ça tu es quand même là pour
donner du plaisir aux gens qui regardent
pour moi je trouve que c'est quelque
chose important non mais après comme
dans toute activité tuas tuas pas envie
de faire trucire l'histoire du fun je
sais pas trop quoi dire enfin tu es pas
là pour faire le guignol mais dans tous
les sports en fait mais çaempêche pas
que tu puiss être heureux et content de
pratiquer genre je sais pas quand
Ronaldinho joue au foot mais c'était pas
un guignol he Ronaldinho je sais pas il
avait le smile il était heureux tu vois
enfin c'est un des gars c'était le plus
ça se voyait mais parce que je pense que
le fait de donner du plaisir aux gens ça
te rend heureux
aussi met Ronaldinho dans des States
vides et un truc
h
j tu pens pas qu'il s'amuse autant mais
du coup ça veut pas dire tu dois plus
t'entraîner et faire n'importe quoi
enfin tu as une exigence à avoir pour le
haut niveau mais que la pratique reste
sympa et tu prennes du plaisir et je
sais pas tu les joueurs de tennis des
fois font un jolis coup ils sont
contents quoi tous en fait euh et cetera
donc aux échecs tu peux être content pas
chaque coup que tu joues mais je sais
pas tu fais une belle partie machin que
ça soit cool quand même quoi donc donc
tu peux quand même jouer pour être
content en tu es pas que là pour être
malheureux en pour moi de toute façon
enfin le la genre de communion avec le
public l'échange comme ça de tu vois
d'émotions positives enfin l'échange
d'émotions que ça positive ou négatif
d'ailleurs mais l'échange d'émotion avec
les autres et le côté partage ça rend
l'être humain heureux en fait moi je
suis convaincu de ça que l'humain enfin
il a une une nature profonde de d'avoir
envie d'échanger avec les autres et donc
là les donc là les échecs tu cette case
là tu la remplis pas du tout en fait tu
crées un truc qui fait tellement chier
le monde que ouais tu es en muré tu es
en muré dans ton trucé dans et ça je
pense moi je crois vraiment ce truc je
suis peut-être complètement délu ou quoi
mais je crois vraiment que la nature
enin une partie de la nature humaine
profonde une des caractéristiques de la
nature humaine profonde c'est le partage
en fait avec d'autres humains ou avec
d'autres avec la vie quoi dans sa
globalité
la pratique serait aussi mieux diffusé
mieux rémunéré alors ça je suis pas sûr
mtk1 parce que là c'est déjà très bien
payé très bien rémunéré c'est juste que
ben voilà les fonds viendraient
peut-être un peu différemment quoi pour
dire la chose de manière simple non
c'est bien rémunéré là c'est très bien
rémunéré même c'est juste que peut-être
que tu aurais moins de c'est un autre
débat
ça
r camp c'est pour ça que j'ai arrêté
j'ai ressenti de la Harne plus que de
l'échange ben ouais par mais je suis sûr
si tu fais des rapides que tu mets 1000
personnes dans une salle qui
applaudissent qui gueulent et tout bah
tu vas le sentir l'échange en fait
peut-être pas pendant la partie parce
que c'est quand même un jeu de combat il
y a quand même un côté combat mais avant
et après tu auras senti que tu as fait
profiter autru enfin tu as fait quelque
chose pour les autres et moi je trouve
que c'est un truc important je pense que
l'humain a besoin de ça en
fait
bah toute façon je l'ai bien vu à la
dernière backup tuas plein de joueurs
qui étaient hyper heureux qui reviennent
à chaque fois parce que bah tu es
content tuas le public qui est là machin
4 c'est la première ligne de l'ordi he
sur R tour pr je pense qu'
veut cavalier D4 pas cavalier 5 Cali D7
ouais sur pion prend il ve C4 tuas pas t
prend il cavalier E5 c'est bien joué
c'est inattendu au possible pour moi
mais hyper bien
joué mais bel il a des éclart de génie
quoi j'ai l'impression ouais il fait des
trucs bizarres ou qui vont pas c'est un
éclair ouais mais à
qure tu regardes les sub batiles et je
me marre vraiment bah ouais ouais mais
moi pour moi il y a ce on d après les
c'est pas le foot le foot tu vois une
balle Bou
mais en fait moi je dis que j'ai déjà
prouvé que c'était faisable donc en fait
moi j'ai prouvé que votre argument que
vous me sortez depuis 10 ans de me dire
que les échec c'est pas le foot et que
les gens il vont pas venir regarder
parce que c'est pas marrant en fait moi
j'ai prouvé par la de manière directe
que vous aviez tort donc ça c'est cet
argument là de dire qu'on peut pas
mettre des gens dans un public devant
des parties d'échec à kiffer ça j'ai
prouvé que c'était faux déjà donc cet
argument ne me le ressorteit jamais
parce que vous allez à l'encontre de ce
qui a été prouvé en fait donc ça vous
pouvez plus me le dire donc ça c'est
juste factuellement
faux je parle des échecs de très haut
niveau ben ouais alors enfin tu fais le
même format tu mets les joueurs de très
haut niveau et les gens ils vont fa oui
mais ce plus costuk contre Bacro tu sais
c'est Carlsen Nakamura donc non ça va
être le même
résultat ça va être exactement le même
résultat même encore en plus fou parce
qu'il y a encore plus de monde et encore
plus de
hype mais après donc ça j'ai vraiment
prouvé que c'était faux mais c'est juste
que il faut avoir envie de partager
quelque chose avec les autres et pas
être enfermé dans son
truc pour fou ouais mais on pensait que
c'était génial et en fait bah c'est bien
mais c'est ouais ça reste chaud juste
c'est bien mais ça va peut-être pas
suffire mais mais c'est mieux que s'il
avait pas gagné
quoi clairement en fait tu penses qu'on
qu'on puisse faire une énorme salle avec
1000 personnes en spectateur alors moi
je enin donnez-moi un million d'euros je
vous mets 1000 personnes dans une salle
qui regardent des échecs et qui sont
contents d'être en plus sont cont d'être
juste donnez-moi l'argent mais je vais
le faire je vais juste vous le prouver
une une 1è fois mais bon j'ai pas accès
au millions qu'ont les autres pour
organiser des tournois mais donne-moi
l'accès aux 5 millions d'euros que le
grand chestour avait chaque
année il va il va se passer un truc mais
ça je te le garantis en fait les 1000
personnes tu vas les avoir après tu peux
continuer à donner des millions au même
qui font toujours la même chose hein et
je peux aussi te garantir que ça
marchera jamais mais non ça c'est faux
dire que je peux pas remplir 1000
personnes je l'ai rempli très facilement
non mais là la backup j'ai vendu 215
places sans faire un marketing sans rien
en 48 he h h g 1000 c'est pas beaucoup
hein c'est ça va non non avec 1 million
je le fais par exemple mais même avec
moins tu ferais mais avec un million
d'autant plus mais avec 1 million je
fais peut-être même beaucoup plus oui
bah je remplis
stadeou je peux je peux faire je peux
faire
plus après qu'on pas tu don 1000 € à
1000 personnes pour qu'il fasse mais on
te dit il cont
venir que je vais même faire payer les
places en fait c'est pas je vais pas les
payer c'est eux qui vont payer pour
venir comment tu fais pour bien jouer
s'il y a 1000 personnes qui gueulent à
côté bah soit tu t'habitues soit tu mets
un cas quand il BR comment font les
footballeurs pour bien jouer un stade
com non mais tuas thabituer aussi au
bruit il reste quel place sur la BUP al
pas joueur turtles a public je crois
encore j'ai pas vérifié mais il en reste
vraiment pas beaucoup il en restait
moins de 10 je crois mais si tu veux
mettre le casque anti bruit pour jouer
tu mettas un casque antibruit et tu
seras pas gêné quoi mais euh mais moi
j'ai déjà joué des parties du bruit en
vrai en Coupe de France aux échecs il y
avait il y avait un festival je sais pas
trop ce que c'était un truc avec des
dans la rue etc la musique techno à fond
B j'ai très bien joué ma partie c'est
une de mes meilleures quoi moi je m'en
fous ça ça ça mête pas du tout
quoi mais non non c'est c'est vraiment
faisable en fait c'est moi j'aime pas
trop le discours des féti des échecs il
a les échecs c'est chiant non les échecs
c'est
un des jeux les plus amusants au monde
qui mérite juste beaucoup mieux que ce
qu'il a actuellement c'est tout en fait
non mais je crois que c'est les gens qui
veulent pas changer les trucs qui te
disent façon ça peut pas marcher donc on
reste comme ça mais ça pe marcher ok
laisser la chance quoi mais ça peut pas
juste argument et il y a plus de débat
et on s'arrête quoi non non c'est génial
les échecs et pour l' côté trich je
feris comment avec 1000 personnes non
mais non mais ne t'inquiète pas en faitf
c'est il y aura zéro problème de trich
en aura beaucoup moins qu'actuellement
d'ailleurs ça je peux te le garantir
aussi
tu peux même faire des des brouilleurs
d'ondes que les gens entendent pour que
les joueurs puissent pas entendre tu
peux faire tu peux faire des caches de
ver enfin tuas 1000 manières en
fait mais la triche ce sera aussi plus
efficace que sur énormément de tournois
qu'on peut voir tuas des tournois avec
des millions d'euros où tu cliques de
chez toi tout seul quoi donc bon si tu
si on parle de triche je crois pas que
le problème soit dest public parce que
avec des témoins de par partout et
compagnie je seraai un peu moins inquiet
en fait que plein de trucs que je
vois après d'près de ce que j'ai entendu
je suis plus le seul à penser comme
ça il y a une évolution quand même qui
se
passe A4 il a pas l'air méga comestible
on peut vérifier ce qu'on disait en fait
enfin prendre comme ça c'est possible
mais l'idée elle est jolie c'est de
faire ce coup là pour échanger ce pion
tu peux pas prendre du pion évidemment
ça te coûte la tour c'est très joli et
si tu prends de la tour tu te prends une
fourchette donc tu es pas ravi et donc
tu vas te faire échanger ton pion C
contre le pion d par ailleurs si on fait
t prend
à4 il a cavalier5 roi bouge C D7 attaque
le fou on le sauve et le pion court
alors après tu adame tu as donner ton
fou donc déjà ça te coûte un fou cette
histoire
euh bon ok tu as une tour qui se bat
bien contre les pièces en final hein
mais euh bon et donc c'est incroyable ce
A4 qui sort de nulle part mais donc
c'est très bien joué de sa Bar parce
qu'il veut réduire le nombre de pions
sur les chiquers en plus ça fait une
faiblesse en B5 il pourra attaquer avec
le CAH D4 ou quoi et peut-être ça va le
sauver cette idée mais bravo enfin
vraiment joli coup là pour le coup il
faut juste AER que les échaque ne sont
pas un spectacle pour un live grand
public moi ça me va faut juste faire un
truc en plus on doit faire la place
ouais le problème c'est que tu as tout
l'argent en fait tu as tout de l'argent
public en plus globalement
donc pas d'un côté demander d'avoir de
l'argent publique pour faire un truc
donc nous on a payé avec nos impôts
comme toi et de faire un truc qui plaît
à personne enfin un moment donné c'est
un peu
je sais pas quoi non mais je sais pas
trop ce qu'il dit enfin je crois qu'il
veut pas qu'on remplace mais en fait
déjà c'est pas pour remplacer mais à un
moment donné enfin tu as des réalités
aussi quoi en les choses elles sont
faites pour les gens pour kiffer je sais
pas mais en fait on peut laisser faire
aussi enfin je sais pas oui mais
actuellement tu peux pas le faire parce
que tu as aucun financement non je sais
que c'est les bâtons dans les roues tout
le temps et que bah là tu peux pas ouais
tu es bloqué en fait mais sur4 il est
vraiment fort
h et je crois que c'est signé d'après ce
qu'on nous dit chez ouais c'était à
chaque fois que je suis passé devant
c'était fini hein doncarou ikarou ça va
dépendre des appareimentss en fait bah
il des résultats tuasir nimporel
appariment tuas
beau carou il va jamais qui va essayer
de le battre bah tu peux contrer tu peux
ce que je ça va être hyper chaud demain
ça va être asse sympa et Baky bah écoute
ça ça va ça va tournicter longtemps
ouais Micha qui est venu voir
aussi et je pense que c'est peutêtre
plus gagnant en fait part vers la nulle
peut-être avec ce coup brillant
excellent franchement très très j'
aurais pas pensé peut-être avec les
Blancs genre tu as une micro chance mais
avec les noir j'aurais jamais vu c'est
trop
beau vraiment un très très joli coup
mais tu vois a pas de double point
d'exclamation cel
je
pour les Français au candidat ça
dépendra de demain
mais on pourra te dire demain on pourra
dire demain ouais là c'est là il y a
trop de
facteurs il y a encore des chances à
l'heure actuelle demain peut-être qu' il
y en aura plus peut-être qu'il y en aura
beaucoup plus peut-être qu'il y en aura
énormément j'ai reçu votre cahier votre
almana hier ah c qui sont d'excellentes
factures et contenu qualitatif tous les
deux ben écoute bonne lecture he j'ai
envie de te dire doc GG tu seras la
backup ou pas du
coup mich qu' en a marre du Grand Suisse
ah bah Micha elle veut que du
ouis si tu veux tu les ramènes à la
backup on te les on te les
signe moi je vais commencer à faire
payer les signatures hein obligé Gotham
il fait payer 30 € la signature bah les
gens qui venaient à son event signature
le machin plus cher que la
BUP peut-être tu peux prendre un selfie
un truc oui mais bon ok ça
va tu es déjà millionnaire tu prends je
sais pas combien tu peux faire plaisir
aux gens
oigé d'être un r
quoi je pense qu'en fait c'est vraiment
le plus
efficace pour des cons non
mais ça maintenant moi j'en suis
convaincu 30 € vraiment je tu ve après
toutes ces années d'expérience dans le
milieu entre guillemets de l'influence
vraiment le plus intéressant à faire
c'est ça marche vraiment
c'est minable
quoi pas decup pour moi j'attends votre
stage en montagne h c'est qu' faut qu'on
fasse un chage en montagne hein mais si
on peut écoute faut qu'on en fasse plein
faut ouis dans la montagne pour
l'instant on peut absolument rien
annoncer dépendant trop de trucs mais
quand on pourra on fera moi je continue
de les faire un peu avec Mao mais toi tu
es un peu par trimestre quoi voilà le
prochain il sera à Paris fin janvier
e je sais ou ouais fa quand même penser
aussi au parisiens quoi le faire plaisir
un peu le donner de la joie dans cette
vie
trist on vient on vient une fois par an
faire mais tu devrais faire payer
nettement plus cher à Paris parce que tu
devrais dédom mais tu devrais te
dédommager du fait dire ouion vous
comprenez je dois me déplacer dans cette
ville non toute façon vous avez plus
grand plus grand pouvoir d'achat pouvoir
d'achat vous volez toute l'né
c'est mais mais donc voilà ouais ça puis
après je sais pas trop on verra dans
l'année on a le stage d'été mais mais
bon avec K si on peut refaire l'été
prochain on vous dira si on peut pas là
bon on réfléchira comment on fait mais
il y en aura d'autres tôt ou tard mais
là il y a pas de date il y a pas on peut
pas trop on sait pas donc c'est cas de
jouer bien
joué tu ve sortir toi
repartiras V es
cont jus Liena qui a commencé à manger
en fait
hein un truc qui se passe
ave
calinousin ça s alors qu'il y a que des
gagnants au 7 mais enfin les gens ont
joué le jeu qu' devaient jouer depuis
longtemps quoi enfin ils ont joué pour
pour la Calif donc bon bravo à eux bravo
eu oua ils ont ils ont fait le jeu
hein
allezc bonne
chance match bon samedi à
toi que je faire ouis pas trop trop j'en
ai fait deux cet été là j'en ai pas trop
j'en ai pas du tout de prévu en fait
mais j'ai pas pris ma retraite encore
mais faire vendre tes
autographes
si si je donne toujours des courses
sinon jeis pas comen il a jou prend 3
j'y pensais mais je dis ça va être
complètement nul ça bah il veut P on
prend C4 A3 et en fait tu peux jamais
gagner G5 parce que le pion F part je
crois que ça fait nul non ça fait nul en
force je crois tu fais ro prend DC roi
D4 A3 bou bou 3
C4 C1 machin prend6 prend h ou tu fais
H6 et tu dis et voilà ça va faire nul
pour pour et puis
peut-être non 4 incroyable quelle belle
défense peutêre ça va être la fin qui ça
joue plus pour rien en fait ou donc on
se quittera peut-être peut-être
là est-ce qu'il a un lien on peut
técrire dans prend des cours
ouais tu peux me trouver al il y a via
le site de K il a tu peux me trouver sur
pas mal de réseaux sociaux et m'écrire
ou où j'ai déjà mis la fiche du stage
par exemple où il y a la mon adresse
mail donc tu pour me trouver facilement
soit sur Twitter sur Instagram sur
inedine sur via le site de
K le formulaire existe plus ok bon c'est
un vieux formulaire de toute façon
c'est un peu périmées les infos qu'il y
a dessus mais l'adresse mail était bonne
euh alors pourquoi elle a pas pris en C
il se prenait une fourchette s'il
prenait où il perdait sa tour
euh mais bon voilà enfin sur tous les
réseaux que je t'ai dit je suis à mon
propre nom donc tu tapes mon nom prénom
tu vas me trouver et tu pourras m'écrire
message privé ou trouver les infos ou
quoi et et normalement je consulte et je
réponds si s'il y a rien euh
essaye via keV ou quoi
non mais il va te chesscom machin oui tu
peux écire sur chesscom aussi j'ai mon
pseudo chesscom tu m'écris dessus ouais
ça donnait ça la partie je pense ou ch
si tu veux enfin il y a de partout
quoi PIM
ouais ça c'est juste nul he enfin tu ou
cavalier ça défend contre contre un
pion ils dans son
carré al pourquoi il mange pas
directement bah je pense qu'il s'est
levé là il est soit pas là soit il une
proposition de nul et puis qu'il
accepté
pas gag contre il remonte un peu il a
raté son début deour je crois qu'il
gagne des points quand Mme ou je crois
qu'il fait pas un si mauvais
tournoi non non mon pseudocom c'est Fabi
mon vrai pseudo c'est juste
que éclairé j' oublé mon
pass mais il est pas sin son gagné 3,6
points il gagne va faire quasiment plus
10 bah oui non il fait un beau tournoi
en fait mais c'est juste qu'il a perdu
la première et ouais il va être à 50 %
mais c'est pas mal quand même il a pas
fait le tournoi par devant il a pas pesé
sur le tournoire côté il il a 12 ans ENF
il a 14 je sais pas mais
non
oui pas mal
[Musique]
mich
5 et demi tu vois ceux qui étaient plus
en cour ça un B qu ils sont fout ils
sont quasiment tous fait nul on sait pas
pourquoi
mais ok bon juste est peut-être plus
fort il joue toujours là contre is je
crois qu' toujours en
piste
[Musique]
gag je crois qu'il va
gagner
pour est dans la merde de partout
quoi me se battent comme des fous il don
tout non maisandid serait
bien
Naka est content c'est pas wesle ça va
c'est une tête de candidat
quoi
mais oui mais il revient
[Musique]
déconne je crois qu'il un truc avec F6 C
je comprends pas tropit B4 F D4 je
comprends qu'il est pas joué à fait leur
dit il est content il une qualité de
plus mais en fait même quel plan faire
avec les
Noirs je comprends pas trop le mais il
revient avec la tour il machine ouais
mais je crois que tu fais
rien mais enfin moi ça me ferait peur
hein franchement non mais les pion
disparaissent là tu fais k C5 tu prends
à 4 tu non mais décision normale enfin
j'en sais rien ça normal mais écoute il
a trouvé ce A4 hyper bien joué bravo
hein non mais c'est magnifique hein ce
qu'il a fait ok bravo d'avoir fait nul
là bien joué Bartel
quoi et donc ça va très tout simplifieré
il y aura plus de pioncher les blancs ah
il y a une idée j'ai compris ça ça ça
ça ro 4
ça bah ro B5
ça et euh et c'est pas de
Dr ça doit être nul
OK et je peux faire autre chose en fait
j'ai joué vite
cherch alors a 5 c'est pas
con on suit plus de B en fait on suit le
comme il reste de rondes on suit la
course au candidat en fait là ce qui est
l'intérêt du tournoi en fait de base
donc on a suivi toute la tête de tournoi
et B qui on le suit un peu en fond donc
on le met de temps en temps pour voir ce
qui se passe mais en fait là ça joue
pour les candidats bah qui ça joue plus
pour rien en fait c'est fini et là il se
trouve que ala ben il est encore en
cours surtout depuis la victoire de Naka
alors évidemment on a dit que c'était
très compliqué machin de calculer de
enfin bon c'est un Chmil B
mais cette partie là elle peut valoir
son pesant d'or à la fin de la saison
pour savoir s qu'il va au candidat ou
pas la partie de Baki contakbf qui gagne
ou qui perd ça a aucun impact sur rien
en fait h donc c'est normal de suiv
vivre la bagarre au candidats surtout
qu'il reste que deux rondes dans dans ce
tournoi donc c'est quand même c'est fini
je quoi on a sui B avant mais là on suit
les joueurs qui peuvent
en fait quand le roi sé loigne pour par
Fab le truc tu as toujours le fou qui
couvre comme il est en
B4 en fait nous de base en fait on peut
pas faire fou C1 pour expliquer ça fou
prang g 5 5 qui a F7 donc là ça va pas
donc après on s'est dit qu'on pouvait
prendre en F6 mais du coup c'est nul et
là du coup a une nouvelle idée c'est de
faire A5 de garder le fou en B4 sur le
SOC d'aller avec le roi attaquer le
cavalier le décaler bouffer les pions et
après envoyer le pion
h B c'est ce qu'il fait il a fait F5
direct c'est pas
con al pourquoi leur dit pas que c'est
gagnant c'est pas
complètement sur ro B3 là il se fait pas
triquer6 4
bah il doit penser qu'il bouffe les
pions que le roi est
[Musique]
loin je comends on pas fait à 5 pour
aller fou en B4 en
fait ta turbine
ouais fait ça ça m' l'air 1000 fois plus
fort je compr pas d'ailleurs pourquoi
c'est pas plus gagnant ENF gag en tout
cours non par que là j'ai l'imession F5
scén fait ro B3 ro
A45 je peux plus
empêcher pr B3 jeis Plô partir en
F8 c'est quoi ce G6 à chaque fois ah
caver H4 il sacrifie ah oui mais fa si
j'avais gardé le pion peut-ê il faisait
la même et il faisait F
d' je sais
pas mais vas-y fais voir faut que tu
mettes la position
ouais il a du bol Bartel quand même que
ça tienne ça là tu prends TR ça il a pas
trop ouais non non non ça il avait pas
bien joué de la part d'Ali resa quand
même ah la PR elle est faile c'est quoi
c'est roi C4 blanc ro G6 noir 3 noir
cavalier
3 et pion H7 A6 et G5
F6 hyper intéressant très noir très au
noir nous on vou de faire à
5 position est hyper
intéressante tuends sur A5
A5 bon il F7 ça va mais bon euh
ok bon je v dire la défense F7 ok pour
prend F75 5 G7 j'imagine ouais je sais
pas
C6
b4ou il est je pense quand même qu'
prend à 5 devrait ah ouais qu' prend à 5
et il part ouais mais bon ok
prend c'est donc pour ça qu'il a
commencé par ro F5 et après je fais pas
F7 je fais juste le con je B5 F B4 il
dis que c'est quand même très nul euh il
fait roi A4 tu fais roi
F5 il fait le fameux F7 disons F ro
F4 D4 mais il va vers C6
encoreier
reprend55 C6 fou8 ouais
prend5 moi j'aurais déjà en jeenvoyé le
pion j'aurais fait h5y H5
5 ah ouais ok je vais faire ro F6 c'est
le temps que que
ouais tu vas faire cavalier F3 roi prend
F7 et tu vas ramener ton roi
h déclorer dans le carré c'est fini
ouais
bonne tentative mais
ok très bonne tentative
av parce que tu tu peux paniquer en
disant ça je dire ça ça ça ça ça ça ça
ça ça ouais mais il va revenir fa
trouver un chemin pour aller vers A1 ou
H2 ou ouais mais jeurais pas
complètement
confiant tu V
faire C5 j'aurais
ça H4
fa TR qu' B3 je pense c'est le seul c
plus D3 je pense tu te met mauvaise op
du RO ouais il fa qu' ouais mais ça
tu non mais la question c'est pas que tu
vois c'est que de loin est-ce que tu
veux rentrer dedans ah oui H3 cavalier
D2 H2 k H2 ouais mais bon non non non
mais tu peux te planter l'avoir he ça ça
fait penser des exercices qu ouais ouais
ça fait penser au mais c'est dur
hein
is c'est drôle parce que sur H dame le
roi était en F5 et a G3 échec
mer
craque
cavalier ça une agilité à te planter des
forchettes à droite à
gauche c'est
chaud Ker il a fini ou pas euh je crois
ouais il a gagé
ok bah qui ça va durer des
plombes je sais pas si va finir par la
gagner ou
pas ça se peut que non ça se peut que
oui
moi j'endraer le fou F8 du coup que je
sais pas je me dirais que ça les blancs
ils peuvent se planter
[Musique]
h par que le fou5ordi ce que j'aime pas
trop c'est quand tu fais fais CER des
deux ouais mais fa fite fais voir déjà
on a vu l' vente roi A4 et là il y a pas
encore
G6 H4 prend
G6 mais je peux ah non non il
H7
dommage mais par contre je peut-être te
faire
ça
non ah non 5 F7
qui je
prends
C5
F42
[Musique]
attendse
chaque
[Musique]
je suis un peu mais bon je peux
faire4 non pas du
tout
mais j'essaie de courir avec
mon
hyper
facile faudra que tu AR à me bloquer
avec ton roit je sais pas où mais bon ça
va pas
suffire non mais là là non ça ça
gagne tu vas faire tu vas caler un échec
avant j'ai
TR c'est
mais bon pas loin
[Musique]
deong tu peux te tromper à un moment en
fait en tout cas faut la jouer bah c'est
qui
réfléchi est-ce que il y a qu figure ou
peut-être il se trompe
[Musique]
machin
sur la nul est
signé dans cas d'ici un quart d'heure on
va le savoir mais
ouis on peut se
barrer bah je sais pas c'est vous voulez
si voir la fin il fait F F reg comment
ça se
finit engagé dans notre dans notre folie
donc la partie de B on attend que ça se
finisse je crois que l'ORD aime pas à
cause de roi roi des
TR je pense qu'en gros faut faire gaffe
à ce genre de
scénario c'est nul de spoil
ouais après ça pass grand
chose je crois que ça va spoil quelques
secondes il a fait F F8 en fait il a
pas G6 machin
ouais mais c'est qui font les cons de
bah ou de mettre
directettre une pénalité de 150000 € par
résultat mis en avance quoi tu les
termines quoi tu sont en liquidation
quoi
et marquant en fait il a fini ou pas je
sais
pas je suis pas content ah mais moi je
mettrai des amendes à tout le monde je
je ferai plein de truc il est pas fini
il peut-être la
sauver
possible en tout cas il se bat il se bat
il se bat à fond pour essayer de la
sauver il galère mais
ouais bon il va faire G6 et cavalier H4
c'est bah en plus on sait qu'il l'a
trouvé quoi ouais non mais genre dans
tous les
cas
et darda qui a fait une compre gche hein
bravo darda le CH il continue à laisser
des plumes m plus que des plumes àf un
peage quo c'est beau toute ta
fourrureage G6
joug cavalier H4 G5 et G6 qui pr
f86 cavalier qui G5 et merci au
revoir 2717
g st bien
réfléchi je préfère
suivre on te l'interdit pas en fait on
te dit juste que là on est là pour
suivre sur sur la fin de compétition le
la course au candidats après on t'oblige
pas à suivre la course au candidat
enfin c'est ce qui nous paraît
sportivement important
après on oblige personne à rien
il faire G4 je pense
ouais non G4 F7 F6 k
g65 fourchette quand même il y en avit
partout la
fourchette il va prendre il y aura plus
de pion sur chiqu plus de pièces plus
rien donc la est signé écoutez nous on
va vous laisser là parce que le la la
bataille est terminée à mon avis ça va
durer encore un un certain certain
moment mais ça
c'est dur de dire ça peut faire nul ça
peut gagner compliqué et euh et marquant
et marquant pareil marquant qui est un
peu sous pression c'est un peu l'inverse
alors que by c'est lui qui met qui met
la
pression donc on se retrouvera demain
pour la journée complètement décisive
Fab à partir de 15h
bah ça va se battre sur sur tous les
échelons enfin sur tous les échelons sur
toute la tête du tournoi mais sur sur
toutes les premières tes puisqueil
devrait pas se rencontrer entrex les
joueurs qui ont 7 etnemi et donc ça va
être une joyeuse
fête et à mon avis ouais on va avoir
besoin d'une victoire de Naka Fab et ben
on verra on verra demain écoutez on
Varou on fera un petit résumé de la
journée du jour sur la chaîne Youtube et
et on vous dit à demain à demain les
amis une demiheure plus tôt demain une
demiheure plus tôt 15h à demain les
amis